foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
hello and welcome to round eight of the
Tata steel chess tournament my name is
Fiona style Anthony and I'm delighted to
be joined once again by Grandmaster
Daniel narodeski Dania how are you today
Jonah good afternoon to you good morning
good afternoon to everybody I am doing
great so excited for another round of
Tata steel Fiona this is the midpoint of
the tournament and so much is going to
be decided in the next two or three
rounds the field is so tight and I can't
wait to jump into the action indeed
today is going to be a very exciting day
before we get to what awaits us let's
quickly check in with the results from
yesterday
unfortunately we had one game uh
finished by walk over Daniel dubov did
not show up for his game against Anish
kiwi it later became clear he was
awaiting uh the result of his PCR test
and was not willing to play with a mask
but the great news is for today Daniel
tested negative both in his PCR test and
the antigen test he took just an hour
ago so he will be back fantastic news
for everyone involved elsewhere we had
three decisive results Magnus beating
pregnant Karana beating Duda and Jordan
beating visit and Daniel that means that
after seven rounds we have a clear
leader at the top
yeah having a hard time pronouncing his
name
um this is a new is this his first
tournament lead I I'm not really used to
seeing him at the top of the tournament
standings but some dude named Magnus
Carlson an imposter has made his way to
the top he's got five points out of
seven closely followed by chakra uh the
hoodie Grandma we need to work that we
need to work the word hoodie into
something
can we pretend I never said that we need
the chat's help but uh he's got four and
a half out of seven and then there's a
big Peloton with four out of seven uh a
group of three and a half including
Fabian and caruana and Sergey karyakin
and that tells you how strong the
tournament is Sam Shanklin are on three
out of seven
that tells you who they are up against
but a very very tightly packed field
Fiona indeed a lot of these players can
still Harbor hopes for the the final
Victory we still have eight rounds uh no
sorry what am I saying six rounds
to go and but let's look at today's
matchup and I saw that Sam shankland he
actually posted on Facebook last night
uh he's very excited it's been three
years since he's faced off against uh
world champion Magnus Carlson so that's
one to look out for obviously the second
one as well mommy dearov against uh
Prague and as always I mean every
matchup uh promises some fighting and
exciting chess
indeed karyakin report you have some
Unstoppable object and immovable Force
kind of situation or removable object
Unstoppable for us however you want to
say it essentenko against Geary that's a
very high level matchup really all of
the games and I'm really interested of
course in Mama Dr of Prague because
shocker is going to be gunning to win
the game and hit uh five and a half out
of eight but Prague he's going to be
frustrated after yesterday's game can he
get it together and pull off at the very
least they draw with a black pieces
Magnus we'll be following that game
closely Fiona as well for sure and then
well another storyline is Fabiano
Carolina he beat yesterday Duda today
he's up against Huron van ferez to out
of his first seven rounds he's had six
decisive results as so I'm sure we can
expect some action there and I'm also
curious to see how we'll visit the early
tournament leader how will he recover
from the last year then he's playing
with the white pieces against Nils
Cornelius so I'm sure he will be looking
for the full plant as well
he absolutely will be and all of these
fires are so you know they're used to
having losses uh it's not a crisis for
anybody and a lot of these players have
showed tremendous resilience so far this
tournament as you've indicated including
Fabiano caruana yesterday so very
curious to see how things are going to
unfold if it's going to be anything like
yesterday uh Fiona it's going to be a
tremendously entertaining day for sure
and Dania maybe we can remove the
pairings for a second because I think
Daniel do both after uh forfeiting
yesterday he's here nice and early
already sitting at the board in the top
right corner there just behind pregnant
as a name we're gonna quickly show you
that so Daniel is with seven minutes to
go he is ready more than ready for his
battle against the young Kristoff do
that and Dania well we are looking
forward to the action here but our
viewers at home can also get involved in
the action can you tell us how do they
do it indeed and get into the action you
should don't forget to vote on the
result of today's games go to chess.com
events navigate to the tournament select
a game click vote and select your winner
you could win a piece of the one
thousand dollar prize pool for best
voters or free Diamond memberships
voting ends after the 10th move of each
game so don't miss out and remember to
vote on all the games chess.com events
jump into the action and don't
procrastinate it ends on the 10th move
absolutely get involved and we are gonna
go on a very short break but we'll be
just back in just a couple of minutes
with the start of round eight here so
don't go anywhere we'll see you soon
today
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
welcome back it is round eight here in
vacancy and we see Daniel dubov and
young Christoph Duda do that clearly not
afraid we saw our handshake as he
arrived at the board and Daniel dubov he
seems to be having a good time not seems
he doesn't seem too taken aback from the
forfeit yesterday Daniel
no he doesn't he seems I mean he's I'm
sure he's happy to be back at the chess
board uh and yeah he's got the white
pieces so uh could be worse of course he
should stop losing a painful game
instead it's a Fabby So Daniel is going
to be playing very ambitiously today
it's uh you know pretty safe bet when it
comes to do Bob and we saw there Niels
grendelius and ichigiri and Andre
asapenko waiting the signal the clocks
are going to be started any second and
pushing in his chair Fabiano caruana
awaiting Jordan then Forest yeah so it
looks like Jordan yet to arrive uh we
just saw a handshake there between Sega
karyakin and Richard report maybe
magnus's ways are starting to influence
his second Jordan
okay it's very fashionable you know
that's that's that's what the cool kids
are doing nowadays they're coming 40
seconds late
and there we see Prague arriving for his
game against Jack and Jack immediately
saying okay while you're here now just
start the clock already
timing yes and Fabiano also not losing
any time one E4 is on the board we see
Sam has arrived for his game against
Magnus carts and in the background the
lady with the the red hair very
noticeable you can follow her work her
name is Piers pong and she does some
great Digital Arts so she is doing a
digital uh painting of the the players
on an iPad we see play has gotten
underway but no sign of magnets just yet
surely he's gonna be here in a second
and I can only imagine from Sam's
perspective how difficult it is to
choose an opening against the world
champion I mean you're going through the
options nothing seems particularly
appealing I'm really curious to see what
Sam is going to put uh in front of the
world champion because Sam of course
very well known really across the world
by now uh for his uniquely dangerous
opening preparation and
he's going to try to make a serious push
for an advantage I think Magnum we might
see Magnus see something see Magnus play
something more offbeat from the start
I think that's entirely a possibility
Magnus is aware of Sam's Tendencies and
there it is there he saw Sam stand for
the handshake very respectful of course
of his opponent Magnus he had also
waited for Magnus to arrive before
starting the clock end well one D4 is on
the board here
indeed it is and
it took me a second to realize that
Magnus yes indeed he has two blacks in a
row
um and if he can pull off two wins in a
row that would be absolutely huge
indeed Magnus he hasn't won here in a
couple of years he loves this tournament
it is his 18th participation that's a
lot of his life spent here
18. 18 yeah oh my God that's crazy
and he's not even old he's like 31. come
on
and also the tournament is so uh so long
I mean the the event last Almost uh
three weeks like two and a half weeks so
that's yeah a lot of his life I think
someone had done the maps on how much
time Magnus has spent here but it is a
lot he loves this tournament and he is
very eager last year Jordan the standout
winner two years ago Fabiano with a huge
score of 10 out of 13. so Magnus he is
looking to write those wrongs wrongs in
his book anyway
I just like how cast is just adjusting
his pieces okay so I'll take two minutes
on the first move he is completely
unperturbed and just like against Prague
he goes D5 and let's see if he repeats
the Queen's Gambit declined he does now
Prague played Knight F3 in this position
Magnus responded by taking on C4 and
they transposed into a queen's gamut
accepted
Sam going Knight to C3
and oh
the tarash
variation with C5 Fiona that is
at this level
do you remember Magnus playing this
before like I think it's such a rare
guest uh indeed as you just said
it really is and I think the proper name
for it is the tarash defense I mean
there's a lot of tarash variations in
chess and this is one of them
I do not remember Magnus having played
this opening in recent memory uh now
what I will say about it it's named
after zebra tarash one of the strongest
19th century players he was a rival to
uh world champion steinits and nimsovich
and and he develops a lot of these uh
openings that have withstood the test of
time including the Taurus variation of
the French and C5 is a move that
immediately challenges the center and
Fiona it often leads to uh a an isolated
Queen Pawn structure generally speaking
white takes on D5 here the majority of
the time
and uh well I think Magnus by playing
the Terrace he has achieved maybe
exactly what he wanted which is getting
Sam out of at least his main preparation
for today's game as you said earlier
Magnus he has such a broad repertoire so
it's tough for some
um to prepare very deeply against
everything it's not just tough it's
impossible to to prepare against every
single possibility so from that point of
view would you say uh that's a good
choice by Magnus do you approve
yeah I mean I think the next three four
moves are going to be interesting
because in this position C takes D4 is
also a move
and something tells me and let's see yes
Magnus plays it and this is a really
really exciting line now the point is
that after Queen takes E4 black has this
move Knight C6 uh Fiona and you can't
touch the Knight and this is a
well-known Gambit it's been it's been
pretty well explored for for a long time
so Sam was aware of its existence the
point is that once the queen moves away
black plays he takes D5 and after Queen
takes D5 the Box certainly does not want
to trade the Queen's Black Goes Bishop
D7 and aims for a very very quick
development and a lead in development I
honestly do not know what the current
theoretical standing of this variation
is possibly neither it is Sam and the
last thing I'll say for now is that in
this position white also has the move
Queen A4 check inducing Bishop D7 so
that after Queen takes D4 you cannot
play Knight C6 because there's no longer
a standoff between the Queens so would
you say that the tyresh is an ambitious
Choice by Magnus
absolutely
absolutely I mean first of all this is
upon sacrifices Sam does indeed play
Queen A4 check
and let me again reiterate that Sam has
studied and analyzed this line at some
point in his recent chess career I think
what Magnus is banking on here is first
of all the fact that Sam did not review
this before the game because there was
no way of expecting it in the second
that uh you know that magnus's new
analysis with the most recent engines uh
can perhaps find uh New Paths and and
challenge Sam's old analysis even if he
remembers it so we'll have a very
interesting uh battle here some for now
has been playing quite quickly uh he
hasn't sunk into a deep think just yet
but as you say very likely he hasn't
reviewed this this morning but we talked
about roaches as being one way for you
guys to get involved today you can get
involved even more actively because we
have our online amateur tournaments
happening this afternoon yesterday was
the rapid but today if you're a fan of
Blitz or bullet then you can play the
first event starts in just 23 minutes
that will be a blitz event three plus
two is the time control it is free to
enter if you want to find out how just
go to the link at the bottom of the
picture there chess.com
Tata hyphen steel hyphen chest hyphen
tournament hyphen 2022 and in three
hours we will be playing some bullet one
plus one and uh one plus Nils sorry and
Dania no get that away from me get that
away from me
you must get that away from me
I can't I'm averting my I'm looking out
don't shoot the messenger this is of
course a picture courtesy of our
producer oh they could I have some major
I already have some major issues about
producer he's merely continuing to get
on my bad side
conversation is imminent and unpleasant
conversation indeed and while we are in
the words I view so so far we've only
looked at some shankland against Magnus
Carlson let's have a quick look at what
is happening elsewhere what is catching
your attention at first well first I'm
just checking the alignment between the
boards to make sure that it's the same
because I wouldn't put it past pick
but what is catching my eye that's a
great well a lot is catching my eye oh
my goodness so first of all
um we don't have to go there immediately
carwana against van Forest is entering
an extremely sharp line of the Ry Lopez
you know what let's go to that game
first and then I want to check out
vidit's game against Niels I also see
that if I'm not mistaken Richard report
has taken played the French so Robert
has he will be devastated that he missed
it
oh absolutely shout out to to Robert but
let's start with uh Fabiano against
Jordan
yeah so Fabian against Jordan was an
open Roy and what is that you might ask
well the open Roy is a variation where
black plays A6 Knight F6 and then Knight
takes E4 that is not the Berlin the
Berlin is when you take this Pawn
without having played A6 Bishop A4 uh
and the inclusion of these moves changes
the nature of the game entirely because
if so white plays D4 and now black has
this additional move B5 whereas in the
Berlin black drops the Knight back to D6
and attacks the bishop so B5 Bishop B3
D5 black gives the pawn back this is all
very very well known and after Bishop C5
uh Knight bd2 black goes for a an old
variation this has been around for a
long time castles Bishop C2 and Knight
takes F2 this is I believe called the
Dilworth variation I'm not sure who
exactly Dilworth was not necessarily a
famous player but what is the idea of
this move well after Rook takes F2 black
is not in a hurry to take on F2 that
pin's not going anywhere and black plays
the move F6 blasting open the king side
what black is saying is that yes I'm
giving up two pieces for a rook and from
a material standpoint that might not be
ideal but once I take the stroke nf2
White's King is going to be exposed for
essentially the foreseeable future and
with the f-file being open Black's gonna
have a long lasting attacking chances
this is a very theoretical line and uh
the main move here is he takes F6 but
and Daniel taking his time one thing
that's interesting we actually had this
variation the open Spanish on the verges
a few rounds ago that with Jordan being
on the white side against
a game he lost and I was just looking up
in that game Jordan with white pieces on
move nine he had not played as C3 but A4
so that's where that game deviated but
very interesting to see Jordan maybe get
inspired by Shakira's opening Choice
against himself just a few days ago
absolutely and this is already very
interesting Knight F1 is exceedingly
rare I only see three games in the
database but Jordan not surprised by
this move at all he responds Bishop
takes F2 and now he's going to play F
take C5 what's really interesting about
what Fabi just did there is that he does
not take on F6 he actually gives up
the E5 Pawn voluntarily and my guess is
that he's going to drop the king back to
G1 and this looks like a line which
prioritizes king safety over uh you know
over material
so which can buy you in here uh would
you rather have uh the material or the
safer King
um well I'm always a fan of two pieces
against a rook in the middle game
I I just feel like it's it's usually
easier to handle the two pieces so
material are safer King I guess
technically black has deleted material
because now black has two pawns
as soon as I asked my question I was
like
that the best way no but that's a
formality because I think in a middle
game context two pieces are still
supposed to be uh in most cases Superior
and a case in point is that white is
already threatening Bishop takes H7
followed by Knight G5 so I see five
games in the database now and they all
feature different moves there's E4 Queen
D6 Bishop G4 Queen F6 and queen D7 all
five of those moves have been tested and
E4 definitely being the most natural
among them
I I think this could just be a case of
both players uh being happy with what
they got Jordan cleared the one who
initiated this whole line so uh well
surely he must be happy and Fabiano
probably also uh I could picture him
being in the camp of being quite happy
with his two pieces for the working
ponds
indeed and Jordan kind of looking off to
the side I can guarantee that he has had
this position on his computer at some
point and he's just trying to remember
it the engine likes Bishop G4 in this
position which is one of the moves that
has been played so we will keep an eye
on on this game I'm very excited to see
how the next couple of moves are going
to unfold has Fabi succeeded in out
preparing uh the impeccably prepared
Jordan men forest and Daniel we're back
in the bird's eye view and I think the
next game we're gonna go to has got to
be visited against granddadius what on
Earth is going on there happening well
let's have a look at that game and let's
look at it from the beginning because
craziness started basically from move
three so Knight F3 G6 Knight bd2 now
this is still pretty normal uh this is a
system where essentially white wants to
play E4 so generally black plays D5 and
then often white places move B4 uh to
create a clamp on the queen side this is
standard fare it's been around for many
years but Neil's going Bishop G7 and
actually allowing a transposition to a
perk uh which is a little bit awkward
for white because of this Knight on D2
and and Niels I think has played the
perk in the past so castles and Vivid
pushing that pawn through to E5 and
what's interesting is that Niels decided
against playing the move uh D6 so he
tempted vetted into playing E5 and he
obliged and rather than 98 he's got
Knight H5 and again tempting with it
into G4 Knight comes out to F4 if it
goes Knight E4 and now I could not
predict a single move in this game you
would think Fiona that he moves this
Knight rongo D5 attack the Knight on e4
and I guess the point is that if White
had taken onpassan in this position
black just moves the Knight back to D5
and look at how exposed white skin King
is look at how weak the G4 Pawn is black
gets a big initiative here and the
engine agrees so vivid correctly
dropping his Knight back keeping the
center closed but after 96 Fiona an
incredible move
wow Knight of five Knight F5
sacrificing a whole piece but the point
is of course if black were to capture
the Knight after G takes well what do we
see the night on E6 simply has no
squares so that piece white is going to
get back what a tactic I mean I'm in
shock I'm just sitting here I feel with
my my mouth right I'm like what's going
on in this game what is surprising to me
and I'm curious what your thoughts are
done here maybe we can just get to the
current position after yeah C5 and
Knight takes take it out the bishop
what's surprising to me is that Neil
says the one who has been spending time
with um
with it clearly not too taken aback by
this transposition uh into what's more
of an E4 opening and uh with it being
the one blitzing out those moves I would
have expected that the surprise effect
would work the other way around
and what's even more amazing is that
there are two games in the database
I'm shocked but this line has been
played before incredible
and clearly but it knows about that and
I agree with you I would expect Niels to
somehow be more at home in these offbeat
wild opening variations but man is there
nothing there is nothing new Under the
Sun
um and just optically speaking this does
look very good for white I mean with the
fiance Bishop gone from G7 black is
going to have permanent weakness of his
dark squares the main weakness in
White's position of course is David has
committed to the move G4 he's weak in
the F4 Square the pawn on G4 itself is
of course a weakness and Niels in French
style is exerting pressure on the D4
Pawn so the key question is how to take
back on G7 you can make a case for both
musiana if you take with a knight well
you open up the attack on the G4 Pawn
but you relinquish some of the pressure
on D4 vice versa in the event of King
takes G7 the king is vulnerable but you
preserve the pressure on the D4 Pawn so
big decision early on for Nielsen I
would be terrified to Flying a position
like this with black for sure completely
agreed with you and uh well Nils maybe
he thought he was gonna spring a
surprise but very clearly so well
prepared and well what an exciting game
in store for us actually just before we
went here and can we bring up the bird's
eye view and just one more time because
from the corner of my eyes suddenly I
spotted another game which was looking
absolutely wild I don't know if that's
just going to Peter out but let's go to
yesi Panko and Anish giri
oh I think that's a I think they're
following
don't quote me on this I feel like
they're following a game from the U.S
championship between Fabi and Wesley so
but I I saw something very similar so
let's break down how this happened and
what what is going going on in this
position uh so this was in Italian like
all good things it started with a Juco
piano
okay so Mainline Italian and giri opting
for a very ambitious system he goes D5
of course black can play this with D6 or
you can play it with D5 okay takes takes
this is very theoretical and very very
sharp rookie one Bishop G4 Knight bd2
still lots of games in the database
Knight B6 H3 Bishop H5 Bishop B3 the
other move here is Bishop uh B5
Queen takes D3 and now Knight takes E5
now how this works is that you know
black takes widescreen and white takes
black screen and white has an advantage
in that end game basically Bishop takes
B3 a takes B3 white has nicely
centralized Knights and white Scott
White's got a pretty steady plus here so
uh Geary refraining from that instead he
drops the screen back to F5 now he's
hitting the F2 Pawn so you can't Fork
the queen of the bishop
moving his Knight back Gary bringing his
Rook to Y8 and now zapanka going G4 of
course this is a sacrifice not a blunder
Bishop takes G4 you take two pawns for
the piece and wise King is basically
wide openness in fact Googling King H1
and Knight E5 is I believe a novelty
according to the database now the idea
of Fiona is the deflight blindly grabs
the Knight
then okay then I think it's a draw I
think the point is Queen H3 check whoops
it's fat uh Knight takes C5 Queen H3
check
King G1 and at the very least black is a
Perpetual with the move Queen G3
so that's one of the lines is there a
way for white
um the question of course is first of
all does yes panko want to avoid at the
draw I think in general and again I'm
curious to hear your thoughts especially
as a competitive player yourself my
feeling is that very often the day
before the rest day tends to be a bit
more peaceful and I think that the round
four here which is uh the last day we
had before the first rest day I think
was the one with the least decisive
results with the most uh like uneventful
draws let's say and I think a lot of it
is down to the players not wanting to go
into the rest day on the back of a loss
so what are your thoughts and your
experience with this without without
question Fiona I agree with that there's
nothing worse than entering a rest day
having lost the game particularly having
lost to the white pieces so if I had to
predict I would predict that Andre takes
the 995 and that we have our first first
result of the game now the alternative
just to lay it out on the table is
Knight H2 you can drop the Knight back
and the king is relatively safe the
problem is that White's getting
checkmated on the next move it's just
that what black plays Queen G6 and you
know black has the threat of Knight D3
black has a lot of long-term
compensation for the piece and coupled
with the fact that Gary is clearly still
in his preparation you can kind of see a
wry smile there yeah I was gonna say
yeah I I think he's he's leaning toward
taking that Knight and in that way
taking the draw
I mean it wouldn't be a terrible result
for either player and he should be
getting a lot of rest days after not
playing yesterday today potentially a
quick and draw on the cards another rest
day coming up tomorrow he will be ready
for those last uh five rounds
oh he definitely will be and I just
wanted to point out one more thing about
this position after 1965 uh it may
appear that black has the move Queen H
fortune and that might look deadly right
black takes on F2 but it's a paper tiger
because white could just go King H3 and
black quickly runs out of checks
remember that white is now up two minor
pieces that is a lot and after Queen F5
Queen G4 blacks so-called initiative
evaporates so Gary will have to take the
draw after Knight takes E5
I saw a question in the chat and I'm I'm
gonna read it out from Dolphin hero Ken
Daniel gave us his opinion on early
draws is he so passionate as his and
before I pass it to dania and I think he
will be able to elaborate uh Robert it's
not early draws I think that he is so
passionate about I think its draw offers
when the game is getting to the height
of excitement but Danielle lets you
answer
yeah I mean I think anybody who's
watched sort of my stream or knows my
chess Lane tendency knows that in
general I'm not a fan of draws I've lost
a lot of games having taken unnecessary
risks at the same time I respect the
fact that sometimes the way that the
game unfolds right you know given the uh
the current state of opening Theory
there's inevitably going to be a just a
good amount of games that I'm in quick
draws and very often players have
considerations like being tired like not
wanting to lose before a rest day and I
think that has to be respected you know
for example I took a quick draw at the
last round of the US Championship I was
just exhausted you know and I didn't
want to end in a loss and I I feel like
that has to be honored as legitimate in
terms of draw offers when the game is
reaching the height of excitement I
agree completely I think that draw
offers in those kinds of situations can
result in you know tremendously
anti-climactic situation and a lot of
frustration for chest fans but I'm not
talking about a situation like this I
don't think Andre is under any
obligation let's say to go Knight H2 and
I don't think players uh should bear
that in mind I think they should make a
decision based on how they feel uh and
what they think is best but at the same
time I I agree that you know quick draw
offers and and draw offers to diffuse uh
tension in a very interesting position
should be frowned upon yeah so
um we will see
um we'll see what Andre comes up with if
he wants to play on and did we look at
Rook takes
E5
Rook takes E5 aha so I guess
after Rook takes E5
it's funny white has I mean white can
play Knight takes C5 and this is still a
Perpetual why does the cute Bishop takes
F7 check but unfortunately black is not
going to cooperate and after King h8 if
you decide all right I'm making the draw
now no you're not your queen is hanging
so it has to keep the bishop on B3
all right all right I'll give you the
draw now something to avoid yet so
basically what we think is if Andre is
happy to make a draw he will probably
take with the Knight and if he wants to
play he will go for night um age too
okay so we'll come back here we'll keep
an eye on it I will let ASAP panko make
his own decision and well then my eye is
going to the board next door
of I mean today there is things
happening everywhere there's an age for
Pawn in kariak and I guess that's more
theoretical but what is going on in my
media of pragnananda why are the players
not developing in their pieces why is
the equivalent so early done yet this is
not an opening uh like what do they say
I don't
what's what's the saying don't do this
at home or oh don't try this at all
don't try this at home well the first
move that really has not been tried at
home okay so this is in English C6 is
kind of a reverse allopin variation D4
e4s totally oh E4 is a little bit less
common than e takes D4 and Bishop B4
check but it it still is very well known
the move Queen A4 has only been played
two times and this is a prophylactic
move white is trying to discourage black
from uh from playing D5 the point is
that after C takes D5 uh black is unable
to recapture with a pod but Pratt going
D5 anyway and now going B5 chasing the
queen away and I think his point is that
he's insisting on being able to take on
D5 with a pawn is this preparation I
don't think so I mean proc has an hour
28 which means he spent 12 minutes and
my mediara now has an hour 30. so both
players might be out of preparation by
move five
perhaps for the first time this
tournament and I just wonder Fiona what
Prague is intending against Queen B3 uh
because I mean do you sacrifice the plot
and then here this is very awkward
because you can't really cover the check
on D7 or is frog intending to to play
Queen takes D5 which
I don't know something about this looks
a little bit off but it's interesting
yeah I mean queen D5 uh I'd rather
definitely play that don't give up upon
uh on on B5 answer I'm not entirely sure
because it looks weird after if we go
back to that line after Queen B3 Queen
takes D5 but I guess one of the problems
for White is you just don't have so many
uh pieces in the game yet and
um I don't know can you take on D5 and
play Knight C3 then how does black
defend the two pawns what is going on
there
yeah this is definitely a good option I
guess Mike has to play Bishop B4
and white can adopt several interesting
setups here I mean I think the
straightforward move here is Bishop D2
and that kind of forces black to give up
the bishop which frankly is not
particularly desirable I mean if you
look at these dark squares if white
plants a bishop on before that might
cause a lot of trouble in terms of
Black's coordination
uh and after Knight C6 white can play E3
with the nice detail that if black
pushes this Pawn down to B4 white
responsive Bishop B5 and then takes the
Knight and wins the pawn so
I think this is a this is how Madara
should play and he does play Queen B3
I'm very curious about this game here to
me it feels like Chuck said I am not
interested today in any theoretical uh
debate when this kid was born and I'm
saying this jokingly no disrespect meant
to pregnant and But Chuck was probably
already a world junior Champion one of
the top players in the world when Frank
was was born surfing uh what shakh is
saying okay let's just get this on to
some new territory here and and play
and this is very much up shocks alley
he's always likes these somewhat offbeat
openings but not openings that
necessarily violate you know tons of
principles although I guess both players
uh you know quote unquote violating
principles of development and what's
interesting is that Brock has just
played them with Knight F6 and that was
the top engine recommendation I was just
going to mention it something tells me
that perhaps even though he spent a good
amount of time maybe he did that to full
shock into believing that he's none of
his preparation this is not an easy move
to come up with Fiona if you're looking
at this position for the first time now
what is the idea what happens if I just
takes on C6 well I think the point is
that after Knight takes C6 this is a
garden variety uh sacrifice for a lead
in development Black's got two knights
develop Bishops coming out to E6 and if
you keep grabbing I mean just look at
this position white is going to get
toasted on the C file and on the queen
side
and so this definitely not a pawn I want
to take on B5 maybe instead can I play
E3 I defend my panel on D4 which I feel
is very important and attack the bishop
at the pawn on B5 with the bishop
and yeah
yeah I mean A6 and then I suppose you
can develop with Bishop G2 but now the
issue is all go Knight before Knight D3
so it's why it's kind of stuck in
molasses here and this Pawn on e4 gives
black this very very nice positional
blockade uh making it difficult for
white to develop uh properly
yeah and I don't know if shark will be
so happy about the speed at which Knight
F6 was played because that seems to
indicate that indeed maybe uh Prague is
still in somewhat familiar territory by
the way meanwhile Andre has played
Knight H2 so that game is going to go on
uh a little bit longer shall we go back
to the birds eye view and see what else
haven't we looked at uh just yet
absolutely yeah first of all night H2 by
Andre and you know even though I said
nobody should be blamed for taking a
draw in such a position we should
absolutely take our hats off for anybody
who decides to play on even though Andre
knows that Gary is still in his
preparation we will see if that very
gutsy decision pays off uh drawing your
attention to dubov against Duda that
seems to be the most uh symmetrical
slash mainstream position perhaps of the
day so far uh Fiona we have sort of a
Catalan structure we can get to that one
later but let's take a look at the
Sergey Kuryakyn game because I don't
think H4 is actually common
um and it's giving report pause yeah he
hasn't moved since we last stopped by
here so our first French of the
tournament but I believe Richard report
uh from him that's not a surprise right
he's played it before
he's played it before I mean he's
probably played every single available
move in the starting position and he has
reigned it in a little bit I mean there
was a stage in his chesker where he was
literally playing like A6 and G5 and all
sorts of crazy moves and it was working
for him uh but he's dialed it back just
a tad uh okay so playing the French and
Sergey going for the advance which by
the way Fiona is also not that common at
this level I mean normally we see Knight
C3 and uh less commonly but the Knight
D2 is still more popular than the
advance
and in this position Queen B6 is the
traditional way of playing but Knight G7
is one of the most reputable
Alternatives and in this position the
main move for white is Knight A3 and
Bishop D3 H4 has been played once
according to the database
[Music]
I mean what is it today I feel that
today is such a weird day we've got an
offbeat openings on almost every single
burden in a lot of them from very early
stages
and I think today really is epitomizing
the way that chess opening Fashions and
chess opening Styles have changed over
the last couple of years I mean if we
were commentating this tournament in
2005 this would be Unthinkable we would
have Mainline nighters we would have
maybe a grunfels we would have a [ __ ]
slav uh you know or Batman
wall a Berlin yeah and and even think
about five years ago tons of Berlin's
night orbs now we have all of these
offbeat openings and I think that's
tremendously exciting because the way
that I think the philosophy of the
opening has changed for a lot of players
is that they are no longer necessarily
trying to quote unquote win out of the
opening they are trying to get a an
offbeat position that they are more
comfortable with than their opponent and
also an offbeat position that's kind of
anti-computer in the sense that uh a lot
of players are trying to choose
positions with a type of Center or that
with a certain type of structure sure
that even the top computers have a hard
time properly evaluating from a
practical standpoint I think it's very
interesting what you are saying and I
think it's such welcome news and not
just for us as commentators but also for
us as as transfer just fans for you
probably as well as a chess player as
well and
um yeah it's been a very exciting
development and I am very much welcoming
that we have such a variety of of new
moves and new openings to look at rather
than just the same old and here well
after H4 he took quite a big thing and
decided on Knight F5 in the end
yeah which is which is totally normal
but he is provoking the move G4
and uh I guess his idea is to play
Knight H6 and he's claiming that white
is going to be
quite a bit overextended on on the
king's side although after Rook G1 you
also have to reckon with the fact that
the Knight is now fully excommunicated
from from the game so I have no idea
what to make of this position we'll
cross that bridge when we get there when
we get there and of course Sergey I I
don't really see too many Alternatives
because now if you revert to mainstream
Waters I guess you could play Bishop D3
and meet C takes D4 which takes F5 but
something tells me that Sergey might
combine I mean if you've already played
h4s the Russian expression goes having
said a you kind of have to say B and I
think way we can expect G4 well we'll
find out uh shortly but for now we're
going to take our first quick break of
the day uh but seven hugely exciting
games to look forward to today don't go
anywhere we'll be back very soon
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I think the first time I heard about the
tournament here was probably sometime in
1999 but the first tournament that I
actually followed was the one in in 2000
so I would say that's my like first firm
memory of the tournament here probably
my best memory from the village here uh
was the year that I I won and people of
bike on their song sang a nice little
song for for me I I really appreciated
that
I think there are people in my team who
are better than me at working with with
engines so I would say I'm not so good
at finding ideas with it so I generally
prefer thinking on my own
solving chess is way way out there and
frankly I hope that it won't be in a
very very long time
my goal for this tournament uh is to
have 13 days of good preparation
and a good mindset when coming to the
board hopefully I'll I can get back to
to my best after a couple of
let's say frustrating performances the
last couple of years
[Music]
hello and welcome back to round eight
here at the Tata steel chess tournament
and Dania what around it is shaping up
to be
indeed we have really interesting
openings all across the board we have a
great variety of moves of variation
variations we have gambits I mean what
what don't we have and uh one of the
most exciting games is that of the world
champion who is Black against Sam
shankland
and Magnus playing uh an opening it
started out as the tarash defense but it
transitioned into and we were talking uh
during the break the proper name for
this is the Vons Gambit is that
sounds about right you you said you were
familiar with it I had never never heard
of it so let's see uh that Gambit and
you can tell us Dania if it's any good
I think it's really interesting so Sam
did go for Queen A4 check as we
discussed inducing Bishop D7 now he
takes the pawn Magnus takes on D5
now he goes Knight F6 and basically the
point is that of course taking another
Pawn just like in the uh which which is
also featured a bunch of mommy yeah it's
just not a good idea and actually I
think the move here's Knight C6 and then
the Knight comes to D4 this is obviously
very dangerous so Sam going Queen B3
Magnus developing his Knight to A6 the
Knight heading for C5
and after Knight F3
the Knight swinging to C5 The Rook
coming to ca to x-ray white screen and
the position on the board uh is this one
Sam has just played the move E3 now of
course the engine in such cases almost
always prefers white and it's giving
white a pretty sizable Edge but if you
look at this from a practical standpoint
what does wax compensation consist of
well first of all black is really nice
piece development he's going to put his
Bishop on D6 he's got an x-ray down the
C file Fiona I mean there's ideas like
Knight A4 Knight E4 uh and Sam also has
issues with his dark squared Bishop
which is now going to remain kind of
Behind Bars uh for a while so I don't
have any doubt that white is probably
objectively better but this is exactly
what magnus's point is he is very
clearly playing for a win today and he
is making no qualms about it I mean he's
not hiding that fact with his opening
choice for sure and I mean we've seen
him I think lately taking more and more
liberties uh with his material and it's
been overall serving him well and
clearly Magnus he's out for blood if you
saw me smirking away from the corner of
my eye there's this chat meanwhile I
don't know Magnus was thinking hand in
in head in hand and it looks like the
not like this so chat always goes a
little little crazy but thankfully
Magnus has now adapted his thinking pose
yeah this is this is just classic Magnus
and he is deciding
I think between developing historic
spread Bishop to D6 and immediately
trying to exploit the C file pressure
with the move Knight C to E4 both of
these are feasible
yeah
um what do you think which would be the
move that would be tempting you the most
I would be more Tempted By by Bishop D6
just sort of keeping the tension and
well how is the game likely to unfold
here I think Sam is probably going to go
Bishop P2 we might have castles castles
and then maybe a a neutral uh developing
move such as Queen E7 kind of completing
completing blacks development and then
perhaps going for a6b5 it definitely
seems to me like Black's position uh is
is easier to play and that doesn't mean
black is better Magnus is about to make
a move and of course for me to say this
it's waiting for me to say this and he's
playing Knight C for the second
candidate you have to make me look that
nice don't you I'm sure it was a close
toss-up between the between the two I
have to say I am very curious to see how
this game unfolds because it's one of
the kind of positions where I've always
as a player a stronger to understand how
exactly do you create the compensation
here when everything looks symmetrical
it looks like white is going to be able
to Castle so I'm very curious I'm sure
Magnus will answer my questions for now
let's go back to the the bird's eye view
uh well in the asset panko against kiwi
the Queen's have come off maybe we can
quickly update that
yeah what an interesting I don't even
know what to call that end game
queenless middle game we have in the I
said panko gear game Andre of course
going for uh the win with Knight H2
uh Anish dropping the queen back to G6
and uh Bishop C2 Knight comes out to D3
essentially forcing the trade because
black threatens Checkmate okay so trade
on D3 Queen takes D3 Knight D to F3 and
Anish still with over an hour 40 on his
clock trading queens and taking that
third and final King Side Pawn
holy smokes I have no idea how to
evaluate this end game and probably
neither does essafenko I mean how do you
start uh evaluating this because I mean
it's so tough to judge if there were
less pieces on the board if we were
closer to a pure end game then maybe
they would be more General and more
General wisdom but here how do you start
evaluating uh what is stronger the tree
black king-site ponds or the white piece
yeah I mean I guess there's a couple of
questions that that you can ask yourself
to to clarify your understanding of the
position and I don't know what the
answers to those questions are but one
of the questions is who benefits in the
event of the trade of one pair of Brooks
who benefits in the event that both
Rooks are traded and probably my gut
instinct would be black I think if both
pairs of Brooks are off the board it
seems to me like Black's pawns are going
to uh start moving and knights are not
very good at stopping past funds I think
that white probably needs to keep the
Rooks on the board and I think that for
white it's absolutely crucial to develop
the rest of his pieces and to involve
everything as actively as possible so
for instance one way to play here would
be Bishop F4 I mean Anish probably will
go C6 and then this knight from H2 could
jump into the action with Knight G4 and
probably the position is closer to
Dynamic equality than it is to a big
Advantage for either side but the next
five seven moves Jonah are going to be
absolutely crucial they're really going
to set the tone for the rest of this end
game very interesting before we move on
one final question to you you talked
about the Rooks which you think white
should try and keep on the board does
that also count for the the minor pieces
or do you think white should be looking
to maybe trade Bishops or Knights or
should I try and keep as many pieces on
the board as possible that's a great
question that one I think is a lot less
clear and a lot more dependent on where
the trade occurs and under what
circumstances I think trading Bishops
would be an interesting idea although
that would only leave white with knights
and as I indicated
Knights are just aren't very good at
preventing the motion of past Pawns in
the long term so it might be an
interesting idea to trade uh one pair of
knights just so that black doesn't have
his Knight which can sometimes be used
as a support figure it can jump out to
C4 but man these determinations are are
so hard to make and you kind of see uh
sapenko very hard at work you're trying
to make heads or tails of this
incredibly complicated end game
absolutely and really kudos to him for
for not going for dearly a draw and
there but Anish well as he said he's up
a time from his clock so he has clearly
looked into this end game before and
well very interesting to see how things
unfold here
let's go back again there's one game we
haven't looked at yet that's duboff
against Duda if there is nothing that
catches your eye before that maybe we
should take a quick look there let's
have a look at it let's have a look at
it it does seem to be
hurtling
furiously toward a draw
but these types of positions can
actually be deceptive and if anybody has
a a slight little something then it's
it's definitely white also look at the
time situation Daniel has only spent a
couple of minutes and JKD is taking a
pretty sizable portion of his clock
should we go back to the beginning and
see how we got here
it was a Catalan
the price surprise I know never seen
that one before and C5 which is one of
the most reputable variations of the
Catalan and in this position white has
three main moves there's 95 there's Pawn
take C5 and uh do about going for a
third move which is Queen A4
okay so Bishop D7 Queen takes E4 and we
have a mass trade in the center C takes
D4 Knight takes D4 Rook C8 essentially
trying to trade on Black's own terms
which Duda does he takes on D4 he
develops with Tempo and then he puts the
other Bishop on C6 this is a very very
important move because it disarms the
Catalan Bishop which is uh the surest
path to equality do Bob obliges he
centralizes his Rook moves it away and
after Bishop B3 castles uh again duboff
trying to trade on his own terms and Yan
has just taken that Bishop on D4 if
you're under the position is very
symmetrical the likeliest result here in
the early going is a drop but I I do
think that white is a little something
something just because black is a tiny
bit cramped and after Rook takes D4
white has better control of the D file
and I think yawn will have to be
accurate for the next three four Moves
In order to avoid sinking a little bit
further into this slightly unpleasant
position yeah we'll see uh how much do
buff can get out of this I do that
probably happy to get to the rest day
with a solid draw with the black pieces
he hasn't had the best start to his
event
um so well we'll see I can do both make
something happen but definitely I think
the the most quiet and the most in the
balanced game we have today so let's not
dwell here too long I bring back the
birds live view and I'll let you choose
Anya where to go next
oh man there's so many interesting games
to explore
um I wish we could just like look at all
of them simultaneously but we'll get to
all of them let's have a look at how
uh the Vivid game has has changed
because we're now in a very unbalanced
end game in that game
uh we last looked at the position after
Knight takes G7 after a pretty long
thing Nils decided to take on G7 with
the Knight
vid at playing H3 defending the pawn on
G4 Niels takes on D4
and the way that the queen trade happens
is white plays Bishop H6 so wait not
rushing to take back this Pawn Neil's
throwing in a check and then it blocks
it with a screen we have a trade Knight
takes D2 Knight C6 F4 so why this
basically said I'm not worrying about
winning this Pawn back at all instead
white is focusing on creating a
intimidating Pawn Mass on the king side
I love what vidit is doing because Fiona
in the long run I don't think white has
to worry about the spawn why it's going
to win it back you know the knight's
gonna come to B3 and White's gonna
castle and black is very passive here I
mean Neil's probably has to push his F1
maybe F6 or F5 to create more space
but if anybody's playing for an
advantage here it does seem to be white
I think this one is such a big opening
Successful video so if we look at the
clock times but it has barely spent any
time and Neil's already down to an hour
and I'm loving uh with its position uh
as you said usually I'm a little
concerned when I give up a pawn here I
don't need to be worried even I can see
that black isn't gonna be able to hold
on to it
um and yeah just black so crammed
I agreed with you that probably F6 I5
will have to be played because I don't
really see any other Alternatives but it
it's also not really a move that we love
to make
no it's further weakening and okay so
ef6 if ef6 I think White's just gonna
castle and then play yeah I mean play
Knight B3 Knight takes D4 this bishop on
H6 is so nicely placed and I mean Niels
kind of had that type of arrangement
yesterday against Sergey
um he had the like night on where was
the Knight on H7 Bishop on G6 it was
something along along those lines and if
you play Rook takes F6 which uh the
engine suggests then again white can
still Castle long and if Black Goes Pawn
hunting with 96 uh White is the very
nice move Bishop G2
and this leads to a forest line Knight
takes up four we have a liquidation
takes takes takes captures captures
captures captures and uh White can just
take on C6 go rook hu1 and just look at
how terrible the pawn structure is the
knight's going to be three this is
already close to loss for black so
concerning very very concerning for
Niels yes
end game I think some me as you just
pointed out some immediate concerns for
Nils and even from from the camera it is
clear that Niels is is not happy uh with
how things have gone here and um
with it well he's bouncing back in the
best uh possible way at the moment he is
looking very focused and he will be
looking to get back on his winning ways
whenever I'm known sometimes on my
stream when I get tilted I I always say
that my opponent sees everything
um and the word vidit or veget in
Russian means he sees it's like a
conjugation of the verb to see
that's interesting I didn't know very
very good last name yeah for sure and
well what he's seeing here is a very
pleasant tourism position so I bet it
will be happy here let's move on Nils uh
he is thinking but he has some big
questions uh to answer here and read it
yeah we can say if there's a tactic does
he deceive it the tactic
okay if we are back anyways and yeah
anyways moving on swiftly
um
maybe we can check in with Fabiano and
and Jordan
I was thinking exactly the same thing
because that was a very interesting
variation and a rare move by Fabi uh and
in particular the rare move that we were
discussing
was Knight F1
uh so after F6 he goes night up when he
gives up the five pawn and we Fiona had
stopped at this moment the Jordan going
Queen D6 which was indeed one of the
moves uh which had been previously
played
and uh Fabi continuing his development
Bishop E3 Rook 88 Queen E1 another very
logical move getting the queen over to
the uh King's side Jordan responds by
disarming the light Square bishop and
offering a trade which Fabi accepts and
Fabi has gone Rook D1 this is the
position on the board
it's clear that neither side you know is
going to launch an immediate attack
against the opposing King I think the
battle has kind of transitioned to more
positional territory as white tries to
apply pressure on black center and
Jordan tries to do everything he can to
consolidate and to disarm uh these
Knights as much as he can let me ask you
are you highlighting the two Pawns in
the center and I think it's always such
a a difficult question to answer over
the board but how do you deal with the
tension in the center here as black at
which point do you want to push one of
the pawns if ever which Pawn how do you
determine that
yeah I mean you kind of have to manually
consider E4 and D4 on every move I feel
like e-force that comes to a really nice
well first of all E4 gives up this juicy
juicy Square on T4 but I also think that
white is the move Knight G3
counter-attacking The Rook but more
importantly if the Rook drops back you
can snap off this Pawn on e4 due to the
pin the move d4 is also premature I I
just don't see it working I mean D4 is
quite interesting actually but I feel
like so if I play CD4 and then Knight D4
this works out for black after Rook D5
but Fabby can just move the bishop away
from G5 we have a move and Jordan has
gone H6 and I think partially he made
this move in order to prevent Bishop G5
and he's thinking about breaking through
with D4 it might be time for Fabi to get
that Knight to G3 and kick this Rook
away from F5 so that it can't go to D5
at any moment
in a very interesting moment here so
you're saying D4 if we make a pass move
for white maybe we can take another look
at D4
yeah so but even here the engine seems
to
be a little bit cold toward this move
uh due to the move Bishop F2 and I guess
the point is that this E4 square is is
now a tremendous weakness and white can
occupy it either with the Knight or with
the queen so maybe it's still premature
maybe black should play more you know in
a more measured style move the Rook back
of Queen E6 uh make small improvements
to your position and ultimately uh
prepare something resembling essential
breakthrough but interesting so
basically what you're saying those
tensions in the center and the possible
Pawn pushers they just have to be
calculated basically at every turn by
both players
yeah virtually at every turn I mean you
know I don't see E4 or D4 being
particularly good in the next three or
four moves but that's also how blunders
happen you just kind of assume that I
will DeForest never going to be a
problem uh and you know the way that
these positions go things can change in
the span of a single half move like
white can make one little inaccuracy and
the landscape of the position can change
entirely so yeah you need to be testing
uh testing it basically on every move
very interesting done yet we are gonna
go on a short break in a minute but
first let me put you to the test if we
bring back the overview uh can you maybe
in a few in a couple of minutes tell us
what is happening in each of the games
and what are we looking forward to when
we come back after the break absolutely
let's start from the top left the world
champion Magnus Carlsen of the black
pieces he played uh a very very
interesting Gambit line he has
sacrificed upon for a long term uh
initiative
and uh we will see if that uh Gambit and
gamble pays off mommy Diary of Prague is
just a crazy position uh they're already
in New Territory but it may seem like
Prague uh has outprepared chakra so
we'll keep an eye on that one as well in
essepanco Geary uh Anish sacrificing a
piece on the king side offering a drug
via a Perpetual but yeah kind of
declining it opting instead for a very
unbalanced then again he's got a piece
for three pawns very unclear a French in
karyakan report Sergey playing in
advance they have opposite colored
Bishops and the situation has stabilized
quite a bit there Gujarati did it he's
got a pretty sizable advantage in the
end game after a very unorthodox opening
he's been a big Pawn mess he's got the
two Bishops great position Fab event for
us we were just looking at that it's a
situation of two pieces for rook and two
pawns uh a battle over the center Ken
Jordan preserve his superiority in the
center or will Fabi uh get the upper
hand by attacking that center with his
minor pieces and finally in dubov
against Duda it's a very very balanced
Catalan Jana Kristoff should be able to
make a drop but he's gonna have to make
a couple of careful moves he's got a
little bit of an unpleasant position
that was really impressive and well as
you've just heard plenty to look forward
to when we come back during the break I
would produce a big will be checking in
with the challenges uh letting you in on
what's happening there so don't go
anywhere we'll see you shortly
foreign
yes welcome everyone to check in with
the challenges my name is baltobik I'm
the Esports producer for chess.com and
also the producer here in waikansei and
today we're checking in with the
challengers again each day we're
checking in with them because next to
the master section we also have the
Challenger section and the winner of
that section will be facing in the
masters section next year at Tata steel
2023 so there's a lot to play for less
time on Mike was bad so I'm looking at
you chat we we do we do take these
things seriously I try to improve on
that so let's see if we can also improve
on the games that we can show and today
I'm proving by picking Daniel Darna
against Gene Zoo they were playing each
other in round number seven and boy was
it a miniature uh we're one of them
we're going to show that right now after
the move G4 this is only 13 moves into
the game we're not that deep yet we had
B4 and look at this Knight
it went to E2
after A5 it jumped to D4
and after a short Castle it jumped to B5
this Knight is dancing around like I'm
kind of dancing usually when I dance I
dance like an unattended garden hose so
you don't want to see that in public but
this night took quite the route 2b5
which was
a blunder according to the engine
because after Bishop takes B5 Bishop
takes the pawns start rushing down you
can see him going it's like there's a
Black Friday sale in the dollar store
and these guys are going absolutely ham
and this is actually not uh the best
team wage and what is the best
continuation that's actually a funny
line after Kingdom B1
A4 is actually the incredible move
C4 in this position now it seems very
odd that you push that pawn up
everybody's probably screaming on
percent already you can take care of one
C3 we're going to talk about that in a
bit uh but C4 is the best move why if
you play A3
we play B3 and you're perfectly locked
in there's no way for black to pull
through all the way around you play B3
we play A3 again there's nothing going
on for right we are actually in a very
good position here so what happens if we
go on poisson
great question we actually take here on
C3 and now we have this A2 Pawn which is
a very important Pawn in the scatter
structures well defended with the Knight
and the King if you push this Pawn we
actually don't care we're just gonna
move back if you try to take it
this is where we go Knight B5 pulling a
lot of pressure on this pawn and as you
can see the king hasn't castled yet so
you cannot just take
we will take with check we're gonna have
to go outside of your way and now we can
start hammering down in the center and
white is actually a lot better so C4
would have been the perfect move here uh
apologies after King B1
a4c for the only line that we didn't
look at right now is Queen takes C4 but
this is a very interesting one you can
already push through with E5 you cannot
capture because
we see the battery we take this Knight
we take the bishop back and we end your
chest cover here with Queen takes D7
probably not that but it does look
sounds very menacing at least we have
that going so E5 is a very strong move
here obviously you also cannot move the
Knight anywhere let's go Knight dude
Knight to D5 which looks like a very
obvious move we will just take these
these take on D6 with the Knight of the
queen uh we can start hammering down in
the center as well let's just go with
the queen here and
very very big nuisance now what happened
in the game
was like I said this this night was
prancing and dancing around
like it was Woodstock and after A4 King
B1 we're going to see the issue here uh
B3 was actually the best move here was
that Plato was such a huge oversight by
the white player Bishop to E3 and this
is where the fun begins for black we
take on B2 with the pawn
and after we take here
finally up D5 for attacking the queen
these Rooks are coming in facing the
king and after Queen lead to Rook B8 the
queen goes to E2 to defend and here
comes the final nail in the cafe
coughing is like a playing Pokemon again
the coffin I do know how to pronounce
English even though by a terrible accent
you wouldn't say so Rook takes A2 and
it's absolutely over
what happens if we take an excellent
question
we give a check if you go back
it's a sharkbot
and if you take the pawn here there's
actually a very cute little scenario
here where you go Bishop A3 check
if you go
where are we going to go let's go to A2
you give another check
you give another check
and this is where the fund is going to
end the queen is going to come in and it
is a forced mate so A beautiful sequence
there Rook takes A2 and it's all over
the best move for white here uh is
actually I believe C4 trying to make
some room uh in this position but as you
can see we are just going to hammer down
on the position we can already take this
bishop as it is but we can also play
Rook A8 and make sure that this Pawn is
actually going to promote Bishops coming
in and it's going to be all over so A
beautiful miniature by Daniel Darda who
had played two games before this both
going in the 140 move so he's probably
very happy to have won this game very
very soon team gets a half a rest day as
they would say he's home early and uh
that's the game wow that's I don't know
that was really cool I like these small
miniature these aggressive style attacks
and the challengers are going very
strong let me quickly pop up the
standings here I should have checked it
but I didn't and it's probably no uh
it's probably no
surprise that Arjun Air Guys is still at
the top uh but there are someone in the
engagement is in the leads in the
chasing pack with Five Points so
anything can still happen in the
Challenger section I've spoken enough
you guys want to go back to the master
section we're just gonna write through
that let me bring it back to Fiona and
Daniel
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to round eight big thank
you so much for the check-in with the
Challenger is always good to keep track
of what's happening there as well but
Dania our main focus is of course the
master section where today I thought we
might have a quieter day before the rest
day but at the moment the players are
certainly proving me wrong
indeed all signs Fiona are pointing to I
mean already we have very interesting
positions in virtually all of the games
we have a very wide variety of different
openings uh of course it's impossible to
predict what the results are going to be
but the players definitely feeling very
ambitious going into uh going into the
rest day as we look at our bird's eye
view here we just see all sorts of
positions on the board we have gambits
we have catalans we have French uh we
have an unnamed opening and vidded
against grendelius and this is this is
so much fun
yes for sure and well maybe the first
position that I'm curious about to do a
more Deep dive is
against pragnananda we left that off a
while ago and some things have been
happening
my goodness in this position is
going on here I mean there's it's like
the pieces are splattered all over the
board and there seems to be very little
Rhyme or Reason behind why they are
where they are so let's have a look at
what happened now you'll recall that uh
in this position Prague when B5 and the
Knight F6 we suspected that you might
still be in this preparation chakra
ended up going Bishop G5 so he didn't
take on C6 Prague checking on A5 the
Knight blocking on C3 B4 okay that makes
sense chasing the Knight away so that
black can take on D5 with a knight and
now Bishop H3 by mamad yarov and this is
given Prague quite a bit of pause so the
point is that in the event of a trade
this knight from H3 is going to come to
F4 and it's going to contest uh prague's
best place piece which is the night on
on T5 and you know black and go Knight
D7 here but also you have to bear in
mind that this prawn on C6 is a pretty
serious weakness Fiona this could end up
quite shaky for black
yeah so after Bishop H3 how do we as
black try and uh maintain the knights
um
so the the engine actually suggests
keeping the bishop and see it alive with
the move Knight D7
but the concerning thing for me is this
move F3
and after e takes F3 white actually
doesn't have to take back well I can go
E4
with massive complications I mean Knight
F6 and now the bishop on G5 is hanging
so we could have a trade on F6 and then
another trade on C8
and after Knight takes F3 a again very
very unbalanced uh position that the
engine assesses as equal
that's in the position where you took in
the position where you took on F6 just a
couple of moves ago here in this line I
guess we could not have taken on F3
because the pawn was simply hanging in
so amazingly the reason I also thought
it was 1964 but Knight takes E4
walks into Queen E3 with very very nasty
pin here this force is F5 and that's
very weakening no the move is insane
it's Knight C5
and after tc5 Bishop takes H3 white has
given up a very valuable light squared
bishop and White's position starts to
collapse whoa
this game is a little too messy almost I
mean the pieces are absolutely
everywhere so once again it reminds me a
little bit of a chess 960 game rather
than normal chance because it just feels
like there's pieces everywhere I'm not
sure where they've come from what
they're doing but
um I'm sure shark will be right at home
in this and well Prague he's also been
very impressive in how he's dealt with
things so far would you rather play
white or black in the current position
on the board then I'd actually rather be
white I mean I changed my mind at first
I thought okay this Knight on D5 is very
strong but then I kind of realized that
black has more static weaknesses Black's
Pawn structure is not very healthy uh
there's a backer Pawn on C6 this Pawn on
e4 can also be targeted and as you as
you said Fiona I think chakra R is
feeling great right now because you know
he has always distinguished himself as
someone who is able to successfully
navigate you know not just complex
positions but I would even call them
chaotic or irrational positions he is
like a fish in water in these cases so
right now the ball is in prox court and
he needs to be very precise you know on
this move and and on the next couple of
moves yeah big fight ahead here we see
be Prague at the board Shakira currently
away
plenty to figure out I think he will
take some time so that gives us the time
to go back to to the overview and see
what's happening
elsewhere I see that that French has
changed quite a bit between kayak and
and report I see Niels has decided to
play F6 which we thought he probably
should and what else
yeah Andre asapanko did indeed Play
Bishop F4 getting that Bishop out from
C1 and
do Bob's game Jan has just made a very
accurate move you can see he played
rookie a threatening a fork with E5 and
and forcing duboff to compromise his
peace activity just a little bit so my
guess is that that's game that game is
hurtling uh quite rapidly toward toward
a peaceful result but we can definitely
look at karyakan report and see how
that's transformed and then who's favor
yeah let's go there
a very exciting position first thing I
noticed I'm always a little bit
surprised when H4 has been played and
then white suddenly castles
yeah and you know that's another that's
like a classic symbol of modern chess
this would be Unthinkable in Kappa
Blanca's time for example and we will
remind everybody that her yakim played
H4 and I was wrong I was pretty pretty
sure that he would go G4 maybe he should
have gone G4 but Sergey going for the
more conventional approach Bishop D3
Bishop takes F5 and this particular
structure is very typical for the
advanced French uh where black plants
the bishop on E6 it blockades the pawn
and although this bishop is not good in
and of itself Black's position is
tremendously solid it's very very hard
to access uh Black's position he has no
targets and then report decided to trade
the other Bishop for sergey's Knight
okay that's interesting and expanding on
the queen side with A5 and this is where
Sergey deciding to Castle in spite of
playing H4 guess what rehard immediately
goes H6 and he absolutely wanted to play
G5 which is why Sergey went windy too
Queen E7 and A4 the position on the
board is this one
I have a few questions here
um if I'm black ideally I don't want a
cast on kingside what I want to do is
get G5 in and get my king out of the way
get the other Rook to G8 and try and
crash through on the king side how
realistic is my dream Dania
oh I mean you're talking to the wrong
wrong person I have a very bad influence
in that regard I'm totally contemplating
Rook G8 in this position
uh but you could end up in a you know a
kind of Duda situation from yesterday
where you burn all of your Bridges and
before you know it your king is kind of
stranded so uh well what I can try to do
is prepare his own Pond break and white
can go rook fb1 and then you have a
fascinating case of opposite side
attacking G5 B4 and one issue with
Black's attack is that it's very very
difficult to play G4 I mean it's not a
good idea to play G4 because look at
these dark squares look at how much how
weak they are and if white controls the
dark squares white disarms the attack
and I think rehard decided
it's not worth it yeah even if you take
the part of nature because I'll go G3
and then I'll lead this knight from G2
to F4 yeah and it's going to be very
hard for black to make further progress
and rehart has castles
it has
I mean I get it but
fb1
Sergey still orienting himself toward
the queen side attack with B4 now that
all my dreams have been
um
they've been squashed they've been yes
they are trampled with feet unacceptable
so what is my as black what is the new
plan now that G5 is out of the picture
for now uh do we want to get upon
breaking on the the queen side is black
ever going to look for B5 himself or is
he just going to try and face White's
plans
yeah there's a couple of ways to
approach this
um black would love to play B5 but if
black does the same thing
um Sergey beats him to the punch it's as
simple as that white just gets before
and first and if black insists on B5 uh
this doesn't work out I mean takes takes
and then simply B takes A5 The Rook is
hanging and after Rook takes B1 Rook
takes B1 the pawn cannot be recaptured
so concretely this doesn't work out for
black and that means that I think
black's time is better used in a
prophylactic manner I think what black
needs to say is okay
Sergey is going to go before anyway I
need to prepare myself for it there's a
couple of ways you can do that you can
play the move B6 taking some of the
sting out of B4 and using this
opportunity now to get the Rook to C8 I
think that the position is much closer
to equality than to any advantage for
white but this is an important moment
for rehart to tighten the screws a
little bit and make sure that B4 doesn't
come with with great effect and Danny
there was a question uh in the chat for
Mr goat what is the difference between
Rook F to B1 and Rook a to B1
that's a great question and it's always
an important question to ask in this
case I think the the answer was pretty
straightforward when you play Rook a to
B1 anytime you play B4 subsequently
you're gonna have problems with your A4
Pawn now the engine lights for a kb1 as
well because the thing is let's say B6
happens and then white plays before
um after a takes before Bishop takes
before Knight takes before Rook takes
before The Rook actually does protect
the A4 Pawn but I think Sergey just
wanted to make sure that he never
experiences problems with that pawn I
really think that's the only
consideration
um
they work on the f file at the moment
wasn't doing anything there and it's
hard to see maybe on the C file there
could have been something but uh yeah
the a pawn being the main consideration
here so we'll come back to this one I
think things will start happening soon
for now
um well we can bring back the bird's eye
view for a second second and I think at
some point soon we can check back in
with a certain Magnus Carlson Maybe
I think we should I I think there have
been some really interesting
developments
so let's see what those developments
were and Magnus has it appears reclaimed
the sacrificed one very interesting so
let's rewind a couple of moves we left
this not too long ago when Magnus went
Knight to E4
right and now Sam deciding to prioritize
kingside development Bishop T3 Magnus
chopping the Knight and then going after
the pawn with Knight D5 so Magnus
delaying his own development and instead
uh going right after White's C3 Pawn Sam
says be my guest take it Magnus says you
know what I will and this is the
position on the board
wow and I saw in the chat that some
people are concerned of course there's a
lot of Magnus fans in the chat and maybe
they saw the eval bar go up a little bit
I don't know what it is and does Magnus
have reason to be concerned here do you
think he's happy
well it's hard to say and I think Sam
should probably start with a move Bishop
B2 notice that there are no dangerous
discoveries along the C file if you play
Knight takes A2 that's not going to turn
out well I mean just look at Black's
King it's going to be kind of the
crossfire here so in this position
Magnus is best advised to play Bishop B4
and maintain that Knight on C3 no I
think and this is just a very complex
position Sam has some issues with his
Queen placement
um because if you play Queen B3 here
Magnus supports the Knight with A5 and
guess what a very cool line if white
plays A3 Bishop A4 and the queen is
literally trapped that's pretty crazy
line so I love the sound effects
well you know it has to be sufficient
sufficiently illustrative of what
happens between the straps it's taken
away from you so amazingly the engine
suggests drum roll please wait for it
unbelievable move I don't think Sam's
playing that he is about to make a move
I didn't even notice that pawn hanging
there in the corner like my eye I didn't
either oh I mean how often do you take
that Bond like one time out of a hundred
uh in a situation where black hasn't
castled yet okay Sam plays Bishop B2 I
think we'll see this on the board
I think we are likely to see this this
position on the board Magnus Magnus can
move his Knight back but that's a huge
concession Fiona because that gives the
bishop just a monster diagonal the
things are really heating up here and
getting uh more and more concrete I
think Sam probably has got to be happy I
mean he said he was so looking forward
to his match against Magnus Carson and
he's got himself a big fight which is
certainly what he was hoping for
yeah absolutely Sam likes concrete
positions he loves complex positions uh
positions that are heavy on calculation
he believes that his ability to
calculate these types of positions out
is uh you know is is he's one of the
best in the world at it and yeah he's
not delusional he's right he's got the
rating and the results to back it up
um I think he is excited about having
this kind of position against Magnus now
another possibility after Bishop before
um white can go Queen B3 A5 and then if
he wants he can take this Knight on C3
this doesn't this is not out of the
question Rook takes C3 is a fork but the
queen can drop to D5 and obviously
protect the bishop it looks the thing is
precarious now
it does but but here white has the move
Queen E5 check and if you cover the
check with a queen You're Gonna Lose the
pawn on G7 so black will be forced to to
move the king to f8 White can go Bishop
E4 it is extremely precarious but I
think this is where Sam excels I think
he's not afraid uh to walk on hot coals
so to speak if he believes in his
calculation
and he could just well Magnus he rarely
loses uh any games but who knows Sam he
will be very eager he had a big win in
Vikings a few years back uh beating
kramnik in his last uh competitive game
in classical jazz and he will be looking
for another big scalp today we can see
him there working hard at the board
there's so much to calculate but he is
hyper focused a very exciting game we'll
come back here very shortly yeah you're
you're right on the money Sam doesn't
really play for draws and he knows that
if you beat Magnus Carlson once in a
classical game that's an achievement you
can look back on for the rest of your
life as as one should
and he'll be working at this opportunity
yeah for sure uh we see Jordan there
looking a little bit perplexed on the
live uh camera his game hasn't changed
too much for now he's dropped the Rook
back uh elsewhere
oh we had a trade in this is interesting
I said panko Geary did indeed trade
Bishops
let's go back there let's update uh that
game
yeah let's see how that how that has
impacted uh the State of Affairs on the
board so Andre in in the position we
were looking at here played Bishop F4 C6
and I had mentioned Knight G4 as a
possibility he goes Rook D2 uh inviting
a trade of Bishops which Onish accepts
Bishop B3 takes takes
and again I I sort of thought that the
trade of Bishops doesn't necessarily
favor either side it's hard to say
uh what can we expect here from Andre
well Rook ad1 is is very tempting here
and then probably Anish will go Rook ae8
you know Fiona I'm a little bit worried
about white White's position here
because once these pawns start rolling
things get hairy pretty darn fast I was
thinking about this last time we left it
off especially for Andreas the Penco
it's always tough you always have this
thought at the back of your mind I could
have made a draw here a long time ago if
I wanted it and could have been back in
the room or having a walk on the beach
you know looking forward to rest day and
well now that pawn mass is gonna start
moving at some point one question that I
one thing I was wondering about uh can
we somehow as white start putting
pressure immediately is there something
to be said for bringing a rook to the G
file maybe to the file and just trying
putting some pressure on these pawns or
will that not lead anyway
absolutely it should be considered I
mean I think the point of doubling
Brooks could be to induce the move G6
well why is that good for white well it
you know black now has to deal with the
weakness of the F6 and H6 squares
unfortunately I'm just not sure how to
exploit that and this is where White's
passive Pieces come into play because
you can't play Knight G4
you have to burn a Tempo to move the
other Knight out of the way
uh but now black can just ignore
everything and go Knight C4 after a
knight G4 it looks like Black's
blundered because White's threatening a
fork but no Rook H3 check and after for
example Rook H2 we have a trade and I
think black can disarm whites initiative
with the move
uh King G7 defending the F6 Square so
it's an interesting idea but and maybe
Andre is trying to make it work he's not
a 42 minutes and in a position this
complex that is not a lot of time no
indeed um unused here displaying some
nice preparation also I think a nice
psychological Choice by Anish who he got
a free point yesterday today no question
about it he probably would have been
happy with a quick draw with the the
black pieces and when he plays that line
well the owners is all on yassi panko to
make the big decision for the two of
them is it gonna be a quick draw will
they play and I think sometimes
um it's almost like a little gamble
where you're asking your opponent well
what are you gonna do are you just gonna
call it a draw without trying with the
white pieces and do you sometimes feel
in that spot There is almost a little
bit of pressure on the white player to
be like no I I sort of have to play I'm
I have to write pieces after all oh
absolutely and I think openings like the
Berlin also inherently contain that
pressure because first of all white does
have a horse draw and white has you know
white can play rookie one in the Berlin
and essentially get a risk-free position
that you're also probably not going to
win
um but but this type of way this way of
playing it is very very effective
because uh you know anybody's gonna be
torn drawing any scary is it's not a bad
result and as you said Andre is probably
thinking I could be in the warm uh
heated hotel room watching a nice movie
under the covers and watching the rest
of the games he's a big football fan as
well I think it's a premier league today
yesterday he pretty much ran off from
the into uh from the interview so could
be thinking about that as well could be
watching Allison I think he's actually
an Arsenal fan I was just looking
Arsenal Arsenal's match ditches start
half an hour ago so maybe that's
something else that's on his mind right
now
yeah I could have been watching I could
have cut the whole game uh but no I had
to go for the win and now I'm I'm
suffering in an end game I don't think
he's suffering I don't think white is
worse and the engine is giving uh
equality which which makes sense I mean
uh these positions tend to be quite
balanced but Andre I mean he he has to
be very very cautious the next couple of
moves maybe Knight D4 uh is the right
approach or trying to swing the Knight
over to F5 kind of like your idea
attacking what's kingside before the
pawns get rolling I don't know
yeah well he has his work cut out for
him uh I don't think he'll be watching
any football today this isn't gonna end
anytime soon at this point
um meanwhile
elsewhere where should we uh maybe
update
well first of all I'll point out two
things in the karyakan report game
they're heading down the line we
discussed recap C8 B4 B6 so report
keeping the tension on that Queen side
Carlson did indeed uh respond with
Bishop B4
and yeah dubov versus Duda continues to
look more and more symmetrical there are
some up developments in The carwana
Forest game let's go there then
let's do it and Andre does go Knight D4
by the way okay
oh this might actually be a repetition I
want to say so let's see we we joined
the game
we last looked around this moment Jordan
played H6 right
um Fabi responds with Bishop F2 clearing
away space for the night Jordan dropping
The Rook back prophylaxis against Knight
E3 Fabi going Bishop G3 and the check on
C5 and the word petition you just
mentioning I guess means that Fabiano
could play Bishop F2
um with Jordan dropping back the queen
to D6 so that's a possible repetition
now the question is Fabiano with white
piece is going into the game of course
would never have agreed to an early
repetition but here what are the
Alternatives if not Bishop F2
well first of all you're Contracting H1
but here I think Jordan will play D4 I
think he's going to push that pawn and
his pieces are very nicely positioned uh
to support not only this Pawn but also
the C7 Pawn which is going to be
defended by The Rook after a trade
and see the thing is why does a hard
time exploiting the weakness on e4 if
you if you just stick a queen there
that's not really going to cut it
Black's gonna play D takes C3 and why is
that dangerous well after Rook takes d8
Knight takes d8 bc3 Queen C3 Black's
taking another Pawn look at black
superiority on the queen side black also
has f file pressure this is not very
appetizing
um so I'm not too enthralled with this
option I think fabby's going to repeat
once and I think that the big decision
is going to be whether uh to play Bishop
G3 on the next move my guess if I had to
predict is going to be that we're going
to see a repetition by the way Jordan
can play D4 even here not out of the
questions but I think Fabi might choose
a different move here such as 93. well
very I'm very curious to find out what
happens here does the game go on uh does
Fabi go for the repetition does Jordan
go for the repetition we will find out
after the break we're gonna take a quick
breather but don't go anywhere very
exciting round I will be back very
shortly
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
hello and welcome back to round eight at
the Tata steel chess tournament a
tremendously exciting day ahead of
tomorrow's rest day Dania there is maybe
a couple of games where we think they
might end peacefully but elsewhere
there's so much going on
yeah well again dubov uh against Duda is
rapidly hurtling toward the draw I mean
you see Knight T5 there that's there's
gonna be a trade of knights and there's
very likely going to be a draw for uh
shortly so that's really the only game
that's on the cusp of ending
um as for the other games I mean I
mentioned just the Karana van Forest
right where we were thinking they
repeated once yeah they repeated once
hopefully not more than not more than
twice but we will see
yeah we'll see I mean Fabi has a pretty
big choice to make of course he doesn't
want to over press uh and and that's
always a difficult decision to make he's
on 50 so my gut instinct would be that
he he's probably going to play I mean he
he needs to take a lot of risks if if he
wants to finish uh closer to the top of
the tournament standings and white
against Ben Forrest is a game that he
really has to try to win so we'll see uh
whether Fabby goes for it we also have a
couple of developments in the Sergey
karyakin game shall we go to that one
because in the other games I think
they're still uh take you know they're
basically at moments where we looked
let's go to kariakyan and immediately
the first thing we notice is some
pressure on that pawn on A5
yep Rook swinging out to B5 attacking
the pawn so just to remind everybody in
this situation a report I think he
played correctly Rick fc8 before and now
just B6 keeping the tension Sergey
deciding to release the tension B takes
A5 Bishop takes A5 and Rook B5 so
um I think black has to defend the plot
and he probably has to do it with the
move Queen A7
when okay Sergey is going to be likely
to go Rook B1 doubling on the B file
maybe preparing Rook B7 and the engine
is giving an interesting move Queen A6
prophylaxis what is it prophylaxis
against well it kind of immobilizes The
Rook because if the Rook moves up the
queen swings to C4 and that gives black
unnecessary activity
uh so this reaches kind of a weird
standoff where black also kind of wants
to play Rook C4 I think the position is
quite balanced it looks good for white
but a free heart is careful I think you
shouldn't have any problems here yeah so
it looks like he has nicely neutralized
we didn't get the pawn storm we were
hoping for early on with a G5 he had
taken a more solid approach but it looks
like things are under control here for
him at the moment so let's go let's go
back again maybe we can quickly check in
actually with duboff and do that
and see uh the Pieces come off there
maybe we'll even catch a handshake who
knows
we are likely to catch a handshake now
um what happened here I I think Duda
made a very accurate move uh in this
position let's rewind five or six moves
rookie eight I mentioned it he's
preparing E5 and this kind of forces
dubov to initiate further trades okay so
he trades on D6 now Duda reclaims uh the
D file while this a lot of words
uh then he makes some lufts and then he
goes Queen C6 and A6 and Knight D5
forcing the nitrate uh completely
symmetrical position no weaknesses for
either side and you can kind of see I
think dubuff looking up at his opponent
you know those wordless exchanges often
mean we're about to see a handshake I
think the simplest for black is to play
Queen D2 this forces a queen train in
fact I'm quite confident that we're
gonna see this queen takes D2 Rook takes
D2 and now it looks like white loose is
a pawn but no he doesn't you can give a
check and basically do the same thing
that black is doing Works C7 and you
know basically Mass liquidation is is
inevitable takes takes takes
uh something like this is likely to
happen and around this point I think a
draw will be very likely yeah and I
think you're absolutely correct when uh
dubov made his last move B3 we sort of
saw him look up at Duda which very often
is a sign of a peaceful outcome to
follow shortly uh for now Duda is still
thinking so we'll move on from here but
yeah very likely uh this game will end
peacefully soon
um maybe we can well not much has
happened in shankland against Carlson
but the players are starting to spend a
lot of time
um yeah Sam is yeah Sam is taking a long
time after Bishop before which we kind
of anticipated because uh his Queen
doesn't have any clear spots to go to we
were discussing Queen b3a5 and Duda just
made a move by the way and it is it
Queen D2 it is Queen D2 it is Queen yeah
maybe we couldn't go back to visit
against grandel's
let's do it yeah there have been a
couple of moves in that game
okay so F6 he takes F6 now Neil's
deciding to take with a pawn there's
really no appealing option here
and visited castling long so to remind
everybody the idea I think for white is
to ultimately reclaim this Pawn uh by
Swing swinging the Knight to F3 or to B3
black would love to meet that with
Knight E6 but it's not easy to do I mean
I guess black could try to go rookie
eight
but after Knight B3
96 white ghost Bishop G2 and now he hits
him where it hurts on the D5 Pawn
Black's position just starts to crumble
here
I mean it looks so tough for Niels who's
also lagging behind on the clock only 45
minutes already we're only on move 17.
is there any way that black can look for
some
active counter play Maybe on the queen
side
that's a good question I mean
like could I suppose try something like
A5 but I'm not entirely sure where it
leads I think that rookie 8 is probably
a reasonable way to start controlling
the e-file
and oh my goodness after Knight B3 there
is an insane idea Bishop F5
and it looks like it fails for two
reasons first of all looks like you're
learning a bishop but no you're not
after Knight takes F5 the bishop on H6
is trapped but the secondary reason
seems to be Bishop takes G7 and here
there's the move Bishop E4
counter-attacking The Rook The Rook has
to move after King takes G7 black is
completely fine so it turns out that
Knight B3 is actually a serious mistake
and in this position white should start
with the move Bishop G2 to avoid that my
goodness that's an incred I mean Bishop
F5 is such an incredible move
it really is and it comes out of nowhere
I mean that Bishop on H6 looks perfectly
safe in conjunction with the G4 Pawn I
mean Knight F5 is never possible and
that's exactly the point you're trying
to get rid of the Jeep on uh to activate
the Knight
that's a cool resource incredible
incredible stuff uh there so after
rookie 8 but Bishop G2 seems to keep
things under control
and yeah fitted just with a comfortable
Advantage here it seems
yeah the engine move here is F5 also
makes sense kind of to your point trying
to create counter play yeah on the king
side rather than the Queen's but white
just goes Rook G1 and the key for white
is to keep this Pawn alive on G4 because
it totally limits the Knight and again
black has to solve you know this just
procrastinates on the problems black is
facing which is that you know white
threatens to win this pawn and then when
the D5 Pawn basically just win the game
I'm
grindelius isn't is in dire shape here
he's in big big trouble for sure and uh
well Dania let's quickly bring back the
bird's eye view because and Mr Big he is
wondering we thought we were gonna see a
quick handshake in in or and do buff
Duda but he is wondering has dubov
slightly misplayed this can do both have
uh can do that have something here
uh let's have a look let's go back to
that game uh because again we don't have
too many other developments uh we have a
couple of Moves In shocker yards game
and shanklin's game but let's let's very
quickly revisit the do-bop game and then
we'll move on
um you see how nice I am to to the
producer he appreciates it he's sending
some hearts
um so we left this one off after Queen
D2 and we were expecting a quick
liquidation so the Queens did come off
the Queens would come off and dubov did
go Rook C8 check but rather than going
Rook C7 he went ping F2 so he offers the
a pawn
and in return he wanted to go Rook C7
but Duda doesn't take it dude it goes B5
and I guess the point is that if white
plays A4
if y plays A4 oh duboff might have
missed this white takes on A4
and now it looks totally drawn right no
Rook D4 A5 Rook D5 you lose the plot you
lose the pawn and you're gonna be
tortured here for another three hours
all right that's not time
this is a serious inaccuracy by by
Daniel now he can go Rook C7
but black still goes King G6 I think he
just lost the pawn I think and I think
we can tell it from his body language as
well like maybe there was just one
moment of inattention uh uh he thought
the game was pretty close to to being
over and sometimes it just happens I
think you let your guard down for one
second and uh yeah it must have just
missed this resource by by Duda this is
a shocking oversight because
you know the move B5 is is something you
you have to consider you know it's
prophylaxis against Rook C7 and I don't
think everything has been lost here for
Duba but I think he has to go for that
position I mean I would throw in this
move just to force Black's King onto an
awkward spot and I would basically go
for for this position maybe throw an A5
just uh you know why not and and you can
you can make a move like G4 expanding on
the king side
and perhaps even age for it just trying
to stop Black's King from uh ever making
any progress and then you park The Rook
behind the pawn it should be a draw but
it's very frustrating spot defending
this when you literally just had this
position I mean un seemingly unusable is
you know requires tremendous
psychological gumption and my goodness
if Duda wins this game that would be
absolutely ridiculous that would be
crazy I mean uh dubuff he's gonna have
to recal recalibrate because one moment
you think this game uh is over will will
sign the draw in a in a second and then
B5 appears on the board and you realize
you're just completely missed this and
now well the game is nowhere near over
and you're gonna have to defend this
weekending a pawn down uh for the coming
maybe a few hours even
yeah no this is definitely going to be a
very difficult a struggle session as
duboff takes off his Blazer there
preparing himself for the long road
ahead
ma'am and I think he's just rushed and I
think he played too quickly you know he
has over an hour on the clock just kind
of I I think he kind of automatically
assumed that Duda was going to take the
pawn and he was looking forward to a
draw for and you know this happens to
everybody you in your mind the game is
already over you're you're not losing
there's no way to lose it it's going
down in a draw and you lose a little bit
of your objectivity as you into that
yeah and well hopefully for him he can
hold on but now it's gonna be a whole
different story here we'll come back to
this I thought I think we both thought
we were never coming back to this game
it was gonna be over by the next time
but now we'll have plenty of time uh to
come back to it
um and we do have a result elsewhere
though as the game between Sergey
kariakin and Richard report has ended in
a draw
it has and they did find a repetition in
the position we last looked at uh rehard
deciding on Queen C7 we were talking
about Queen A7 he makes a very similar
move in Sergey deciding that he just
doesn't have any Targets the pawn on A5
is safely defended and there's always
this idea of going Bishop D7 and
skewering the a pawn if the Rook leaves
A1 and so deciding uh Surya deciding
that the best course of action is just
to repeat Rook B5 Rook C5 a handshake a
solid game I think a good job by rehard
to deal with that move H4 uh and I think
that Sergey maybe we'll look back and
say that perhaps uh the move G4 on move
seven would have been a you know a more
ambitious try I mean the engine approved
of it and I think after Bishop D3 this
just gives black such a solid position a
good job I buy a report drawing with
black to go into the resting yeah pity
we didn't see the the G4 action but in
the need a solid game here looks like
both players were happy with the draw in
the end so we can go back to uh tulip
bird's eye view and see some of the
players we've had some moves in
shankland against Carson so maybe we go
back there are also memories against
pregnant and that seems to be heating up
yeah let's start maybe with a Shanklin
game
and then we'll go to soccer yards game
so Sam deciding in in this critical
position we were discussing Queen B3 and
then Bishop takes C3 he plays Bishop
takes E3 immediately
Magnus recapturing with the bishop and
Sam going Rook AP1
now it's quite clear to me that Magnus
has solved his opening problems I mean
material equality has been restored
uh and I mean you can go B6 if he wants
but Sam's idea might be Bishop A6 here
and then a very nasty check on e4 so
Magnus might be better advised to get
this bishop out of the way first just so
he doesn't have to worry about it and
then after Queen E2 either Rook C7 or B6
and I would actually prefer to be black
here yeah I was just gonna ask you now
that the material balance has been
restored and the bishop pair here it
looks like an open position where the
bishop should be doing well so that
what's there not to like for black
yeah two Bishops and a a uh distant Pawn
majority so that virtually any pawn end
game any end game at all is going to be
Troublesome for white because of the
possibility of an outside passer uh for
black and I always like to talk about
who's got the numerically smaller Pawn
majority both sides have their Pawn
majorities but white has a four on three
and black as a two on one the smaller
the total quantity of puns the easier it
is to make a past spawn right black just
needs to go B5 b4a5a4 and then he's
ready to create a password for white
it's going to involve you know moving
tons of Pawns forward uh and it's a lot
less certain so the engine is still
giving equality due to this move Knight
D4 Fiona and Sam probably does have to
find this move uh if he wants to be
completely fine and after castles the
point is that white can go Knight B5 and
very importantly force a trade otherwise
A7 is going to hang and this is quite
close to a draw uh because of the
opposite colored Bishops yeah so maybe a
crucial moment here with some uh having
having to find uh this Knight D4 idea
um well Magnus to play first of course
we'll come back to here let's uh check
in which
and pragnananda
indeed and they're following a path that
we kind of discussed as being rather
undesirable for Prague who by the way is
31 minutes now after only 13 moves
that's crazy so after Bishop H3 he
decided not to refrain from the trade in
fact he took on H3 right takes h397
chakra hitting where it hurts Rook C1
chasing the bishop away and then going
Rook CA and this move F3 I think might
have been underestimated by Prague once
again if he takes F3 I think shakuri are
he can go E4 immediately or if he can
take with the queen and very quickly
play for Fiona this gets really
unpleasant like that f file and E4 is
coming I mean Black's starting to get
blown off the board here the king that's
still stuck on the eighth it's nowhere
near castling yet with the bishop still
on on f8 and we both said that I think
he
um well he played enough beat uh early
Queen A4 and I think he got just what he
wanted he he got Prague out of book he
got all his pieces into play Prague has
made a move uh he has played Knight F6
yeah but
night night hf2 I think simply Knight
hf2 this forces he takes F3
and after either E4 immediately or queen
takes F3 black is in huge trouble here
huge trouble and there's so many
weaknesses white can probably just
Castle any time he likes and bring an
extra piece into the attack by uh The
Rook will be on the f file white has the
center black has all these weaknesses
you're highlighting and I would not want
to be Prague here
no it's just bad it's bad and obviously
black can take on A2 but this is the
pawn Checker out cares about least E4
Knight B6 castles and
first I'm 93 Knight F5 E5 I would go so
far as to say that this is looking
probably not completely lost or anything
like that but incredibly Troublesome and
he's also doesn't have a lot of time on
top of that so
let's remind you all at home that he is
only half a point between uh half a
point behind Magnus Carlson so he will
be looking uh he lost I'm sure have an
eye on the Magnus game from the corner
of his eye but he has been very
impressive in this event so far and he
is firmly in control here well more than
firmly in control he's much better
against Prague
mm-hmm and I'm I'm quite confident that
he's going to play Knight F2
he is an excellent formless tournament
and for Prague you know that game
yesterday might be eating away at him
that moved Knight G5 probably wasn't his
dreams or nightmares this morning
and despite some really enterprising
opening play it just seems like things
have once again taken a turn for the
worse for the young Indian Grandmaster
indeed we will come back here later like
you I expect Chuck to play a knight F2
but for now let's go back to the bird's
eye view
we see that Daniel luboff he has gone
down the path you suggest that he will
have to defend uh this work ending with
a minus Pawn a yesi panko he hasn't
doubled the Rooks on the G file but
instead on the f file maybe we can
quickly go back there let's have a look
yeah that's an interesting idea
uh adopted by Andre
so he has gone
all right so we have the trade on E3 if
you played Knight D4 Onish activating
his Knight as well and then doubling up
his Rook so both sides have doubled
their ropes and I think Andre's Point
here
is that if black plays F6 I think F6 is
a very serious mistake why is that
because it weakens the king side just
enough to give white okay maybe serious
mistake is an overstatement but this
gives white a lot of activity I mean
Rook G1 is coming on the next move
on the other hand black and play
rocketsio but I really like what Gary
just did he went Knight D6 he said you
know what I'm not weakening my king side
one bit and this Knight on D6 is
discouraging Andre's night from coming
to F5 he can still play Knight F5 but
I'm not sure that the trade of knights
necessarily favors white here I would
take black here any day of the week
especially given the time situation yeah
Anish has got to be very happy uh with
where the opening has brought him what
I'm curious about if I'm a sepenco now
um how do I proceed to I try and
activate my king I'm also concerned a
little bit about that Knight on H2 I
would love to get that into the game but
I'm not sure what the best way is
yeah if you just sort of throw the
knight in with Knight G4 it's not going
to get you much because of Rook G3 and
the Knight is nowhere to go white is
forced to go Rook G2 and at the least
black can take to take and then play H5
and here come the pawns the Knight is
totally limited by this very nicely
placed Rook on the open file this is not
the end of the world for why the game
goes on but Geary can continue with C5
and this just shows that Knights aren't
very good in these types of positions uh
when they're when they can be attacked
by pawns they're constantly jumping
around and you know it's just hard to
find an anchor point for for the knights
in this position and I'm not gonna lie
as soon as H5 appears on the board if I
put myself in here say panko shoes this
is where the diodes start creeping in
and the fear at least for me I would
start getting fearful that is only the
First Pawn but the other two won't be
far behind and so he will have to
I think find some very accurate moves
here to stay in the game against uh
Anish and yeah as you mentioned the
clock situation another thing to watch
out for
but for now let's move on again from
here where do you want to go back to
well first of all
um I should point out that Fabi I think
is still thinking about whether or not
wait is he thinking about whether or not
thanks so I think
or did he make a I think he made a move
yeah he did make a different move he
chose not to repeat so let's have a look
he played the move Queen E2 in this
position
which is kind of a neutral move just
getting his Queen
to a slightly more active Square you
know Fiona I'm not sure about this I
think after Rook DFA black might be a
little bit better I think I agree with
the evil bar here and the reason why
is is that if you play Bishop G3
uh black can give a check and if you
decide to repeat now the queen can swing
back to E7 the point being if you take a
Pawn on D5 then after E4 white is busted
I mean look at those minor pieces
they're all on the f file and they're
all sitting ducks
and suddenly we see that pond Center
come to life in this line we've been
talking about you have to watch out for
for d for an E4 at every turn while here
which would already be too late but uh
yeah Jordan after Rook to f8 that
pressure along the f file
um I would be concerned here as well I
would definitely uh take take black here
and I'm curious how is how is Fabi going
to to proceed uh is there already a
concrete threat in the position here if
white makes a pass move yeah yeah E4 E4
is already it is a threat because of the
night moves you take on after and if y
Coast Bishop G3
Fabi put the queen on E2 just now and it
will really hurt him in this scenario so
he has to do something about this I I
think it's likely he goes Bishop G3
and he might repeat and hope that Jordan
goes Queen D6 and against Queen E7 you
can still play Bishop G3 here because
now the movie 4 is met with Knight D4
and the Knight of F1 is protected I
think
I would give it about a 40 to 50 chance
that we actually see a repetition in
this position
well we'll see I'm curious Dania
yesterday in the interview Jordan said
you know he felt that he was trying to
play more solidly and that maybe overall
as a player over the last couple of
years it become more solid but then
clearly this tournament proved him wrong
uh as you know as I mentioned earlier
he's had six decisive results out of
seven games and I saw a comment here in
the chat by Edge Cadets saying Jordan
trying to be solid but somehow he
somehow finds himself in a volatile game
once again I don't know do I agree
um if Jordan tried to be solid in this
game what do you think Dania isn't
Jordan the one who initiated all this
with this line in the the open Spanish
yeah and you know I think that some
people have an overrated perception of
to what degree this intention to be
solid is actually impacting players
decisions I think it's a lot more about
uh the kind of objective analysis than
it is about playing solidly or playing
sharp lines I don't even think that
these players necessarily categorize
their opening choices like when Jordan
was analyzing Knight takes F2 right I
think it was more that uh maybe Jordan
and his and his second just found that
black is a good position there all of
these players are capable of playing any
position whether it's solid or sharp so
I really don't think it's factoring all
that much into Jordan's decision making
it's not like he's consciously trying to
produce more decisive games uh in all
these players they play the position uh
rather than trying to steer things into
a particular kind of direction that was
more feasible maybe 30 40 years ago when
opening theory was more limited somebody
like tigrant Petrosian really could
steer the game uh pretty reliably into
positional territory let's say nowadays
it's everybody's Universal and it's just
harder to do so I think it's just how
the tournament tends to go more than a
conscious decision I think that's a very
good point I am still curious here
Fabiano still considering his options
will we see a repetition now in this
position I hope not but we will come
come back here
if we go there for one second because
only one one move has been played oh no
actually a couple more so maybe we could
this is a disaster this is a disaster
and it's and it's becoming more of a
disaster with every move I think here
Pride
um according to the engine he did have a
chance uh to play the move Queen B5 I
mean I'm sure he saw this move this move
as straightforward you're threatening
mate after Queen takes F3 the point is
that the Knight can actually swing back
through C7 and try to go to E6 to at
least pressure perhaps the only Target
in White's position upon on D4 black is
still much worse here but I think this
is a little bit more double-edged
instead dropping the Knight to B6 after
castles
I don't think the eval bar is
overstating it if blackface Bishop B7
here this knight from D1 swings over to
F5 Fiona the king is nowhere to go it's
gonna get mated on the Kink side
this is looking closer and closer to
just being lost for black yeah I mean
this is an absolute nightmare for Prague
and it's literally once again it was a
weird game where in the opening he
seemed to be the one I remember when he
played Knight F6 we were quite impressed
that he would still be familiar with
this position and then
um suddenly things turned around so
quickly and I don't know Dania if you
can pinpoint the moment uh where it all
went wrong for Dania because somehow uh
for prank because somehow it all
happened so quickly
it really did and I think you're asking
the right question it is a little bit
hard to to understand like how did
things go wrong so quickly and I first
of all I think shockery are played
divinely I think all of Bishop H3 was an
amazing move and I think the key moment
was here I think the move Knight D7 uh
would have preserved a double-edged
because although 97 there's always this
F3 move and the engine keeps swinging on
its eval but practically speaking I just
think White's having a lot more fun with
all the center playing
so we might even have to go back earlier
it might just be Fiona that prague's
entire opening campaign
is just not practical and this move
Bishop G5 might be the the Practical
refutation and if chakra found this over
the board then that's even more
impressive
it's crazy yeah what a strange game you
have got to feel for Prague who I mean
as we've just seen never really got into
the game uh just putting pressure from
the get-go taking him out of known
territory and right now he is in his
element
um he has got a a near winning position
and
um tough spot for Prague but we will
come back to this game and the remaining
five after a short break so don't go
anywhere and we'll be back soon
I just want to say I know it's early
yeah yeah it's early for all of us but
Bobby you're looking fresh no thanks
Danny
chat Chad likes it man looking good
what about me
all right guys let's go run a show back
here we go
and Fabi this video series was great by
the way and people love it
really do
by the way again dude you're
you're just looking fresh man I love
your new haircut it makes me good
thank you
hey how's it going
[Music]
I don't even recognize myself
the whole new me
[Music]
hey Fabi Dan how's it going hey Robert
hey man
you know just trying out a few new
things here and there the day is
beautiful sun is out
cool
hey Danny yeah forgot to mention that
haircut's looking real fresh on you yeah
thanks man yeah cool appreciate it you
[ __ ] serious was a guy got to do
around you to get noticed
what are you talking about
I that seems a little out of line a
little uncalled for
you know you already can't spell chess
without them what more does he want
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
tournament that actually I mean if you
manage to do well in the starting like
four or five rounds and it's very
interesting like you're in Costa contest
for something you don't you don't even
know what exactly but it feels like
you're fighting for uh for something
maybe is the first crazy one if you if
you do bad lays and then it can be
depressing yes but in general like at
the end of the day you you always have
to play chess and you need to be like
ready to play those long games
foreign
I think my first experience was was when
I was like 17 I guess I played the B
tournament
it was tricky you actually have to love
love chess very much to you know to to
feel comfortable here uh which uh which
I hope is my case
here there is no real alternative so
you're actually fine with playing long
games and I mean okay it's your favorite
game you just play moves and you yeah
try to enjoy it
when I came for the first time like I
saw the sun exactly three times I served
exactly three three Sunday days and this
was funny like it was very very easy to
to predict my results so this time I'm
also like I I really want to do well but
I know that when I see the sun it's
probably time to to you know to to give
it a shot and when you don't see it see
the sun you should be in super solo mode
and you know like uh
better times will come yeah
interesting to hear Daniel do both spots
on the sunny weather in Vikings and well
at the time this was fun before the
start of the tournament he couldn't have
known but then yeah I can tell you it
hasn't been a very sunny year here in
Vikings they have seen the sun maybe a
couple of times but that's about it
yeah I remember my first time in vacancy
walking out of the hotel and it's pretty
it's especially windy near the main
hotel and I had a hard time just making
it to the playing Hall I was like Wow
and uh yeah it's not sunny on the
chessboard either for for Daniel dubov
who
is in the situation through some sort of
sorcery on the part of young should stop
doing that this game should have been
over 10 minutes ago and that's probably
what's going through two buff said I
should never put myself in a situation
where I'm down upon you can see the
frustration uh in his body language but
let me be very clear this game should
still end on the track he should still
be able to hold this together
yeah I guess one of the big questions in
this spot is how
um how quickly do you recover mentally
from the frustration that you're still
at the board that you now suddenly have
to work to defend this uh ending upon
them I think Daniel strikes me as the
type who
will not let it affect him too badly
um how easy is it to to draw this
position objectively speaking
it's hard to say
um and I just want to kind of give a
overview of how these types of end games
are likely to go I mean there's a whole
category of end games where you have a
three on three or a four and four on one
side and then the other on the other
side there's a pass Pawn that's
supported by a rook uh just like it is
here but I think dubov's approach should
be first of all I think he should play
G4 he needs to build up the pawn chain
so that all the pawns defend each other
and what will happen if black advances
the pawn to A2 well let's test that out
let's say that duboff puts his Rook on
C7 and let's say that Yan just pushes
his pawn and pushes his pawn and again I
would not trust the eval bar I would not
trust the computer evaluation even
computers require a lot of thinking time
to make heads or tails of these kinds of
positions so the key question who
benefits and who wins in the event of
this position the hard part for black is
to figure out a way Fiona to get this
Rook out of A1 if you do it at the wrong
moment then white will just capture the
pawn on A2 if you try to walk the king
to B2 what's going to end up happening
is that as soon as the king reaches B2
white gives a check and then the moment
the king disattaches itself from the
pawn The Rook goes back to A7 but what
black can try to do is make progress on
the king side and try to worm the King
around let's say to H4 so there's a lot
of complexity that occurs in these types
of positions and dubot has to set
himself up in the right way knowing that
this kind of situation might occur he
decided to play F4
and for an interesting uh decision I
guess one of the the question is how do
you keep the blacking out and the line
you were just showing one of the
problems when you're on the defending
side is black has so many different
tries and he can come with the King then
go back and you are always doomed to
passive uh defense so one of the things
that I would be worried about is I want
to keep the black king out
um
after the king side or not allowed too
many weaknesses
um F4 I'm a little surprised to see that
move what about you Daniel
yeah it's a little strange but I guess
he the point is that if Duda moves his
Rook back to A1 I think Dubai was
actually going for for active defense he
wants to play G4 and then G5 check and
and get that Rook to the seventh Rank
and really lock the king out uh so this
essentially necessitates I think that
Duda should push his own Jeep on I think
he should play G6 and build a little bit
of a of a pawn wall uh to discourage
Duba from pushing his own pawns and how
now King takes G6 this is proposed by
the computer
but in general this particular trade
should favor white because now black is
left with a weak upon an H6 uh and
probably dubov should now swing his Rook
behind the pawn and initiate uh the main
defensive setup so we'll see what Duda
does here there's a couple of options
yeah well we'll come back here but uh do
that we're definitely getting a second
chance after the opening look just
looked like a dead draw he is gonna try
his best to to convert of course the
extra upon into full point
elsewhere the the bar and the shakia
game just keeps going up and up and up
and um I think are probably the first
player who will get a win here today we
see Prague there under the bottom camera
things are just not looking good and
maybe we can go back for starters to
shankland against Magnus Carlson before
we do that and we will do that I just
wanted to point out that this bishop F5
resource was missed by both players
invited against grandilius did it played
93 and Niels could have played Bishop F5
basically equalizing but such a
difficult move to see cannot blame him
he's got 96 and he remains in very very
serious trouble but yes let's go go to
the Shanklin game
whether they will show that moment when
we'll return to visit against grandelius
and missed opportunity for sure and here
we left it off just a few moves ago
yes so we were examining the so Magnus
did indeed decide to dial the bishop
back from C3 and then he went Rook C7
so he decided on Rook C7 rather than B6
I guess he didn't want to weaken the
light squares
and Sam uh pushing that e-pawn while he
still has a chance while black is not
fully completed his development so E4 E5
Magnus dropping the bishop back and
Sam centralizes the Knight with Knight
D4 so the Knight potentially coming out
to F5 and the second idea is to play E6
so for instance black could try to go
Bishop C5 here and attack the Knight
and white could go E6 in this position
the point is that if you take the Knight
you walk into the devastating E7 and so
black is forced to take on E6 and then
he's forced to take again because it's a
fork and this should probably be a drop
it's a colored Bishops but you know
black has some pressure on F2 if I were
to choose the side I would probably
choose black here
yeah but I love I like the way that some
hand has handled this it felt like maybe
the momentum was shifting ever so
slightly in magnus's favor when he went
to win back his Pawn suddenly he's got
the bishop hair life is good and uh I
think it's very good to see Sam take a
very active approach he's going forward
with his pieces and
um I think he's been playing a very nice
game so far
he definitely has and he knows what to
avoid against Magnus like he knows that
he cannot afford to get something like a
slightly worse end game or one of those
positions where Magnus has uh endless
grind chances you know because those
positions Magnus just eats people alive
uh and so I think Sam realized In This
Moment wait a second Magnus got two
Bishops he's got the uh Pawn majority on
the queen side I need to get something
done I need to change the course of the
game E4 was an excellent practical
decision by Sam and if you're just
looking at the computer evals uh you
don't think much of it because there's
there seems to be several equivalent
moves but I I really like the way that
Sam has approached this task and uh if
he makes a draw then uh you know part of
the reason why I think will be his uh
proactive thinking in that situation
Magnus oh je dubing right there and I I
think we could hear it and we could like
at least we could see the words on his
his lips
making sure yeah he's not knocking
anything over
and making sure he doesn't press the
clock
right that is of course a common problem
don't we all want to do that when we
adjust the piece
um but yeah Magnus uh here also I'm very
impressed how Sam has held his own on
the clock we see that the Magnus is
actually the one with slightly a lower
time and right now the time isn't a
problem yet but we're only on move 21 so
it could become an issue at some point
oh it absolutely could 36 minutes and
Magnus is going to take a while here uh
he knows that Bishops he has Bishop C5
in his pocket I can guarantee you that
he's calculated Bishop C5 E6 and he is
looking for a more ambitious option if
he doesn't find it then he's gonna go
Bishop C5 uh and and then we're gonna
very likely see that E6 move yeah and
then one of the questions will be can
white withstand deal easily with the
pressure on F2 we'll come back and find
out about that maybe we can go back to
visit against Nils and then yeah you can
show us one more time the incredible
resource that was missed by both players
absolutely and as I open up that game I
will mention that Fabian went forests
are in the process of repeating the
position so we might see a result there
soon we will keep an eye on that for you
and we will bring that to you if they
continue repeating but back to Neil's
visit against Nils in this position
Vivid castles uh Niels indeed went
rookie eight and now the move to ID3
and here Niels missed the incredible
move Bishop F5 for just joining us this
resource we had showed earlier what is
the idea well the bishop is migrating
over to this juicy juicy Square on e4
if it's captured then after Knight takes
F5 black is simply better because white
loses uh the bishop back and if Bishop
takes G7 then black has the Intermezzo
Bishop E4 attacking The Rook The Rook
has to move uh and after King takes G7
if anything I would probably already
take black here because if Knight takes
D4 black can start doubling on the E
file of that Bishop on e4 is just a
monster but in any case this is
obviously a massive improvement over
what Niels had but instead and trust me
Niels he is hard on himself he is going
to be furious with himself after the
game if he loses for missing Bishop high
five he's going to be furious he's got
96. and just how bad is the position now
it's defensible it's not it's not losing
by any means uh and the reason it's not
losing is because after 94 94 Rook D4
black can essentially use the technique
of saying hey take my Pawn because
that'll reach an opposite colored Bishop
position the move F5 here can be tried
uh to create some counter play on the
king side but after something like
Bishop F3 man is black cramped here
Niels just might have to hunker down and
you know maybe try to get the bishop to
C6 it's incredibly nasty Fiona but you
know given how he defended yesterday I
think he's still got some chances yeah
of course the clock here as well very
likely to play a role at some point
where only on move 19 and we are getting
closer we're just an hour and a half
away now from that first time control
maybe let's bring up Fabiano against
Jordan
yeah where you see the players I started
repeating and so let's just go back a
couple of moves
well Fabi yeah so so after Rook DFA we
mentioned that once again there's a
potential repetition Bishop G3 it
happened Jordan did have the possibility
of going Queen E7 here as we discussed
but you can't really blame him for
wanting to play more solidly and being
okay with a repetition uh against Fabi
with black and Fabi you know he's now
down to 28 minutes I really don't see a
way that white can play because the P4
is being threatened and doing something
foolish just to say that you're playing
for a win is not objective and it's not
how Fabi treats things uh the only move
that I really saw here was Knight G3 but
it doesn't work there's a beautiful
reputation black can still go E4 looks
like a blunder that walks right into
Knight takes E4 but no look at this
queen that move Queen E2 by Fabi has
caused a host of problems and here black
has the movie Rook E7
pinning the night and after Knight T6
rookie two black is just gonna vacuum up
all of these pawns this is terrible for
white I'm betting a silver dollar that
fabby's going to repeat here and just to
be clear Jordan off course he could
still play on himself
um he still has the opportunity to go uh
if Fabi goes Bishop G3 Queen C5 Bishop
F2 I think he's still in time or is it
already too late no I think that's two
times and and you know I think that if
Fabi takes another 15 minutes uh and
then plays Bishop G3 and says all right
Jordan might very well decide to
continue playing so that is a
consideration Fabi must take into
account as well
we see Jordan there looking calm and
collected waiting for Fabiano
to make his decision I agree with you I
think a repetition here is likely but
Fabiano of course he was looking for
more today but he never really got much
out of out of the opening here
no he did not and uh that decision to
take on F2 and follow it up with F6 even
with fabi's Innovative Knight F1 idea it
just didn't lead anywhere particularly
promising and if Abby's going to be
frustrated with this results I mean he's
remains on 50 and he's gonna have to
make a you know a serious push in the
second half of the tournament but first
of all of course we will uh wait to
confirm that repetition actually happens
maybe Fabby finds some way to keep
playing I I don't see it though we'll
we'll find out let's bring back the
bird's eye view for now
um so what haven't we updated in a while
um well there's a sepango Geary but not
much has happened there let's look at my
media rf's game because a lot has
happened there and it looks like chakra
is well on his way
to scoring the point or is he let's see
who the transformation has favored now
what happened here
is that in this position
Prague offering the queen trade between
A4 and the engine seemed to think that
after Queen D3 Queen B5 again offering
the queen trade it the engine seemed to
think that chakriar should have gone for
Knight F5 that's not a very human move
though
because it allows Queen takes D3 Knight
takes D3 Knight takes E4 the point here
is that Rook ce1 is winning for white
this is crazy Knight takes D2 and now
not Rook takes C7 but Knight takes C7
Fiona this is wild and the point is that
the Knight is threatening to spring back
to G6 with a discovery and if black
takes the Rook then white takes the Rook
then white takes one Knight and then of
course white takes the other Knight on
obvious line I don't know how this could
have been missed by shock react but he
decided and once again we also see the
problems that can happen when the king
is still in the center
yeah I mean all sorts even in the end
game and instead chakra uh went for this
position he's still winning I think he
should play the move Knight D3 uh
centralizing the other night and maybe
pick up the pawn
some chances for Prague this is an
incredibly nasty end game chakra has
this massive uh Pawn Center that's
incredibly mobile and he's got much
better pieces but Prague is incredibly
resilient and I'm sure that he's going
to make chocolate work for it
has now caught up on the clock with both
players being down to around 35 minutes
and yeah Prague we have seen him uh put
up some great resilience before his
mature beyond beyond his years and let's
not write him off just yet
of course then has a clear Advantage
here let's go back
um shall we go back to Magnus and and
Sam
let's go back to Magnus and salmon let's
see if anything has happened there
um
he's still thinking and I just by his
pose I think that he is slowly but
surely surely accepting the
inevitability of Bishop C5 E6 and the
reason he's disappointed at that is
because he feels like that position is
too simplified to give him serious
winning chances I'm just getting that
sense from the way that he's handling
this he's now down to 28 minutes as well
which you know starts to enter
concerning territory for sure he's gonna
have to make up his mind soon I agree I
think what we're seeing there and we
just saw a front is frustration add to
um he's struggling to see how to avoid
these simplifications and leading to to
the position with the opposite color
Bishops we'll come back here let's go to
the overview again and see uh if we have
any updates
Fabi is okay so Jordan has the choice of
repetition here and he's thinking about
it now maybe we should just watch that
game because we might see a result right
about now Jordan can repeat it three
times if he wants to and there it is we
have a result and the origin
understandably has decided uh to repeat
and opt for a draw a very very good
result for Jordan going into the rest
day for sure after only making one draw
in the first uh seven rounds and we see
the players working away fast after
their game today is another fun day it
is the PCR test for everyone before the
rest day so that happens right after the
game you're black and you just threw
against Fabiano Carona you get rewarded
by a PCI test
no better gift indeed another result
we've got two of them now
um and not the ones we thought we would
get we thought that uh dubov and Duda
would end in a draw and the other games
would keep going but it turns out that
that game has kept going and
um
these two have ended in dress and look
at Anish giri yep those pawns are
starting to move up the board this is
exactly what I was talking about uh if I
was white here I would start being
seriously seriously concerned
and you know you can lose a game like
this in in five more moves if you let
the pawns go any further if the pawn
gets to G4 and then let's say the king
gets to G5 once black starts pushing the
F Pawn it becomes essentially resignable
so
panko has to make something happen here
and I don't know what it is I mean he
can go Rook D6 but Yuri is not gonna
just repeat moves here I mean rookie six
he's probably gonna go Rook three E6 in
order to be able to meet Rook D7 with
Rook E7 otherwise The Rook would just
toggle between D6 and D7 and a trade is
definitely in Black's favorite
definitely and this might just be losing
for white because
of how bad the night is at stopping the
progress of the pawns especially when
they're supported by the king
uh not good not good for Andre and the
situation keeps deteriorating yeah and I
looking at the camera you gotta feel for
him because I think in those spots it's
just it's so hard to keep the food out
of your mind I had the chance to just uh
go for a draw in the opening maybe we
can very quickly bring uh put that
position on the board again in the
opening when Andre had a choice whether
to go for a draw uh so yeah here after
G4 takes takes Queen takes King H1
Knight E5 Knight H2 was the move that he
did play but if he had captured on E5
that would have just led to an immediate
perpetual
between H3 Queen G3 using the pen and
black has nothing more than to accept
the inevitable I mean admirable for sure
but a little bit overzealous and Anish
has turned out to be very very well
prepared in this line I feel like in his
preparation he probably studied a
similar type of end game so he was aware
of the ideas he's been playing quickly
he has 50 minutes on the clock he is in
excellent shape here and I would say
it's about 50 50 between drawing and
winning chances I'm very concerned for
Andre Daniel we are going to go on a
break very shortly but first can you
maybe recap for us in a couple of
minutes what's going on in the five
remaining games
certainly Fiona well starting again on
the top left we just saw Magnus playing
Bishop C5 Sam is going to play E6 we're
going to have an opposite colored Bishop
situation where Magnus has a little bit
of pressure but that's probably likely
to end in a draw chakra for the
overwhelming position uh a technically
winning end game against Prague and
amazing opening play but uh Prague is
going to keep resisting and he's got
some off chances to save the game uh
Anish gear we just talked about that
he's got three pawns for the piece he's
got great winning chances and Andre
regretting his decision not to take that
early opening draw Sergey karyakin has
drawn against report vidit uh is in
fantastic shape against Niels after
Niels missed that amazing opportunity to
go Bishop F5 I would say that vidit's
winning chances outweigh uh Nils is
drawing chances a draw and Fabiano
caruana against Jordan man forest and
finally Dubai with a shocking plunder in
a dead drawn position he's blundered
upon on the end game should still end in
a drive he's careful if he can calm
himself uh and and play objectively he
should be able to save the half point
but Jan Christoph Duda will continue
torturing dubov for the near future so
plenty of intrigue here will shakirov
catch Magnus in the lead can Magnus
somehow get a win we'll find out so
don't go anywhere we'll see you in just
a few minutes
thank you
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
the longest running tournament Series in
online chess is getting a huge update in
2022 titled Tuesday is doubling yes
doubling the number of tournaments and
tripling the prize fund with 5 000 in
prizes every Tuesday and over 250 000
annually this change comes with a big
schedule shift as tournaments move to 8
A.M Pacific 11 A.M Eastern Time 5 p.m
CEST and 9 30 p.m IST and 2 p.m Pacific
time so there will now be two separate
tournaments at 8 A.M Pacific and 2 p.m
Pacific on Tuesday this new schedule is
designed to best serve the global chess
player base and audience ensuring that
all of the best players in the world
have strong opportunities to compete
watch live coverage every Tuesday
starting February 1st right here on
chess.com this is so exciting everybody
loves title Tuesday and it's great to
see it expanding into two separate
events great news Fiona for sure I'm
looking forward to that myself always a
nice opportunity to try and get some
scallops great news indeed for now let's
get back to round eight here
um we see what do we see let's go back
and start with shankland against Carlson
where at the position we talked about
earlier on has appeared on the board it
has
it has now it's a reality and the
position is greatly simplified we now
have opposite colored Bishops so in the
event of a queen trade
uh the position will really simplify
into what is probably a draw even with
Rooks on the board Sam first of all has
to defend his Bishop there's two ways I
see him doing that the first is to drop
the queen back to E4
okay well that threatens Checkmate
Magnus will play G6
the second way is to play Rook B to D1
involving the rook and also x-raying
black screen again the one concern I
have here on Sam's behalf is that Magnus
will somehow find a way to let's say get
his Rook to F7 and get his Queen to H4
but it's definitely not happening
immediately if you go Rook F7 in this
position you actually lose white has
Queen E4 and watch this after you play
G6 everything's fine right no it's not
Bishop is on C5 it's undefended and that
is what we call a fork so Rook bd1 works
concretely it's the computer
recommendation and if Sam preserves uh
maintains his composure and caution
Fiona for the next two three moves this
should be a draw it looks to me like Sam
isn't exactly in a state of panic I
think he will keep his composure I think
this is probably the number one game in
this tournament that he was most looking
forward to he has taken it to Magnus
Carlson who is actually the the player
who's low on the clock at this point and
Magnus might just have to agree to let
this Peter out here shortly because
um well as you just highlighted he could
end up in some danger if he decides to
overpress you
yeah and the one thing I was trying to
uh get get uh my head around is what
exactly happens in the event of a queen
trade is it really a draw so I was
contemplating a line such as Rook bd1
Queen let's say queen H4 GT let's just
say for the sake of illustration black
plays Queen F6 and we have a treat let's
let's say black plays Queen F6
immediately uh is this in fact a dead
draw and the answer I think is yes and
the reason is that white has this very
nice maneuver Bishop E2 and then the
bishop comes to F3 and this entirely
blocks any pressure that black might be
able to put down the f file and so if
Sam is able to do that uh
it's just symmetrical I mean there's
there's no real way to make progress for
either either side here I would take
black but it's it's a draw
yeah and well we'll see if uh if Magnus
can find a way to either avoid or delay
the the trade of uh Queens for nowadays
some to move we can go back again to the
the overview we're expecting a peaceful
result here but not expecting a peaceful
result in my media off against pregnant
under
no we are not let's check into that game
because stuff is happening in that very
unpleasant end game
for Prague and what has happened here is
that shocker has gone E5 he's put that
Knight on F5 and then in this position
he threw in the Mover of C1 hitting the
Knight on C8
Knight B6 and he has decided to take the
bishop I think what chakra are first of
all the B4 Pawn is going to be hanging
on the next move second of all the dark
squares for black look at those dark
squares D6 F6 this diagonal black could
get checkmated in the center in a matter
of just a couple of moves and it's a
matter of time before Shakura puts a
knight on e4 he can get his King up to
F3
I'm just not seeing it happen for Prague
no uh it's also the problem for Prague
is there is no active counter play there
is barely any weaknesses that I can see
in the white Camp uh the ponds Are all
uh solidly defending each other there is
no isolated pawns no double pawns and no
really no holes so I think
he is not gonna let this one slip
and from here I don't know do we go to
visit and Grand Alias or let's do it
so let's go there and it's funny that we
should have this Pawn structure on the
board because Robert and I saw this
exact same Pawn structure in a game I
can't remember which one but in one of
the early rounds of the tournament and
we thought this Pawn structure doesn't
have a name yet the best the chat came
up with was goal posts but I think gold
posts are Pawn structure that in general
you should try and avoid but here are
things open up opening up in a good way
for needles gopis are you supposed to
kick a soccer ball down the e-file or
something like that
um this is really an interesting
approach by vidit so once this resource
was missed I was you know expecting
Knight takes D4 but it playing F5 G
takes F5 rook hf1 and what I think he's
saying is Mr grendelius I want to
Checkmate you
uh because if Niels starts grabbing all
of the pawns so vidit probably wants to
take on F6 and he wants to move the
bishop away and go Rook G1 now Bishop
takes H3 is the fanciest way of doing
that but here's the interesting thing
Fiona this looks like it has to be a
Checkmate right I mean just look at this
position there's got to be some mate
well there isn't a mate uh the bishop
doesn't sound hard to believe there is
nothing here
there is the move Rook F3 though
vacating uh the path backward for the
bishop this actually does threaten
Checkmate Bishop takes D4 will be made
but black can send over the knight uh
and cover the G file just in time this
leads to this kind of end game Knight G6
and white preserves an initiative here
but black is up a pawn and the worst
will definitely be behind meals so and
the engine confirms this black should
actually just start grabbing all the
pawns but 20 minutes remaining much
easier said than done for sure and well
before we move on from here with Nina's
having some big decisions as you
mentioned very little time we have a
tweet ready I think I know what it's
going to be I saw it on our last break
uh Anton squared me the genius he's a
great friend of mine go follow him he is
back with his photoshops he used to be
very active and then he got life got
busy but he is back with a somewhat
dramatic Photoshop there Dania
that is wow there's just there's a lot
going on in that photo let me put it
that way
and it's funny because I was just
talking to Dan a few days ago he told me
why are the lights so dimmed in the
playing Hall I need better lighting to
do a new uh Photoshop this is actually
part of a whole thread that has been
going for years so go check him out on
Twitter
he had some great stuff out there and
I'm glad he got the lighting he wanted
and he's back producing those uh funny
pictures
we meanwhile are back in the bird's eye
view and
um what I see I see Andre yes panko one
Rook has gotten in but you were talking
about white doesn't want to trade work
shall we go there is and he's just going
to
interpose the work and if so which one
yeah I mean
Anish can make a draw if he wants I mean
there's a repetition on the cards if he
so desires and the way to do that
uh is is to cover with well I guess you
can cover with this Rook
and then after Rook D6
rookie six this type of repetition where
the Rooks kind of follow each other
right
um you know I know some people think
that unusual automatically go for this
option because it results in a draw but
uh I think he's going to be more
ambitious than that and I think the
black is really not risking in either
case here and so the way to avoid that
is to cover with the E3 Rook then to
cover it again and then bring the other
Rook up to E7 so essentially you keep
your Rooks on E7 and E6 the two squares
from which white can attack a black pawn
and here asapenco will have to decide
whether he wants to trade a pair of
rocks probably the answer is no he'll
play Rook d8 I'm not claiming that this
is an easy win for black but after
something like King G6 The Rook can
cover a check on G7 and black can
continue trying to make progress on the
king side entree also with 12 minutes
for seven moves so not ideal but should
be enough I mean you shouldn't be yeah
he's not crazy time pressure I would be
shocked that Anish goes for a repetition
here I think at the very least he wants
to to test Andrea until move 40 and it
feels like
um unless he starts blundering uh his
kingside pawns he shouldn't really be in
any danger so
and this year
um we see once again that I've mentioned
it before but the opening a little
gamble with the indirect draw for paying
off I think and uh well let's see how is
uh duboff's flight going he is also
defending a worse end game fall down
yeah let's see whether he's been able to
stabilize the position
and I think he has I actually think that
Duda might have not chosen the absolute
most testing option so what happened is
that after F4 due to going A5 Daniel
going King F3 and here I think okay so
Rook A1 and G4
now what is the what is do-bop's point
the point is that if white plays or
black plays A4 White's gonna go G5 check
and White's just gonna start harassing
black Rook C7 King E8 and at the very
least white can just put the Rook on A7
and black is never going to be able to
make progress that King is never going
to escape the eighth rank so that's one
possibility
uh Duda can try to prevent that by
playing G6 and opening up a loft Square
for his King on G7
but I'm worried that after G5 check
there is just a mass Liquidation on the
king side and the more pawns are traded
generally speaking the closer the game
gets to drucking G7 let's say hg6 King
G6 gh6
and
this should be a drum maybe white can
walk the king up toward down the middle
but if white just does nothing here
Fiona I think that uh dubuff should be
able to should be able to hold this one
and I like this suggestion I think
dubuff will be looking to to trade
um those pawns so after G4
unexpected G6 he's done you're not a fan
of G6 no I'm expecting it I think he's
expecting
G6 and and then some points to be traded
I think Duda himself probably he knows
that this um that this end game is a
draw with best play but of course he uh
is trying he's been given a very
unexpected opportunity uh in this game
but most likely the income the outcome
will still be peaceful and let's go move
on from here
um and we're back in the bird's eye
View
okay
am I hallucinating
um
yeah we have had a one-time no not yet
he's gone
essentially what he has done
is he's gotten the Rook from E3 to E6 so
it's sort of a semi-rep it will be a
repetition if he goes to Rook B7 so he's
deciding right now in real time whether
to make the draw
and I would vote no I think he's going
to go Rook 87 but the way he's leaning
back in his chair maybe he's thinking
you know there is a little bit of risk
of course associated with White Snake
getting active and black cam somehow
lose these pawns although I don't really
see that happening
it's hard to predict but I don't think
he's making it wrong here I think he's
got good good winning chances after
rookie seven I would be shocked yeah I
agree with you so we leave him to think
about it Houston has plenty of time on
the clock and maybe we go back to to
some shankland and Magnus Carlsen unless
things are happening elsewhere
yeah so Sam has chosen a very
interesting
approach
um so in this position he went Queen H3
defending the bishop and threatening
Checkmate this force is H6 but that in
turn weakens the G6 Square which Sam
tries to exploit with the move Queen G3
he is threatening Queen G6 that needs to
be prevented
um and he's also aiming at The Rook on
C7 which prevents moves like Queen F6 I
suppose Magnus could go Queen D6 and I
would say that that is quite likely
Magnus likes these kinds of moves but
this end game is basically unwinnable
and here Sam could expand a little bit
on the king side he could play the
typical move H4
the engine gives total equality and I
tend to agree with that I think that
and also Sam could try to plant this
bishop on G6 this could get a little
unpleasant for black even if white
anchors the bishop with H5 so
yeah maybe Magnus maybe it's Queen D6
isn't the best after all because the
last thing Magnus wants is to start uh
suffering in this position
yeah the other move here is Rook D7
dropping you know getting the Rook away
from
uh from the Queen's gaze and attacking
the bishop Sam can defend that with Rook
bd1
and then you could go Rook D6 and once
again you have to prevent Queen G6 so
this White's got some issues to solve
here again what bothers me is always
this Pawn on F2 it's annoying it's
annoying because you can never really
move the Rook away from F1
yeah I mean I really liked what you said
earlier about the bishop coming to to F3
I I was completely on board with trying
to close down that file but here right
now it doesn't seem uh to be possible
just yet
first magnets will have to to deal with
the threats to his king
um but yeah both sides still seem to
have some play here some threats do you
think we'll see a queen exchange soon
and then some simplifications or do you
think this will be a time scramble
battle
yeah it's hard to say I think because
the position is so wide open uh that
raises the likelihood of a queen trade I
and I really think that Magnus is
deciding right now between Queen D6 and
Rook D7 and if he really is ambitious if
he wants to squeeze the absolute most
out of the position then the move is
Rook D7 but I I think both choices would
be understandable here
and we see Magnus uh deep in thought
um 23 minutes remain we are on move
2026 and he has as you just said a big
decision on his hands uh one that will
lead uh leave a lot more life in the
position than the other so we'll see
which one he chooses uh for now where
would you want to go next Tanya
well
um let's try to get first of all if we
go back to a bird's eye view for a
second just to point out that dubov
interestingly Duda did not push his Jeep
on he has allowed as we have a look here
at Anish contemplating what to do but uh
he's allowed G5 check interestingly
young schizoph has so maybe that is a
better winning chance uh that's
something we can explore we'll keep an
eye on Geary and see whether he in fact
plays for the win or goes for the draw
um Magnus has just gone Rook D7 so there
it is let's have a quick look at vidit's
game because Niels did not end up taking
that pawn on G4 and he has slipped back
into a very very nasty position let's go
there so let's rewind a couple of moves
and see how we got here
so F5 gf5 Rook F1 here Niels had this
chance to take on G4 fearlessly but he
ended up going King F7 allowing Vita to
recapture the pawn
Rook G8 Rook D2 and oh by the way
there's another tactic here Fiona
there's a lot being again players here
Bishop takes up five again
oh my God it's a completely different
reason but this he had to see this King
G6 and maybe he rejected it because he
saw Rook F2 King H takes for cap six but
guess what after Rook G6 this is uh
this is defensible let's not forget the
black is up a pawn here and this is much
much closer to a draw than the text very
sloppy by both players here and my guess
is that vidit might have missed that as
well the point is that white could have
avoided this
uh or at least white could have gotten a
better version of this with the move
Bishop H1 the point is that after Bishop
F5 Rook out five King G6 white has the
move Bishop F4 in this position
and this attacks the Knight on C7 and
the reason you can't do that
in the event of Rook D2 why can't you go
Bishop F4 here
amazingly black has the move 96.
and um there's a couple of differences
so with the bishop on H1
uh what's the actual difference I guess
who I would have had some sort of
something related to the move Rook q1
check and I want to bog down too much
into the details the bottom line is that
this was a possibility for black and
Niels could have gotten more drawing
chances instead he went 95 uh Fiona
vidit reclaims the pawn and now he goes
B3 fully limiting the Knight on E5 this
is now very very bad for black nails is
kind of out of Counter play but those
complications were crazy on the one hand
Niels for sure he will be kicking
himself when he turns on the engine
tonight to have missed Bishop F5 as a
counter blower like as a resource not
just once but twice and now 14 minutes
on the clock will only on move
25 and
situation is looking dire for Niels once
again I wondered can we do something
active can I as black maybe try to to
push those pawns on the queen side and
create some chances
yeah B5 or maybe A5 is definitely a try
though A5 is going to be shut down by A4
Niels has gone Rook a to E8
Rook a to E8
yeah I mean that's as good as good a
move as any I think and you know it's
not going to be easy to break down
Black's defensive construction right now
everything is protected and yeah you
have this very nicely placed Knight on
E5 the issue is just that in the long
run but it has a bunch of improving
moves you can push the pawn to A4 he can
get his King to B2 this bishop on H6 has
done its job I think it probably belongs
on F4 where it pressures the Knight
in just in the long run I'm you know I
feel like White's winning chances are
are going to grow as he improves his
position can you explain and I think
this is something that isn't clear to me
and I think very often it isn't clear to
the viewers and materially is even yes
Black's position looks a lot worse but
we see the engine says plus 2.6 which is
a a big Advantage so how come it sees
Neil's position as so bad
so I think there's two things that play
I mean first of all I would argue as but
it does indeed play for I would argue
that this is a slight overestimation I
think the proper practical assessment is
something like plus 1.5 maybe plus two
but I would not say that this is totally
winning or anything of that nature
um but I think part of the reason is
that uh this is a situation where black
literally has no plan you can see that
the one of the computer's
recommendations is just to go Bishop C8
Bishop D7 and I think those types of
situations are interpreted by computers
as being very very bad because as white
improves his position inevitably there's
going to be a point where white has some
way to cash in and to convert his
Advantage so situations where one side
is completely devoid of counter play uh
I think are are scaled up evaluations
evaluation Wise by the computer
um so that's something to keep into
account like does black have an active
plan here
uh and does white have a way to improve
his position if the answer to the first
question is no and the answer to the
second question is yes and the advantage
is just going to keep growing
yeah and especially so as nils's time
takes down he's now under a minute uh
per move for the remaining remaining 15
move still I will come back here for now
let's bring back the bird's eye a view
we see Niels just about to make a move I
think A6 Plus
makes sense so we'll come back here
unless you want to say something about
that we can move on maybe
yeah let's look at Chakra I'll just
indicate that Anish is still thinking
about uh which rock to cover with on E7
very interesting and Sam is also still
thinking after uh Rook D7 so indeed
players going in the tank but Mama
dearov against Prague we've had a few
moves there and yeah is losing his
Advantage yeah what's happening amazing
so we were looking at this position we
still thought that it's overwhelming
Knight B6 Knight takes E7 Knight takes
E7 chakra took on B4 which which is fine
but in this position he made a move that
the engine absolutely hates
um I also thought that Bishop D6 was the
most natural anchoring the bishop
and then after King t7 it's time to get
the knight in Via E4
it's possible that Shakura was afraid of
Knight F5 but it turns out that the
cold-blooded King F2 uh stops all of the
threads if black takes the plot on D4
then there's Knight C5 check shoeing the
king away and now look at these Knights
they're aligned white can pick one of
them off with the move Rook D1 but
that's not so easy to see when you look
at this 995 you get a little bit scared
but you're gonna lose D4 so shocker are
deciding to simplify and giving the
bishop away for that Knight and
following this up most probably with a
move 94.
huge decision that Bishop was looking so
good uh down the the dark squares also
restricting the black king so do you
think shakyat has just a very confident
that this is enough I guess he's going
to win The Pawn on F3 at some point
I mean he's playing the long game here I
think Shakura first of all is is really
enticed by the possibility of getting a
knight to D6 and he's also not too
concerned about Black's blockade on the
D5 Square because white does have the
move Rook C5 in fact it's a candidate
move in this position
uh but I would imagine that 94 is the
most flexible and the most appealing
move but uh black can start chipping
away at White's center with the move F6
this is suggested by the engine
and this works out tactically because
after ef69 F6 it might appear that Rook
C7 is incredibly strong and here it's
very important to avoid King d8 because
of the very elegant Rook takes A7 and
you're gonna skewer uh the king and win
the exchange but black can simply go
King E6 well there's a skewer this
Wednesday night no it doesn't like as
king D5 and the Knight on e4 hangs at
the end of the line so chances chances
for Prager absolutely and I think Prague
has got to to breathe a sigh of relief
one Chuck took on E7 because I think to
both of us it felt like he wasn't gonna
survive at the onslaught in the middle
game shark's pieces looked like they
were all over prague's uh position and
now yes he is still worse but at least
he's not going to get blown off the
board
yeah I mean they it was overwhelming and
he you know it did really seem like
prague's days were numbered in that
position but uh absolute credit to him
he
I think that idea of trading the Queens
was very very wise he changed the nature
of the position and I feel like Shaq
didn't fully adapt well to it although
let's not overstate the case I still
think that White's winning chances are
uh fantastic here and the defensive task
in front of Prague is a very
intimidating one indeed so we'll see for
sure let's bring back the bird's eye
view again I'm so curious uh to see what
Anish is doing but now bro we saw the
see that this weapon has advanced
further so let's go back there
no draw he has gone after about 15
minutes of thought and I really think it
was never fully endowed it's possible he
was really thinking about this position
after rook d8 and deciding what to do
and here comes the pawn
I think for Andre I think Andre has to
go Knight F1
and try to activate this Knight ASAP and
if Geary continues to push
then these pawns do have the capacity to
get overextended Brooke h8 G3
and there is chaos on the board Rook F4
rookie two check King G1 black could
start eating up the queen side pawns or
he could go G2 first but then after
Knight H2 white is hanging by a threat
but this age Pawn is limited by the rook
and The Rook can't give a check on
anyone because then you drop G2 Rook
takes B2
there's a rook trade Rook H7 check this
is given as a as equality by the
computer it's anything but equal it's
chaotic so that's just one way that the
game could unfold but it does seem like
black is having all the fun here Fiona
for sure and uh especially given the the
clock situation although thankfully for
for Andre having said that we are
already on move 36 so he's only got four
more moves uh to make but regardless
you're completely right he's not having
any fun here he needs to figure out how
to best deal with these pawns marching
up at the board and yeah he's probably
still thinking it could have been long
gone by now and the best I can probably
get from this is just a draw anyway
right no this is a very demoralizing and
the same thing happens after you decline
you actually decline a draw offer and
then you end up getting into a bad
position you're kicking yourself uh you
keep rewinding rewinding to that moment
and you keep replaying it in your hand
like man I could have taken the draw I
could have taken the draw it's like you
know it's like when you uh
when you lose a tooth or when you uh
your tooth falls out and your tongue
kind of goes to that place like you're
constantly thinking about it it has to
push it out of his mind and I think
Knight F1 is actually a crucial move
here without it uh Black's pawns kind of
continue to roll down unabated
yeah as I will see if Andre goes for
Knight F1 we're back once again in the
the bird's eye view
um
maybe we quickly check in with Sam and
then we can also update the do buff do
the ending where do you want to start
Tanya well I'm actually let's go to do
Bob's game because I'm a little bit
surprised by duda's choice but the more
I've been thinking about it the more I
kind of understand what he's going for
although I think Danielle has a forced
draw here
okay so we stopped last in this position
and we were thinking about G6 but Jan
just off going A4 allowing G5 and Rook
C7 and getting his King back to E8 he
wants to push the spawn all the way down
to A2
so here's the thing let's assume that
white does nothing
the point that Duda is making is that if
dubov allows the spawn to get to A2 the
king can't actually get out of its cage
by walking to B8 remember that The Rook
can never leave the a file and so it's
going to have to drop back down allowing
the king passage forward so duboff has a
couple of Tempe before that comes that
becomes a reality and he can use those
Tempe to play G6 here you know the point
is after fghg
A3
now I can play Rook A7 after A2 the king
does not have to drop back down black is
threatening work off one check the king
can March forward to E4 and if black
starts to push the other passer white
fearlessly activates the king and white
is in time to create very powerful
counter play against blackpink in fact
this is already dangerous for black so
Duda has to deviate earlier but not an
easy sequence to play this requires
tremendous amount of calculation and I
think that's what do Bob is burning all
of his time to do this is a very big
decision for why does he take on H6 is
you play G6 or does he make some third
move I mean from the line you showed us
it looks like G6 is working but of
course uh Daniel I think he's going to
invest most of his remaining time here
we're on move 38 so two moves from now
he will get an extra 50 minutes he has
already played recklessly fast once in
this game he got punished so I don't
think he's going to repeat that mistake
he will try and calculate here pretty
much to the first draw if it is there
but I I think he's done a great job
recovering after losing the pawn playing
some precise moves and I think I agree
with you I think this is headed to a
draw and we have time for one more game
before we go for the last break before
the time control Daniel which one is it
gonna be
um let's let's update everybody on the
Shanklin game
let's do it or the Magnus game I guess
should I refer to the game by the
sanctions
oh yeah or Carl
's Carl land that work doesn't really
work as well
okay so uh after Rook D7 Sam uh deciding
to defend the bishop with the Rook Rook
B3 I guess he didn't want to move the
bishop because that would have
potentially allowed The Rook to
infiltrate to the second rank
uh Magnus going Rook F6 getting his own
Rook to the sixth Rank and of course
stopping Queen G6 and Sam creating some
Luft with H3
I think Magnus is just going to keep
playing it I think he's gonna go B6 he's
going to make small improving moves and
at some point Sam has to be very careful
about the possibility of Rook F7
and uh the pressure on F2 continues to
melt so
Magnus has made a move
and it is B6 and it is let me tell you
Fiona these positions are exactly up his
alley it's like looks like a draw but
it's a tiny little something he's got
black is a tiny bit better here without
question and uh nobody's as good as him
at nursing these kinds of positions I
think he will also sense the the
momentum now we saw the players were
always very close on the clock but
suddenly Sam I don't know if it was on
H3 or Rook B3 where he spent his time
but suddenly that eight minute deficit
is uh huge because we're only on move 28
which means at 12 moves I still remain
to be played and Magnus he knows he is
Magnus Christ and he knows he's the
world champion he knows there is a
certain Magnus effect of players uh you
know being so eager to get the results
some nerves kicking in maybe more than
against other opponents and he is going
to use that to his advantage and try and
put really maximum pressure here on Sam
who I think is going out to have to be
very accurate to get this position
first of all to the first time
controlled without losing any ground
yeah and you're on the money he's got 11
and a half minutes for 12 moves and when
you're playing anybody but Magnus that
sounds manageable when you're playing
Magnus in a slightly worse position uh
it doesn't sound particularly manageable
and this is truly amazing Sam seemed to
do everything right he really hasn't
made any major mistakes even any major
inaccuracies in this game and yet it
feels like he's slipping slowly but
surely into an unpleasant position let's
see if he can hunker down and uh
neutralize magnus's play before things
get out of hand yeah I'm very curious we
will find out what happens here after uh
a short break and huh
guess the game I guess this is a duboff
who has played G6
okay so we'll come back to this to
Magnus and to all the other games that
are still ongoing after a short break
don't go anywhere the time scrambles are
coming up and we'll be right back with
all the action
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
welcome back to round eight here at the
Tata steel chess tournament and you too
can get involved actively over the board
even if it is online tour of our three
events are done and dusted but one Still
Remains it is the bullet which always
makes was so much fun that is starting
in just five minutes everyone can join
it is a free to play there are prizes
for the top three finishers with some
signed chessboards and sign books by the
players here from Tata steel so a lot to
play for if you want to play you can
check out the link at the bottom right
there and if you are watching us on
Twitch the link will also be posted
in the chat so
um whatever floats your vote stay with
us there is plenty of action incoming
here or go and play some bullet come
back later Either Way Dania plenty of
fun to look forward to
absolutely I am bullet absolutely that
is my favorite word in the English
language
uh and these tournaments definitely a
great way uh because I can imagine a lot
of people watching kind of get that
hankering you know when you watch
classical chess for a while you want to
play you want to jump into the ring and
you've got the perfect opportunity to do
that as we have a look at our bird's eye
view two games already in the books both
of them draws coronavan forest and
karyakan report all of the other games
still going and the positions on the
board in those games very combative
Fiona anything can happen for sure and
then there's well dude both Duda which
is looking uh very familiar because you
might have just shown that exact line
unfold before we went on break
yeah let's uh remind everybody of what
that line is and what they are playing
into So Daniel very I mean the
discipline to spend however long he's
spent you know 15 20 minutes really
hammering it out uh not just tilting his
way to a lost end game but hankering
down hunkering down finding G6 and the
point is that after takes takes A3 now
what does white not want to do do not
under any circumstances take this Pawn
because after A2 Rook A7 black steps
aside with track and of course the king
will be able to stop the pawn uh from F7
so that's not the way uh the point is
that you stop the pawn from behind and
then when black players A2 you're just
in time to get this King out of the
checking zone of the rook and the king
is threatening to go up to E5 and then
take the pawn on E6 and once it does
that not only will white be threatening
mate but white will be threatening to
push the spawn down to F6 uh
breakthrough and then create a far
Advanced passer of his own
in fact black is probably best devised
in this position to just go Rook B1
and give up the planet and go King E7
and this is a draw if white remains
cautious white can go Rook A6 anchor The
Rook to the E6 pawn and that way G6 is
essentially safe
yeah so I do buff not losing his cool
here it looks like he is now steering at
the game onto drone territory uh
territory we will have a look
um at this a little bit later on if the
players are still here because this
could be ending in a draw quite soon now
let's bring back briefly the bird's eye
view
and we'll see where to next because
there is stuff happening everywhere else
stuff is happening in shocker yards game
and it's also happening in SF panko's
game we haven't looked at that one in a
little little while so let's start with
uh asapanko Geary if that's okay with
you let's do it
cool so the situation I think keeps kind
of deteriorating for white Andre did not
end up playing
uh the move Knight F1 he instead went
after the H fund Rook h8 Rook G8 check
and then Rook f8 so he's just trying to
prevent black from pushing any of his
Pawns
and it's kind of hard to say how black
should make progress here of course
black would love to play rookie five and
F5 you can't do that they're gonna
blunder the F Pawn
uh black can't play H4 because you
blunder the G Pawn maybe King G5 should
be considered ink G5 does prepare yeah I
thinking G5 is the move
because now you prepare H4 and
soon after that you'll be ready to play
G3 they are one move away from the time
control which is a relief for Andre who
has three minutes on the clock to make
one more maybe it's not sure it's gonna
help them a short moment of relief only
because you make move 40 you get your
additional 15 minutes and then you look
at the board and you realize even with
your extra 50 minutes you're still in
what looks at this point like big
trouble on the board it's um I think
it's just one of these positions Dania
it starts out by just looking
uncomfortable but you feel like it
should be a draw with best play but then
with every move which is the position
gets more and more dire
yeah I mean with every push of the pawn
the situation gets worse and worse white
runs out of breathing room on the king
side
uh and Andre you know he'll have to find
somewhere to set up
you know some sort of a of a fortress uh
or create active defense based on an in
Black's King position uh so all of that
is possible and doable in certain cases
but Anish will have so much time on his
Club I mean he's got 25 minutes now uh
and that's a perfect amount of time to
have in a position like this he's going
to work through every single variation
here I just don't really see this
happening for Andre and Anish well after
slow start uh to his tournament
yesterday of course he was held by the
walk over win against Daniel dubov but
let's not forget the day before that he
beat Fabiano caruana with the black
pieces so he could just be making it
three in a row here which would leave
him on five out of eight going into the
second rest day on plus two so Anish uh
he is very focused and he is looking for
that uh all-important win with the black
pieces
and he is about to make a move
or is he that is
that kind of hovering sometimes persists
for about five minutes before the book
was actually made nope he is pushing
that King off King G5 there it is very
natural and very strong and Andre
he has one more move Before Time control
and guess what it's a very important
move it's not easy for white to find a
move because if he goes that F1 now well
then Anish is ready to play H4 and once
these spots hit H4 and G4 man oh man are
things nasty here for white it hurts me
to even look at this position I'm uh I
think Anish is just going to to win this
game and while we will come back here
for now let's go back to the bird's eye
view of things happening I was reading
in the chat here there's been some big
developments in Sam shankland against
Magnus Carlson and it looks like Sam has
done a great job holding his own yeah
let's have a look it does look like uh
things have completely fizzled out and
neutralized what has happened it did
seem like after B6 Magnus uh is building
up a a sizable Edge but sampling is very
tricky move Bishop E2 Magnus quickly
responded to The Rook D2 and maybe this
was an oversight because Sam immediately
going Rook D3 and forcing The Rook trade
and after The Rook trade Sam recaptures
with the bishop I feel like with only
one pair of books on the board it's
harder to create chances but the engine
was indicating this move Queen D5 and it
was still giving a pretty sizable
Advantage for black the point is that
you attacked the pawn on A2 and if the
bishop drops back and defends it all of
a sudden there's this tactic Rook takes
F2
Rook takes F2 Queen D1 checking issue
and now simply Queen takes B1 the point
is that the Rook can't move because you
get checkmated on G1 if you give a check
on B8 and King Escape escapes to H7
whatever it was Magnus almost played
that move but no he went for a queen
trade but then he did a half hash his
favorite tactic which he's been telling
me every day about he's stopped one
short uh one square short right he
stopped one square short and now Sam has
gotten his King out now this is a dry I
don't think Magnus is any realistic
winning chances anymore uh one defensive
approach for Samus to play F3 and create
an anchor point for his Bishop I think
Magnus is going to try
but that Sam should draw this a hundred
times out of 100. I agree with you I
think this one we can leave for now uh I
think Sam he has had some much more
serious questions to answer in this game
than this end game uh where the opposite
color Bishops should make his times
quite easy we also see Magnus there uh
who seems to be already resigning
himself to only getting a draw here of
course he always wants the full point
but they it probably won't happen but
that leaves the door open for one man to
potentially catch him and delete and
that is shakirov
it is and
we will take a look at his game and it
does seem unfortunately for Prague that
things have once again taken a turn for
the worse
for black how has that happened and why
is that the case yes I think frog is
just losing here
yeah this is the key moment we were
discussing this move F6 Prague playing
G5 so he's trying to go G4 mamigirov
stops him and now Prague did go F6 but
after Rook C5
there is a very important distinction
between the pawn remaining on G7 or
sorry the pawn remaining on G6 what is
that distinction so after absolute
stroke C5 let's figure it out here
oh I see it here after Rook d8 he takes
F6 Knight takes F6 rookie five turkey go
King F7 everything's fine right now
let's compare this to the same exact
position with the inclusion of G5
imagine if the pawn is on G5 here do you
see a difference well there's Rook F5
and that one's at night
and I'm pretty sure that that is the
reason not maybe something uh Prague
overlooked Rook d8 you have six Knight
F6 let's check
yeah that's that's the subtlety the
presence of the square is what disallows
black from
friends tonight because of course the
the night the White Knight is covering
D6 so
wow sometimes then it's incredible these
Pawn pushers you just push them one or
two squares and it makes such a huge uh
difference huge ponzer the soul of Chess
and you see why I mean these square
square control is so important Prague
was forced to uh double clutch it with
F5 but now chakra just comes around he
takes the pawn is The Situation
stabilizes he's got connected passers
and see the Knight on D5 is just not
stable there's no Pawn that anchors the
Knight so it's really only a matter of
time before white dislodges it it might
take a shotgun a good amount of time uh
but he brings his King up he goes Rook
C6 and Now Products position starts to
collapse he's gone Rook C8 I actually
think either Rook takes or six but
probably even better is to take on C8
and now you probably don't want to go D5
due to Knight B6 and White's
overextended but the engine was
suggesting a really strong move H4 the
point is that after G4 you redirect your
knight either to F4 to E3 you get
control over the D5 square and
essentially you essentially and
eventually uh you're gonna play D5 and
once you do the game is over so shock
rear is on the doorstep here yeah he's
going to take some time still has 13
minutes on the clock to decide does he
want to trade works here
um other moves might also be appealing
but I think he will go for the work
trade
yeah I mean the the alternative is Rook
takes H6
and this is quite a bit more messy after
Rook C2 I think soccer is calculating
this
but uh these positions these positions
can get a little bit hairy I mean black
wants to take on A2
and then black will have his own far
Advanced passer I I think shotgun is is
trading yeah I think this is not
something you want to allow even if even
if you knew that objectively it is still
winning
um I think yeah The Rook trade is what's
gonna happen here Prague also has close
to no time at all on the clock still six
moves to make but I don't think it
matters here
um I think Shaq is headed for victory
and let's go back to maybe to visit and
Nils we haven't been there in a while
for sure let's see how big it is going
about process of improving his position
is he making progress
it appears that he is making some
progress by the way look at the clock
situation here and we still have 10
moves to make 10 moves yeah this is
basically a Blitz game in the next 10
moves
um with it okay so you want B3 he
expanded on the queen side he decided to
get oh yeah he did get the bishop back
to F4
Rook after reinforcing the bishop once
again and then he got his King to A3
and this is the position on the board
now white can continue the process of
bringing the king up Nils I think is
trying to get his Knight around to E4 so
he is doing his absolute best to create
active counter play and that is what you
have to do particularly given that it is
quite low on time white does have the
very interesting move Bishop F3 here
with the idea of meeting Knight D6 with
a check on H5
forcing the king onto an undesirable
Square either there's going to be 96
check or if King E7 what it's going to
take and then shove that pawn down with
F6 96 and F7 is coming up end of King f8
you get mated that's a very cute
checkmate
wow yeah so that F Pawn is on the
dangerously close Bishop F3 definitely a
one option for visit can he also
continue the king is King B for an
option
it definitely is and Knight D6 has to be
evaluated and calculated
if you keep pushing with King C5 man I'd
be scared I'd be scared of this I'd be
scared of something like this
and white could definitely get mated
here I mean the engine is giving a
pretty unclear assessment after Bishop
ah so in time pressure I don't think
that it's gonna go for it
but Bishop F3 is not an easy move to
spot that's kind of a weird maneuver and
you have to realize that Knight takes F3
of course is in White's favor because
that would involve giving away Black's
only good piece yeah and also I mean we
talked about this the last time we we
were here I asked you why is the engine
giving such a big Advantage now it's
giving an even bigger Advantage close to
plus four and well I'll ask you later
because with it has just made a move and
it's seafood and Magnus is drawn by the
way officially sorry to interrupt you
Fiona no not at all let's see if we can
still catch the players at the board no
they were made a fast exit but a great
result uh for Sam and these two Sam also
will be rewarded for his efforts with
the PCR test but on in all seriousness a
great effort uh by by Sam
indeed and sorry to interrupt you they
just wanted to clarify that game is also
a draw we've got three draws so far uh
now we can go back to the video game
because we have an explosion on the
board fitted has gone C4
decided to strike precisely at this
moment because the Rook on G8 can no
longer join the center uh the knights on
E8 and the Knight cannot come to D6
because you're going to get your Bishop
trapped after C takes D5 three minutes
on the board on the clock for Niels this
is so hard to defend man so what are
your options now after C4 I guess we
can't really capture it upon or can we
you probably I mean you can try I'm
worried though that after Knight takes
C6 there's going to be this oh no white
wins Rook a knight takes E5 check
Rook takes you two and then Bishop D5
wins The Rock I mean these tactics
they're just everywhere there's no
escape and then especially in a position
like this with pieces all over the world
by the way we are only on move at 30. C4
was moved 31 so Nils has 10 moves to
make
yeah that's going to be rafi's probably
has to play Knight C7 and support the
the D5 Pawn with everything that he's
got of course that's not what he wanted
he wanted that Knight to get active but
vidit just immediately striking cutting
nipping the counter play in the bud
after Knight C7 Vivid is going to have
to find a way to keep improving so let's
have a look at that Knight C7
and how do we increase the pressure here
for white
well the first question is do we does
video want to go C5 and then
does you want to aim for B4 B5 oh Nils
will definitely go A5 in this case to
stop before okay that's one option
another option is just to make some sort
of a neutral move you could still play
Bishop F3
but but let's see what Niels does I mean
if he plays Knight C7
then we'll discuss the possibilities
prevented he's still thinking he's now
down to two minutes
yeah looking dire Knight C7 is there
another way Knight C7 is the only way to
defend the pawn right I think it is yeah
I just don't see another way to
reinforce the pawn and that it is
threatening just to take the bishop and
then to take on D5
what could Niels be contemplating
yeah Rook takes G2 is out of the
question because the Knight is always
capable of taking the bishop at the
right moment
I think he's gonna go Knight C7 it's
just the the time situation is
so concerning here in such a difficult
position
surely he must be considering some
Alternatives because otherwise it
doesn't make any sense not to play
Knight C7 immediately I'm confused
kneel's down to a minute and a half
she is he's freezing and well D take C4S
I mean I that's not the easiest line to
calculate just because of how much is
going on there yeah I completely agree
with you there must be some option
that's catching his eye
and now he's down to a minute
I mean it's so problem one of the
problems for needs is we saw that white
pieces can create a lot of threads there
are a lot of tactics in the air but look
at the white King on A3 that is so safe
there so unfortunately for Nils there
are just no tactical opportunities for
him and tonight Trump in the other
direction like gs7
seven wait a minute Knight takes C6 and
C takes D5 what and vidit is as confused
as I am
takes takes and it's the game just I
think the game's just over that's it
no this is this is just collapsed
because if C5 you just go D6 and Bishop
D5 check kind of like then four has been
bidded yesterday no this is uh I think
Niels is just gonna resign after Knight
takes C6 and NCD
and as you said I mean with it looking
confused as well if we put this on the
the board one more time after Knight
takes
takes I guess there was not any time and
visit is reaching out I think he is
going to take on C6 there is no way to
take on that five and and here yeah
Bishop either Bishop takes E5 or even
just DC is also winning and and there he
goes we zoomed in just in time to see
Knight takes q6 appear on the board
no I'm not sure what it is Nils hallucin
maybe we'll find out what he wanted to
do after CD
but maybe it was just Panic you just
didn't didn't spot Knight C7 and yeah
after Knight C7 black black was
surviving it the game wasn't totally
over that's the problem though with
getting yourself into this kind of time
pressure in a bad position it's a double
whammy and look it means like
I mean it really looks like what you
were saying he must have missed
something easy because he's now shaking
his head uh and in this belief
yeah he's got the the what was I
thinking head shake yeah what
total hallucination here and that it is
going to win another bounce back we've
had a lot of people with a scoring
bounce back wins vetted after that very
painful loss yesterday against van
Forest big big win today and very
convincing game straight out of the
opening for against Nils for sure and
visit and Anish giri if Anish can win
his game the two friends advancing hand
in hand both of them looking to get to
five out of eight but at the top uh
while Magnus he's on five and a half at
the moon but he is closing in uh I think
we'll stay here for now because we might
just see a resignation Nils is not even
looking anymore so much at the board but
I think he was looking at the score
sheet which we see happen so often and
this look of where did this go wrong
yeah he's been really struggling to find
his footing in the tournament he's had
problems in the opening is a very
creative repertoire a lot of ideas but
they haven't been working this
tournament
and uh you know the kind of opposition
that he faces is absolutely brutal in
that regard and now I think just D takes
C6
yeah but this is this is totally
resignable takes and you can take with a
rook or take with a bishop actually it
really doesn't even matter
is a little bit too far Advanced there
will be no stopping that so I think I
don't know if we should stay here I
don't think this is going to reach the
first uh time control because we're only
on move 33 so still seven moves to go
um maybe we can very quickly bring up
the bird's eye view and see what else is
happening elsewhere as we're inching
closer and closer to the first time
control
shakia has indeed decided to trade
sorry
no go ahead I just I didn't hear you but
yeah he is looking like he is going to
win his game same for V that where we
just came from uh do buff well we can go
there later because I think they are
past move 40 and let's quickly go back
well I guess I say panko is also on
Route 40 so shall we stick with with it
for now or where should we go let's
let's stick with a minute let's take it
because we're gonna see a lot of moves
there pretty fast I think I think we're
gonna see a result
I think so 2D take C6 is on the board
and after the work trade I think as you
were just saying Daniel vidit can
recapture whichever way he wants the
problem is just uh well white has two
extra pawns for starters and one of them
is on on C6
and by the way we're probably going to
see a result in the Shakura game very
shortly as well but there is the
resignation uh by Nils so another tough
game for him it really hasn't been his
tournament but for witted a huge bounce
back victory
indeed it is and a very convincing game
particularly in the opening when he
played that early E5 uh this will be a
very interesting opening to explore I'm
wondering who was in preparation and
when both players exited their
preparation but that early Knight F5
sacrifice very inventive sharp energetic
play by the Indian Grandmaster for sure
will deserved Victory indeed indeed and
let's go to mediaov maybe which you were
saying looks like it's going to end very
soon as well
it it does and uh the point here is that
um
okay so Knight takes B2 now chakra is I
think going to just collect all of the
pawns I think he's going to play Knight
takes F5
King E6 Knight takes H6 now Prague is
going to go after the a pawn so it looks
like black has counter play but that's
an illusion because white can go H5
after Knight takes A2 Knight takes G4 B3
it's literally just one threat as soon
as it stops black and resigned because
now these pawns are completely
Unstoppable I think chakra has
calculated that he's got plenty of time
and uh this is the pathway I think the
game is going to go down yeah and well
actually Knight takes B2 is move uh 39
so only one more move to make for shakia
and there he goes he has just captured
the pawn on F5 and he is going to get an
extra 50 minutes here which is and
plenty more than needed yeah he won't
need them he's going to take on it I
mean he's already calculated the line
till the end
and I despite the
the time uh the added time I think the
players will continue to execute their
moves pretty rapidly
and that leaves us with only well let's
go back then to yesi Panko and Anish or
do you want to start with the work
ending first
um no let's look at let's look at the
the honors game
we haven't missed too much except for
the the black pawns they're really
getting closer and closer
um
A4 is a move Daniel I'm a little bit
surprised to see it on the board because
if I were white I would feel like I have
to do something to actively stop the
black ponds but maybe there is just no
such move in this position
yeah and and I guess what Andre is
saying is that well at the moment he is
more or less stopping the pawns from
progressing further Gary could play H3
but that could end up being in fact that
is counterproductive it gives the Knight
this huge Square on G3 and now why does
the one who's playing for a win and if
you play G3 then The Rook well actually
it might be the case that Andre wants to
sacrifice on G3 this might be the end
game that Andre is going for the Lesser
evil and yes black is up a pawn but
winning this is going to be very
difficult White's Rooks are active and
so giri might end up delaying G3 and
instead sort of playing that cat and
mouse game on the on the Queen's head
maybe throwing in p65 just making some
improvements uh and and milking
asapanko's clock
yeah it's very interesting uh well yes
panko he has just gotten in his extra 50
minutes so plenty of time now but it can
go down fast and well let's check in
with the last game and that is uh duboff
against Duda
and it looks like indeed Daniel has
found uh his way to to a draw here
it it does look like that it does look
that way indeed and he actually decided
to go back to F2 uh rather than forward
to E4 but it's similar set of ideas now
here's the thing
what approaches does black have black
has two plans he can try to get this
King to B8 or he can try to push the H
Pawn and neither of them produce the
desired effect so after H5 the king will
come to G2
if you play H4 y can push E4 and then if
you play H3 check this is the crucial
Part White cannot take on H3 of course
because of Rook H1 but white just hides
behind the pawn this is a famous idea
and
you're inevitably going to get
liquidation you're going to get a
position like this
and then this Pawn on G6 is a big big
strength because White's always going to
be able to win G7 at his convenience
uh so that's one option and if sorry if
just in this line if the moment that
white hides on H2 in this line that we
were just looking at what if black In
This Moment tries to bring the king
yeah so so it's going to be the same
idea what's going to go F5 and black
needs to be careful of this in fact at
this point Pike has to liquidate because
if you go to C8 after F6 White's already
winning white breaks through
so uh yeah very interesting to see that
even black here cannot take all the
Liberties and let's look at the other
possibility that black has which is to
bring the king
so again you don't want to go E4 because
of Rook H1 and then the skewer so you
want to start with King G2 and if King
C8 here come the pawns E4 King B8 yeah
The Rook has to move away but if the
king starts moving up toward the Rook
white already plays F5 and again White's
already better so this threat of pushing
the pawn to F6 essentially forces black
sting to remain in the center and on the
king side that means that blacks uh play
essentially evaporates Duda is coming to
that realization right now and really
yeah kudos to Duba for incredible
defense he really just gave him no
chances and big has prepared a little
quiz for us uh the quiz is called guess
the language oh man
okay
let me think about that
is that
could that be Prague it's hard to really
hard to say what do you think I think
that's I was thinking yes it Pinko maybe
but the panko yeah they're tall prices I
don't know how tall frog is maybe Prague
yeah maybe you're right
it could be Geary I'm gonna go with
Prague though let's see
I think you're right then yeah and Shaq
is making the suspense untenable get out
of there yes oh my God
yeah this is how I know I've earned my
rightful place as a commentator
Frank I mean we're just having a bit of
fun here but of course he is in a some
uh in a dire situation uh with a
position that is just less than this one
here do buff as you've just shown us
he's done a great job
of not losing his school after
um The Fast Draw that we were expecting
slipped into a position upon down
um but now yeah as you said Duda is
coming to the realization that he is
running out of tries here
yeah and it's totally understandable
that he's taking as long as he is uh
these types of positions
you know they're very sharp they're
possible to calculate because the number
of options for both sides is quite
limited but uh dubov putting faith in
his own calculation and rightfully so
for sure let's go back uh quickly to my
media of maybe we update that one last
time and maybe we'll take a quick break
after that so let's go back here nothing
much has happened Risa as you called
shakia just taking all those King side
pawns and
um if black goes after A2 as you are
highlighting and tries to use his own B
Pawn white is just going to bring the
the king to help stop the beep on yeah
this is a very easy line to calculate B3
King D2 and then if white black pushes
yeah H6 A4 H7 and black is not in time
black tries to stop the pawn with his
own king of course White's got way too
many past spawns so E6 check is simply
overwhelming and then yeah very shortly
we're going to be hearing from Reddit
and let's go there immediately
fit it she just beat new scandalius
um it was a very eventful game
um like in the opening it seemed like a
very crazy game as well
yeah it was very pretty to play this G4
I think this is the second game in the
200 G4 has been kind of a surprise and
it was very nice Knight G3 Knight F5 he
has to be accurate to you know get a
good game which he did not play I think
the best moves and I got a good
Advantage after that so that it was all
preparation
uh until some point I mean I don't think
you can just play G4 over the board
um
and uh and after that like what were the
key moments of the game
yeah
um after that
um I'm I for sure knew I was better but
the problem was I had so many choices
and it was not easy to pick the best
move because I don't know which is the
best first of all and everything looks
approximately uh similar but I did allow
him some defensive chances in time
pressure for example he could sacrifice
Bishop F5 and then my Rook is trapped on
F5 something like this of course white
is of better but yeah it would have been
much easier for him once he allowed me
this bind with Pawn on F5 and my knight
24 then it's just positionally very very
good for me
um I think yesterday you lost your game
right so like uh was it hard to bounce
back
it was very uh hard yesterday because
um Jordan had played a new idea
um and I reacted well I found all the
best moves until certain point
and then okay I misplayed he misplayed
something like this but at some point I
was just better in fact
and the problem was I was very very low
on time and because of that I made some
moves which are not uh let's say 2700
level
and that allowed him chances it was very
painful for me to have that loss
yesterday especially because I think I
played good until a certain point and I
felt like
I should have at least drawn the game
um you're here with your coach uh Alan
Greenfield how is
um how is your collaboration
uh he's uh wonderful like I know him
since I think 2004 or 2005 he had come
to my place in nasik and he trained me
when I was I think 2100 or 2200
something like this so we have a very uh
long relationship and it's great to have
him here right he just gives me a lot of
positive energy and strength
um a couple of weeks ago you tweeted
something about World Chess and like the
sponsor logos
um has this issue been been resolved
I think some talks have been going on
I don't have the complete information so
I don't think it's best for me to
comment on it without knowing what's the
status going on my team is handling it
actually and while looking at your shirt
is there still some space left for new
sponsors always please write to me
okay well good luck and enjoy your essay
thank you
sponsor with it get in touch with him I
thought it was really amazing what he
said he's been working with Alan
greenfeld since he was 20 rated 2100
that is a long-standing history
that is really is an incredibly long
collaboration always heartwarming when
you have that kind of a relationship and
it really shows that it's it's not about
necessarily the rating of the coach it's
more about the quality of the
relationship it's about the level of
trust that you have and the level of
experience that your coach has so great
stuff from Vivid and of course a
phenomenal win against Niels randallius
absolutely bouncing back straight away
uh Dania we're gonna go uh on a quick
break we still have three games going
here in round eight so don't go anywhere
and we will back soon
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
yeah Robert
can you eat devaretsky's in-game manual
to us one more time yeah no we gotta get
up
[Applause]
[Laughter]
it was you like I was I was gonna do it
but then he's like yeah yeah
um you ready
what did I say I told you let's do it
all right you know what they say though
what happens in Salt Lake stays in Salt
Lake yeah
cheers to my Super Jam friends it's been
good the world championship
on chess.com
let's do this
[Music]
let's chug the whole beer
aggressive whoo
yeah that was that was I was
oh yeah I'm great
round two
[Music]
thanks Robert
can you read devaretsky's endgame manual
to us one more time yeah
[Laughter]
okay okay okay
I just actually didn't expect you to do
it that time I thought you was a
one-time yeah yeah please okay okay I'm
just trying to ad-lib with what feels
next yeah of course it feels natural
wait so we should expect that next yeah
okay just so I'm mentally prepared yeah
okay
what is this
it's eggs
I want an omelette with Bree just
[ __ ] easy
you eat it
wasn't expecting that that wasn't either
we could turn a little bit on the
shoulder there
um the uh faster card and unibrow I just
want to thank my sponsors uh very much
for all they do to to promote chess
um sounds like a great future credit
card but faster card yeah wasn't it
faster hard
[Laughter]
it's a dead card
y'all are respecting the wood a little
too much
not faster hard Bobby oh boy I I can't
be with you two anymore
oh okay
I mean I think it's I think it's
hilarious and don't you think people
would would buy this
no I don't think anyone's gonna buy that
that's the stupidest I've ever seen in
my life
okay
I guess that's it
all right that's it that was great by
the way keep it rolling okay same thing
yeah and we are Denny who is that guy
who's that
he didn't come in with you guys
no
we're gonna be right back
Bobby yes Robert
can you read devaretsky's in-game manual
to us one more time yeah yeah
I just can't
[Music]
so funny
isn't it cool when I predict the moves
you're gonna say because we all see
things in the same way and the same
speed on this show Isn't that cool when
we do that
it doesn't make me very happy
and let's bring up the analysis board as
we do that so Yvonne can give us her
thoughts on the uh on the Pet Shop go
ahead ifan
uh well yeah actually that's a very good
question because I was firstly trying to
fubby yeah Danny
my throat's still dry
you're like you've already you've had
five glasses of water okay you remember
what happened last time
my throat's still dry
you've already had five glasses of water
and you remember what happened last time
it was an accident you peed your bed
you're looking fresh man all six of them
again dude your haircut just looks great
wait did we start the bit yeah
if Black's A6 Pawn was transported let's
say
goodnight guys
good night dad probably
one more time
I said I said it should I not set it
I think it's funny if we both say
goodnight Dad I mean poppy but we need
to be in sync
[Music]
hello and welcome back to round eight
here at the Tata steel chess tournament
and Dania we still have three games
remaining although the first one that we
expect to be over maybe it's a close
toss-up between
memoranduda but they will end in two
very different ways
indeed they will looking over at the top
left we have mamad yarov and Prague and
that game is going to end any second
let's start with that one let's go and
sort of chronological order
oops and let me pull that up for you
here it is
okay so it is a case of too many past
pawns we've all been there but Prague
actually doing as good as good of a job
as he can
uh sending his knife back to try to stop
the h-bond that's the pawn he really has
to stop now here's the point Fiona H6
would be a terrible blunder because of
B3 and it turns out that white skin can
no longer stop the passer well because
it's going to promote because the Knight
defends the promotion Square so chakra
has to remain very cautious
uh and he has to play King D2
Prague is going to give a check and then
swing the Knight back to G5 the reason
this is completely winning for white is
because Shakura is going to go H6 and
then Knight F6 and he's just gonna push
all of these Pawns of the board and
they're completely overwhelming I have a
question could I not have gone instead
of going to C2 could I have gone to D3
instead with the idea of maybe bringing
the king to C4 and then just try and
push the d-pawn immediately
excellent point I think this is even
more accurate because now you just stop
you also just stop both Pawns uh at the
same time this is even more efficient I
completely agree yeah this is this is
even better and shocker has indeed
gotten King detail yeah indeed and well
this game I think will be over
um very shortly as you said just too
many uh pawns to deal with and Prague he
knows it uh so we'll come back here but
for now let's quickly go to the The Rook
ending between Duda and uh duboff and
see is uh do they are making any tries
here
Judah has been taking very long amounts
of time really trying to figure
something out and to no avail he's just
played H5 going down the first path that
we had described uh Daniel can simply go
King G2 and the moment that Duda gets
his Pawn to H4 white can send the epon
down the board
and ultimately black can
transform this into a position where
he's up upon the issue is just that it's
the wrong pawn and even after something
like Rook A7 and Rook takes G7 not 700
takes G7 White's Pawn is active enough
to guarantee an easy draw and this game
will also end very very short shortly
Here Comes King G2 H4 and I am fully
expecting Daniel to go E4 in this
position preparing F5
so those two games we expect to end
quite soon and that leaves us with
Andrea sepenko against Anish giri and I
heard during the break that apparently
Magnus mentioned uh off the Record so it
wasn't during the interview but that he
was quite impressed here actually with
anisha's idea in the opening
yeah this night I mean this is cool uh
Bishop sacrifice in 95 and uh
obviously at a super Grand Master Level
uh you're almost always fine with the
draw of the black pieces so uh you have
the freedom to play these kinds of ideas
that contain within them the possibility
of A4 straw but look at this Tanya after
A4 Anish has really gone into the tank
here
for probably well over half an hour at
this point incredible
and he's definitely thinking about
whether to go G3 I mean that's that's
the key decision just to go G3 does he
try to improve
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
game than a black victory
uh but it's it's a very hard position to
evaluate and Geary not showing any signs
that he's ready to make a move just yet
yeah so uh Anish still contemplating
I think really what he's thinking about
most likely is just this end game here
what are his uh winning his winning
chances uh here
and
if we
I think we should we just keep jumping
around uh waiting for one of the other
two games to finish I guess the first
one that will finish is Mama diarov
against uh Prague as Prague has just
given the check on e4 so we can go there
and Shah he's going your way King thank
you
yeah no I I definitely can do through
this more precise uh but this should be
plenty good enough as well
yeah I mean probably could probably
start with a five here
H6 Knight G5 Knight F6 no it's over well
A4 H7 Knight F7 and the Knight
temporarily stops the pawns but now
White Snake can Circle back to F4 in
order to dislodge the game so that white
goes E6 and it's only a matter of time
before white spawns promote you know
white pushes any of the pawns actually
G4 was also good there
and this one will end uh quite
quite shortly and really there isn't
much to say about this position which
one would you like to focus more on
which will we focus more on a niche and
shall we see on the bird's eye if you do
both maybe that's actually the first one
to finish because dubov has gone yeah a
lot of moves are being played here
and I actually think that uh Jan is
going to go rookie one in this position
uh let's switch over to that game so
rookie one in this position I think he's
going to play
or Rook F1 I mean Rook F1 is the other
way that he can win a pawn temporarily
takes takes but here actually white has
a very nice idea rookie eight check King
E7 and Rook A7 check and this draws on
the spot because King F6 runs into Rook
F7 check
that was probably a better choice to go
to E1 yes or do that
definitely and then we're expecting and
there Comes The Rook I think he's gonna
eat one indeed yeah he's gone rookie one
Rook takes A2 is about to happen oh and
address has been offered and agreed
and another and Mommy Diary of also once
simultaneously had two results at the
same time
we had to drive this game and soccer are
winning at the same time
is so two results we see those two
players Daniel he made life difficult
for himself and Prague they didn't waste
any time Jesus we come back here and
they're both gone already and yeah do
both uh one more time we thought this
one was gonna be over hours ago then one
Reckless moment uh by Duo of overseeing
Buddha's possibility to go B5 and he had
to suffer for a lot longer than planned
but in the end holding on to the draw
yeah good stuff from Dubai very
professional attitude not losing his
mind you know when he blundered that
pawn uh and just proving the dictum that
all Rook end games are drawn to begin
with
so a a relief for sure relief for Daniel
dubov and for Duda solid result going
into the rest day of draw so we've got
two decisive games so far I'm at the art
of beating Prague and vidit beating
grendelius neither result particularly
surprising but for Mom and you are a
great game it was a little bit
topsy-turvy he gave products some
chances in the end game but it was never
really in doubt yeah and uh well with
his victory media of he is now has
joined a certain Magnus Carlson in the
lead he will be making the most of that
recipe I'm just trying to think have the
two
played yet I think not but my no I don't
think so
and that's always a very interesting
matchup
for sure I think Magnus used to and
actually Dania I was just having a quick
look they will be playing two days from
now after the rest day with Carson with
the white pieces so that will be a huge
huge game coming up
yeah Magnus will definitely try to make
the most out of that game and for Prague
it's been a very difficult experience
experience at Tata steel so far but once
again we we have to keep reiterating how
young he is and how nowadays very often
the expectations are are just not very
realistic you know and and I think
people forget that experience is still
incredibly important even though uh
Grandmasters are getting younger and
younger uh it's one thing to have a
certain rating it's another thing to
have a wealth of experience playing
these types of tournaments absolutely
for sure no matter what happens here in
the remaining a few rounds Prague is
going to walk away with so much more
experience and not just that but also
the fact that he will have faced Magnus
over the world in a classical game and I
think he said it was also his first game
against a couple of other players maybe
Fabiano or some others that is going to
help him so much in his future
development and and um at least he has
that one win against Niels nobody's
gonna take that away from him because
sometimes this is an event oh and we
will be hearing from
shortly so we're getting ready to jump
there and after we come back from the
interview I'd be curious to if we'll see
if we can try and zoom in on a nisha's
clock and find out just how much time
has he spent here
a quite a crazy game like what happened
in the opening
okay I played very interesting move in
Queen A4 it's normally his Queen never
go early I mean queen E4 but okay I
played good move interesting of course
it's not very good move or it's just
interesting move to play for win
uh and I think after move 10 11
it's absolutely winning position for
white because it's it's black kings it
was very bad but uh we played I think
more 40 moves because I missed something
I don't know maybe I don't miss but I
just want to play accurately because
maybe some maybe
I don't know maybe I choose not very
good lines I mean it was looks very bad
for black but we go end game in game it
was very bad for black and we play I
played Just accurately and I won
fragananda is so young and you're you're
by the veteran of of the fields
um
do you change your strategies to play
against younger players compared to
older players
okay it's for me it's not easy to change
my style my style is every time to play
interesting chess and Fighting Chess uh
it's not easy to change style when you
play Young or older all this player but
I just love to play chess for Fighting
Chess and very interesting cheers for
this reason it was not important is
Yonkers not young I just play normal
just
um in the next rounds you will face the
co-leader Magnus Carlsen
um how do you look forward to uh to that
game
okay against the word number one of
course is world champion he's very
strong he's of course uh very strong
chess player of course we will play
just just uh
it will be not easy because also black I
will play with black but we will try
we'll play good chess I will try to show
my best uh
so maybe we'll see I mean
I am ready for
to play good chess and to try to play uh
I mean I don't know it's not easy to say
something before the game but I will try
to show my best what is your overall
result against Magnus I I remember of
course that game you played in bill
which was like the start I mean the the
first game before his long winnings or
not losing streak
okay uh not very good results I think I
want
just two times in my chess career
against him but I lose six games maybe
minus four minus five or more like I
don't know but more than 10 draws okay I
think everyone have a minus against
Magnus is because he's worth number one
uh but this is only one game it's
different tournaments and uh okay I mean
I don't want to think about negatives
and I will try to play good chess okay I
wish you all the best thank you very
much thanks
I always love hearing from such a great
guy such a fantastic jazz player and
Daniel he's not too stressed it seems
about his upcoming game against the
Magnus Carlsen
he is so nice and the reason I know him
very well is because uh back when I was
living in California uh he would come
for several summers in a row to the Bay
Area uh to teach at a camp that I also
taught at so we met we had a lot of fun
conversations he never let me pay for
him to pay for his lunch he is just uh
so much fun great company and obviously
an absolute genius chess player and a
great Blitz player of course as well I
had a lot of fun getting crushed by him
in Blitz
for sure I also thought it was really
interesting what he said about today's
game against Prague you know did he do
anything different because his opponent
is so young and he said no young oh it
doesn't really matter I just play my
chess and I said it's difficult to
change his his fighting style and it is
what we love to see and he is in the
joint lead
um meanwhile Anish Gary after a long
long thing he has played the move A5
he has and he has went for option two uh
option one being the media G3 and I'm
gonna say a word
that I think most people are not going
to associate with this position but
allow me to explain the word
what are you what are you saying White's
got 800 pieces left on the board well
here's the thing let's take every one of
White's pieces consider its role and see
how moving it away from its post changes
the position to Black's favor The King
The King obviously holds back the pawns
if you move the king back to G1 then the
move G3 becomes a lot stronger G3
followed by King G4 is extremely scary
uh NY doesn't have the possibility of
sacking back on G3 okay The Rook on f8
The Rook on f8 holds down the F Pawn if
you move it away from f8 uh black is
going to play either G3 or at some point
in the move F5 and if you go over Cafe
black Advance is one file upward which
is obviously undesirable okay what about
the other Rook well if the other Rook
moves it's the same exact problem the
move F5 becomes a very serious issue so
that essentially leaves white only with
his Queen side pawns and if he goes
before blackened just reinforce the
problem with the move B6 and I believe
that white is actually in zugason here
and even if white goes after the B Pawn
black doesn't care F5 and if Rook takes
B6 I was calculating this during the
interview I think after F4 Black's pawns
are completely overwhelming this has
been a fantastic decision by Gary and
his time was not spent in vain
wow I mean I did not uh when you said
let me tell you one word I thought it
might be
and like I'm sure many other viewers I
thought how how is that possible but uh
yeah Andreas now finding himself in a
very uncomfortable position and some
concessions uh will have to be uh will
have to be made here
which of the moves you looked at do you
think is the the Lesser even
I think you should definitely start with
before and for the record I'm positive
that with top computer play this should
be a draw it just like I just have the
sense that if white plays with mega
accuracy these positions usually can be
saved but man oh man is this difficult
practically so I would throw this in why
would I throw this in because I feel
like at least this force is black to
weaken some of his pawns you know
and now okay the engine suggests the
Mover Rook A8 and the point of this is
that F5 is met with B takes A5 and now
black has a lot to worry about on the
queen side
I'm taking on A5
ah takes A5 takes A5 and network A8
makes perfect sense
so I'll play rookie five
and you can keep harassing me with Rook
C8
and probably I will close my eyes and
just start pushing these Pawns
takes an F4 this type of position I mean
this is so nasty to play
and this is not what I wanted and
instead if I don't go to C8 but I go
back behind the F Pawn
I mean this makes sense and then you can
just play a move by King H2 again
orienting yourself toward the sacrifice
and ultimately I guess black will have
to play g3 at some point and go for this
type of end game and then a move like
Rook D7 in order to get the Rook to D3
50. I mean white totally can save this
but I can also see Andre making one more
mistake and slipping into a lost
position
I also think that uh very often I don't
know if you would agree but Anish has
spent so long now on A5 and very often
we see that kind of being uh recip
what's the word reciprocated
and by white and
um because it is a very tough spot here
for Andre there's so many different
uh things I mean he always has to
calculate this ending that you were
talking about if a niche goes uh G3 does
he want to take that pawn probably yes
but so much uh to figure out here
and what I was going to say did the time
could at some point start ticking down
very fast because we are only on move 41
only one move has been made and forget
about reciprocating the time use because
B4 is on the board but maybe B4 was the
the first the more obvious and after
that things will get more tricky yeah I
think before is it's very natural to
throw this move in it's not going to
hurt
um for Anish I I guess eight takes
before is a viable candidate move
and after C takes before
I'm not really sure but the thing is
again it's black to move here and now
black is in a weird way kind of in
because if black plays B6 and tries to
wait well that's no good white creates a
past spawn of his own and this is the
last thing that you want to allow white
to do so I'm anticipating B6 and there
it is
B6 played quite quickly
and this is a big moment for for entree
he has to decide which PC is going to
move
and at the same time you cannot take too
long he can't really even take longer
than 15 minutes I would say on this move
if he drops below 20 minutes he's got 18
moves to make it's not gonna he's not
gonna make it happen so he has to keep
himself at least I would say 20 minutes
to calculate and maybe we can once again
here just try and go through all the
possible moves that white can make the
different pieces he can move because the
options are quite Limited
yeah and I think we can use the process
of elimination to prune uh the tree of
possible moves
um King H2 I I just I think this is
actually not such a dumb move I mean I
know it looks ridiculous to walk into a
fork but again if you know that you're
sacrificing on G3
um I think this is a viable candidate
moves and also the point is rookie three
check can be met with a rook athlete
very important otherwise you'd lose C3
um so that's one possibility and from
Black's perspective the computer
proposes the Smith Brook G6
uh with the idea of Defending F6 so that
this other Rook is going to be free to
move where will it move too well it can
go to E1 and activate itself or it can
go to E4 and start harassing White's
Queen side Pawns so I don't think Andre
is going to go King H2 though I just
don't see that happening I think he's
going to move this this real kind of
fate I think this is the Rook that he's
going to move and
probably he's going to play Rook B8 and
I think that we're going to see this
position on the board if I had to guess
which looks uh terrific terrifying to
let one more Pawn Advance uh but maybe
just not so many other options at Dania
while we wait for Andreas panko to make
what is a big decision we're going to
listen at what Sam had to say after
holding Magnus Carlsen to a draw
[Music]
some shankland you just played a draw
with Magnus Carlson
um it seems like you were pressing the
whole game like I was pressing I think
so I felt it was sort of back and forth
I mean at some point when I played uh
Bishop B2 Bishop before I had missed
some detail that I just can't go Roxy
one he has no takes A2 and it's at this
point I already felt like my position
was uncomfortable I calculate a lot of
direct lines with like Queen B3 with A3
and none of it was working
so I took C3 for damage control I
thought I was already a bit worse but
then I was very surprised that she took
with uh the bishop I thought taking with
the Rook was much stronger and then oh
it was basically fine pretty early on uh
but once I played e45 and then Knight D4
E6 at first I thought my position should
be very good but
then I started thinking after Queen
takes E6 check King h8 was on the board
and I didn't really
see a great way through it at some point
I was like wait how am I going to save
this F2 pawn and so
um
uh and then I actually missed a really
nice detail when I played Queen G3 I
thought that after Rook D7 I could go
Rook takes B7 uh with the point Rook
takes B7 Queen G6 is just draw on the
spot but after Rook takes B7 his Bishop
takes F2 check first is a very important
move order Rook takes F2 uh Rook takes
B7 Queen G6 Rook B1 check and I get
mated by Queen D1 at the end so after
that I was actually surprised that um
that he couldn't put more pressure than
he did it felt like it should be
unpleasant but I guess I held pretty
easily did you expect Magnus to play a
Gambit uh yeah I mean this is only sort
of a Gambit I mean uh but yeah like I I
didn't expect it at all of course uh I
wouldn't have played so terribly in the
opening I guess that maybe I would have
put some more pressure on if I knew this
was coming because I don't think this is
supposed to equalize but I haven't
checked it recently
over eight rounds in um how was your
tournament so far uh it's been lousy I
mean the uh so basically six of the
games have just been sort of normal
draws that's fine but the two games that
stand out is I was dead winning against
Neil scandalius and I drew that game and
then against vidit I got some very
unpleasant position and defended it all
the way to equality and then started to
relax the next thing you know so it
feels like if I'd been on better form
I'd be on plus one instead of minus one
so it's just been a frustrating event
especially to still be one listen you
know seven draws and a loss is not great
but I'm still think playing reasonable
Chess at some moments and certainly
enjoying the tournament it's really
great to play with such strong guys
um any plans for the rest day not really
I'm not even I'm not even sure how much
we're allowed to do but uh you know it's
I'll think about it I'm I haven't
thought about it yet okay thank you
and Sam Shanklin there despite the great
draw against Magnus Carlsen he's being
quite hard on himself Dania
yeah he always has been and you know
that's an ingredient uh necessary
ingredient for greatness and we saw that
he admitted he hadn't checked that line
in a while and you know magnus's opening
Choice had the desired effect but yeah I
I have to agree with Sam I think it was
back and forth I really I don't think
Sam Sam definitely wasn't better the
entire game if anything uh he was
concerningly slightly worse toward the
end and a great job just holding
everything together against Magnus never
an easy task for sure and I think he had
the right feeling that Magnus could have
put on more pressure there was this one
moment maybe later on we'll have a
chance to briefly go back there where
Magnus maybe could have put
um more uh problems than he did but for
now we have only this one game remaining
here in our masters group and Andrea
sepenko as you predicted he is still
pondering uh his next move after B6
yeah they're they're clearly at an
inflection point at a critical moment I
mean I don't envy Andre I'm just going
to sip my coffee and watch him uh make
this decision because
man I mean
between B takes A5 Rook B8 Rook A8 92
King H2 there's five or six candidate
moves and all of them could you could
see a case being made for all of them
and those are the hardest decisions to
make the ones where you really have
three or four options and it's hard to
calculate anything in this position it's
kind of a weirdly it's a weird position
where black has a bunch of improving
moves
so Andre's gonna have to trust his
intuition and I think the worst thing he
could do is is really go under 10
minutes I mean I don't see him defending
it for the next 18 moves if that happens
yeah for sure I mean it's always we
always feel we are so far away from the
next time control when we hit move 40
but it's gonna happen uh way faster
um especially if you're under issues the
minutes here take down so fast and 18
moves to make is a lot of moves at 27
minutes already isn't very much time for
all the moves he has to make when every
move is a crucial decision exactly and I
remember a game remember a game from the
I think 2000 15 us championship against
Ray Robson uh we got into a crazy time
scramble and then we barely made sudden
death on move 40. uh we both got 30
minutes and uh he thought for 29 of them
on his next move and then I thought for
28 of them and then the time scramble
literally continued so we got up went to
the bathroom refilled our coffees
back to work put the hell but back on
you know start working working on it
again it was a crazy incident and I
ended up losing the game that is crazy
but yeah I mean something very similar
is happening right now the players had
gotten 50 minutes and half of that
allocated extra time is already gone for
Andrea cipenko
yeah I mean the time just evaporates so
quickly when you when you when you're
thinking about these super complex
positions you can take five minutes on
on something and then realize there's an
easy reputation uh because things are so
hard to calculate and it's funny that
the move King H2 is a viable candidate
move that's a ridiculous looking move
and who would walk right into a fork and
yet that under some circumstances might
actually be the best move but for a
niche uh the thing that makes his task
easier is that he does have a pretty
clear pathway toward improving his
position he wants to play Rook G6 and
free up the other rook and he always has
the possibility of going G3 whenever he
wants to and essentially forcing Knight
takes G3
yeah frustration there for Andre he just
seems irked
you gotta feel sorry in a way for Andre
who's gotten himself into quite a bit of
trouble you also gotta have respect for
him making this decision early on to
play on
um but now he is gonna have to dig very
deep Dania we're going to take a quick
uh break and we'll be back with the
conclusion of this game in a few minutes
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
welcome again
for bending here in the Dorp in
vacancies
foreign
left
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
back to
harsh all of them
indeed Fiona a major major turn of
events
Let's uh debrief everyone on what just
happened and why black is now completely
winning if Anish finds the right pathway
now
after before B6 Andre deciding to take
and go Rook A8 and Fiona we explored
this option
Geary defending the pawn with rookie
five this is the critical moment Andre
had to return to f8 and anchor The Rook
once again to the f-bond but what did he
do he played them of Knight D2 well that
looks totally reasonable he's preventing
G3 he can't play G3 uh because there's
gonna be a four wait a second what I
just said is the lie you can play G3 why
can't you play G3 because after Knight
F3 check which Andre is banking on there
is the move King F4 and all of a sudden
white ends up in massive trouble if he
takes on E5 then black takes the Rook
with check after King takes E5 f2f takes
C5 this is of course winning because of
Black's past Pawns
okay well what are the other options
available to White if the Rook moves
aside then H3 Chuck wins the Knight The
Rook has to go to F1 and this is what
Andre was relying on
the move that I'm sure he missed
his H3 check brilliant move and I think
Anish
foreign
just to complete this line after King H3
G2 the game is simply Over The Rook is
attacked blackstroke is coming into G3 I
think einst sees this and if he plays
this line he is going to win this game
foreign
sorry my apologies I'm not muted I just
left the mic lying in my bag to dinner
now you're good
oh man this is like I was blind with now
I see
okay I'm back back in the game cool cool
okay so Anish is
yeah no I think I think we can hear you
now
I think so yeah although they should I
can hear you I'm just looking at the
chat
I'm not they're still saying that no I
am back I think I think they're telling
welcome welcome back everyone welcome
welcome welcome welcome
okay so again G3 wins the game on the
spot
can Anish calculate this line out
accurately and he's got
oodles and oodles of time and you see
this is where his time management comes
in so handy 29 minutes and he's reaching
out he does not need any of them there
it goes
and wow
what a win that is going to be I've
already sold it as a win of course the
game isn't over but now that Anish has
found G3 and of course we're curious to
see what is the reaction going to be of
Andrea sepenko
and yeah he's gonna play Knight F3 check
of course that move is absolutely forced
but did you see there the slight Shake
of the head a bit like we saw with Niels
earlier maybe some Shock as he now
realizes that he might have missed just
what you were showing there that line
with H3
and there are several possibilities for
what it is exactly that he missed it
might have been King F4 maybe he thought
that he hallucinated Knight takes E5
with Chuck and what I think one
shouldn't do is say oh well the computer
was giving it a draw to high depth how
could he have blundered like this let's
not forget that they've been playing for
five hours Andre has been suffering in
this end game for well over two hours
and uh these players are only human you
know you it's fat these are the kinds of
positions where the gap between computer
play and human play is perhaps the
widest these positions where there's a
million options they all look tempting
and uh no matter how sharp you are for
the human brain to work through the
complications is well not impossible and
it's also possible that he missed H3
just one more thing Fiona if the king
drops back to G1 the win is even more
straightforward but also very pretty G2
Rook F2 and now we want to sneak this
King right into that Gap there with King
G3 if Knight takes C5 that is very very
pretty Pawn mate indeed and if white
starts with Rook take streets you check
in order to get this Pawn off of H3 then
it is all very easy 95 fe5 and the game
is over black just pushes the the e-pawn
and in the event of Brook takes A5
there's Checkmate in two moves anisha's
gonna I need to calculate this in his
sleep he's seen it and you can see Andre
looking off to the distance really did I
just wonder that
and tough to see him he's gonna be in a
real hard spot tonight we talked about
this many many hours ago at the start of
the show and maybe we can very briefly
once again for the people who might have
joined us later Daniel just put that one
moment on the analysis board
um where uh Andre had an option he could
have gone for a Perpetual check
or first the Perpetual check anyway and
um we were both saying we wouldn't you
know be shocked if he if he went for the
draw it makes sense especially before
arrest that you were saying especially
with the white pieces you don't want to
go into the rest day on the loss and
this was the moment here after anisha's
move 95.
yeah and you know I was sure that he
would do it also because of the speed of
an issues play Andre knew that Anish was
still in this preparation and clearly
Andre wasn't so as gutsy as it was to go
for that end game
it might not have been the wisest
decision given how carefully Anish
studied this line so Knight take C5 uh
and black is forced to deliver Perpetual
checking G1 Queen G3 and uh there's
nothing black can do other than that if
black tries Bishop takes F2 white is
always going to have a move like this
and black has simply sacrificed too many
pieces and of course if Bishop takes E1
um then there is Queen takes F7 and
there's some other Queen G8 I don't
think this would have been in Yuri's uh
Fury's plans but
um
he went Knight H2 Sheltering his King
and after Queen G6 Bishop C2 Knight T3
uh Andre was essentially forced to give
up the F2 Pawn but in return he got a
queen trade and this is how it all began
these three pawns you know in my
experience almost any position like this
where you have these three pawns against
a piece these positions are so so
difficult to play even though the
computer initially even shows a tiny
little something for white I don't
believe it yeah and
um Andre probably now he is remembering
that moment uh hopefully he's not gonna
walk away thinking why didn't I I mean
we were all of course very happy to see
him uh play on it didn't pay off this
time but that's not to say that it never
pays off
and there's that F3 check and we are
going to see a new very quickly placing
F4 the move is absolutely forced
and there he goes King F4 is on the
board
yeah no it's uh
I mean provided that he finds H3 what
you don't want to do if you're a niche
after Rook F1 uh the move rookie 2 check
uh does not win because of King G1 and
white threatens a discovery with Knight
D4 and you should have seen it so
yeah I think oh it's going to transpire
and yeah just you got a feel for free
maybe the position was difficult uh
anyway when the the blunder happened
with my D2
um you were saying the engine could
probably hold that with best play but
here in uh into the six hour
um of play with limited time on the
clock I think he was already in a dive
situation but now the game is really
coming to a brutal conclusion here
without question yeah it's White's
defenses come to a screeching halt after
Rook F1 H3 check just to show that key
line again what is the purpose of H3
what happens if I take takes it well
this is just a deflection sacrifice you
go G2 white can never take the Rook
because black takes on F1 with mate
and if if Rook G1 then you lose the
knight in a fork F2 there's multiple
things that black can do so Rook G3
check is winning but uh not as clear as
the move King E3
with a beautiful detail now this attacks
The Rook uh White's Knight still can't
move from F3
and if rotation 2 King takes F3
sacrificing The Rook but of course there
is Checkmate uh awaiting on H5
some really stunning lines here uh that
Andre must have just missed we don't
know what exactly was it H3 he missed
um
was it just sort of a slip a blind spot
like it happened to Fabiano a couple of
days ago against Anish but all I know
Anish he is gonna get a third
consecutive win to move back to plus two
very impressive and Anish he's had a
topsy-turvy event quality wise
um even Fabi mentioned that Anish really
didn't play well against him at the
first part of the game
um and and I guess wait I knew she has
three wins in a row around now right
three wins in a row yeah he lost one
game earlier in the tournament
um against Magnus and which was of
course his first loss here in Vikings to
Magnus and I said moving back to plus
two but that is incorrect because he
wasn't there so he's moving at two plus
two and putting himself in contention
here with five rounds to go
yeah and this really might be anisha's
best game so far this tournament
excluding the game against dubop which
was
um so perfect that you know
there's just nothing to talk about it
was it was Flawless uh but excluding
that game I'm kidding of course he won
uh by walk over after simply playing one
D4 uh but this was a very smooth game he
prepared extremely well and the way that
he handled this end game textbook
textbook fashion the way he carefully
pushed his pawns and then the moment
Andre uh you know and particularly you
know what I'm very impressed by is the
move A5 this idea to induce suswang how
many people would just automatically
play G3 how could you not play G3 and
yet I'm just realizing that The Rook end
game was likely to be a draw and finding
this idea of inducing Zug Swan from a
practical standpoint an incredibly nasty
nasty idea that and ends up winning the
game for him and Andre is going to make
a couple more moves here but
the game is hurtling towards this
conclusion there comes Rook F1
H3 check that's the key move and I I
don't think Anish is going to spend too
long it's really I mean we saw the
despair there on the asepanco's uh face
this is not he was having a brilliant
tournament he came into this as white
um but and here it comes here it goes
yep double checking
yeah and there's no need to rush too
much but Anish is not one to take 20
minutes when he's calculated everything
out there's a point at which you just
gotta trust yourself and further
quadruple checking becomes essentially
counterproductive yeah of course he
still has plenty of time on the clock
but I think he calculated all of this uh
when he went G3 and now the look to the
side just double triple checking and H3
will probably be played I would say
within the next 30 seconds even probably
yeah and I was just toying around with
there's a lot of lines that involve
black sacrificing one of the Rooks in
order to get uh checkmate with the other
one
but let's wait let's hold off until
Onish plays H3 and then
I'll show them
I mean Andre might simply resign after
H3 yeah that's also entirely possible
the final moment it's funny to see a
niche with the The Mask under it under
the chin of course with liner
um the players don't have to wear a mask
when they're sitting at the board unless
there has been a close contact
uh so I think we've all heard plenty of
that and Vic is telling uh informing us
as well that H3 is the only move
um as well for for black so really we
would be very well the only move to win
and there he goes H3 is on the board
there it is
yeah H3 is the only move as we discussed
um rookie 2 was actually gave up the
entire get they gave up the entire game
all right
so let's see what Andre chooses will he
resign will he take the pawn or will he
go King G1 all three options I think are
equally likely I think King G1 is the
like list
I agree with you I also think he might
just uh resign we saw from his face
sometimes we don't even need to see the
position sometimes having the camera
is enough
um and he understood I think as soon as
G3 appeared on the board what he had
done
um and maybe we can just one final time
as we wait for his decision just show
the lines here absolutely so if King
takes H3 this is one can consider the
main line G2
The Rook is forced to go up to F2
and now the prettiest and fastest way to
win is King E3 Rook takes G2 is forced
if you take the Rook then at a minimum
black and just make a queen with mate
coming
but after Rook takes you to this
beautiful tactical Detail King takes F3
Rook takes G7 Rook H5 checkmate
and if White's King well if white skin
goes to H1 then it's very easy black
goes G2 with a fork and if the King goes
to G1 then still G2
if you take the Rook here then takes
takes and F takes E5 with a completely
winning Rick end game just up two past
pawns uh and that forces Rook F2 and
really the only thing that Manish has to
see here is Kingdom 3 but that's a
really easy move if Knight takes C5
there is mate white is forced to give up
The Rook for the pawn oh and by the way
if uh White does nothing then there's a
beautiful idea rookie one with the same
Motif an H2 Checkmate yeah that
checkmate with the two prawns is really
very uh very cute
yeah I'm sure as Andre is thinking shall
we I don't know whether to whether we
have time to quickly take a look at the
Challenger results we've got some some a
question for you Daniel from our
producer big so we can spend the time in
that way so the question to you then is
what's the worst feeling that you need
to pee when you only have three minutes
left on the clock or that you want to
resign but your opponent is not the void
um
well I have resigned with my opponent
not at the board before I just stopped
the clock and kind of flag him down
um
um and
yeah so no wanting to pee and and not
having time is the most excruciating
feeling now I've had cases like that I
remember uh when I played the 2006 uh
under I think it was under 12 Under 12
World youth uh I had a game like that in
the third round I you know really wanted
to go to the bathroom but I was in very
acute time pressure from the opening and
I just could not afford to get up I also
didn't know where the bathroom was
um so I had to have to I had to spend
time finding it the Arbiters didn't
always speak English uh and I ended up
losing the game largely because I just
couldn't focus and uh you know it it
closely followed by a situation when
you're at the window seat of an airplane
and you don't want to wake the passenger
next to you but you're just dying to go
to the bathroom ah the worst the worst
everybody can relate to that feeling the
worst indeed and Danny I think we're
just that this game is about to conclude
because Andre has taken the pawn on H3
and after G2 I think there will just be
no no way to even prolong the game as
mate becomes inevitable
well the only thing the only Pitfall is
and you just Define King E3 that move is
relatively obvious but you know it can
be missed you have to see this idea of
King E3 and then Rook takes you to King
takes a three the thing is banished had
three minutes I would allow for the
possibility that he doesn't play it with
28 minutes he's already probably seen it
uh but he's going to take as long as it
as long as he needs to to hammer it out
he's not gonna go Rook G3 here because
if you go Rook G3 you have to win the
game again Rook takes F3 King G2 and
this is a winning Recon game but it's
it's a hassle it's a it's a big big
hassle and I think it's the Hassan he
himself wants to save himself we saw him
give a couple of stairs there there's
the thirds there uh in the direction of
Andrea cipenko and I agree with you I
think he has already seen it and it will
be delivered uh shortly and that will
probably Force the resignation
yep
and you can see the discipline all these
top players they have tremendous
discipline they never rush it they take
as long as they need as long as it takes
to verify Beyond any Shadow of Doubt uh
that the line they have in mind is
winning here's Anish adopting the prayer
stance
Beth Harmon style making the final
calculations and we are about to seeking
E3 yeah King A3 uh I think will appear
on the board and once again I mean I've
been talking a lot about you got the
feel for for yesterday panko but for a
niche this will be three on the on the
Trot do you say that in U.S
never heard of that maybe I'm making it
up I'm sure the the chat
will either confirm or debunk my my
claim here it sounds real it sounds like
something a British expression yeah not
very good for the person I think the
church is like Tagalog no it's like
Anyway thankfully Anish making the Move
kingy Free yep with confidence and I
think Andre actually might even allow
Checkmate to happen on the board which
uh far from being unethical is sometimes
a gracious way uh to allow the player to
naturally complete a great game but you
also might resign here
it is all over games thanks
well very very nice combination Dania I
had some time to to Google Tree on the
Trot isn't that's not it but on the Trot
is an expression which means
consecutively so I'm kind of tree on the
Trot I think it's okay I think we can
allow it we're all alone I mean look
somebody had to be the first one to use
an expression who's to say who has a
monopoly on creating expressions
um I always it's funny I really like the
expression a day but I always get it
confused it's this question is basically
see even now I'm getting confused a day
late and a dollar short
and I always say A Dollar Late and a day
short and people like to make fun of me
for that
that's also not an expression that we
use too much in Europe by things so it's
funny really how the the idioms uh
change
cried a lot maybe I could change it to a
day later in a euro short
that sounds a lot better right Vic also
has his favorite expression I don't ask
for a light to load I ask for a stronger
back
wow that's deep
yeah well that's like the George Burnett
shot quote I think you know like the
adapting to the world it's like the
series of quotes that have the same
structure like asking out what you can
do what your country can do for you ask
what you can do for your country
um or like the strong expect the world
to adapt to them you know or the weak
and then the strong adapts to the world
it's like those inverted quotes I always
like the way those expressions sound
for sure and we've got the very uh
philosophical here but extremely well
Andre is sitting there and contemplating
the meaning of life they both look like
they're contemplating the meaning of
life and
uh Andre is asking what this position
can do for him
and getting no answer
but what can you do for this position
also nothing he can resign and the
position is indeed and I think we just
missed the handshake uh so a resignation
after King E3 congratulations to Ani
schweather game flandre yesipenko uh a
devastating uh loss but he is so young
as well he will be back and we see the
players there discussing probably maybe
even what was going on in the opening
it was a very complex very interesting
game with a theoretical segment and
Andre he is going to be kicking himself
tonight he's going to be replaying that
over and over again that made the draw
could have been watching football
all throughout the last three and a half
hours but we have to get tip our hats to
him you know he went for it that was a
very gutsy decision it didn't pay off
this time but Andreas Van Gogh has all
of the qualities of a super GM and his
career really is only beginning so he's
gonna recover he's got a half of the
tournament left uh to bounce back from
this loss and that is the final game of
the master section Fiona another very
interesting day with three decisive
rounds just like yesterday I believe
indeed I thought that maybe we were in
for a quiet today as the rest day is
coming up tomorrow but the players
didn't hold anything back Dania we're
going to go on a short break after that
we will be back well first let's look at
the results of the day with Anish Gary
we still see the players discussing the
game in the background beating Andreas
panko with the black pieces
to join Magnus Carlsen in the lead who
Magnus he was held by Samsung Island and
visit Gujarati bouncing back from his
last year then in the best possible way
by beating Niels gandalius who
unfortunately is still struggling in
this tournament but Dania how are the
things looking at the top
soccer yard with a big win has joined
Magnus atop the tournament standings
they've both got five and a half out of
eight and we see very close behind the
Manish writing SRI on the try Anish on
the truck with five out of eight closely
and widget as well with it with an
excellent game uh we might hear more
about that game after the break we've
got four and a half out of eight rehard
report on plus one and then a big group
with 50 Fabi kariak and asapankov and
Forest all of them are going to have to
take a lot of risks in the second half
of the tournament they've got some
catching up to do and in the case of
Fabby he is still definitely thinking
about winning the tournament so that's
gonna add a fascinating angle uh to how
the final rounds of this tournament are
going to look for sure plenty to look
forward to but for now we aren't done
just yet we will be back with your daily
rapid recap as well as with the pairings
for the day after but first we'll take a
quick break so don't go anywhere
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to Tata steel and round
eight is in the books and now it is time
for your daily rapid recap and the game
we are going to focus on today is the
battle between vidit and Niels
grandellis was an absolutely fascinating
game Fiona with so many interesting
moments and tactical nuances absolutely
visit he lost the previous day to Jordan
van ferry so it was interesting to see
how was he gonna Advance back Niels
quandelios not had the best start to the
tournament and it looked like a village
he sprung this first surprise in the
opening
he really did this move Knight BD knight
bd2 uh not a very common line the idea
is to play E4 and transpose the game
into a perk and against D5 generally
white plays this really interesting move
B4 this is a cool line to explore but uh
Neil's deciding to stick with the perk
and allow that transposition and here
Fiona normally black plays D6 but Niels
castled and perhaps he started to regret
this move very shortly thereafter yeah
because by castling he allowed vidit to
go E5 which is just what video did and
after the knight jump to H5 here comes
at the Jeep on G4 appeared on the board
with it later in the interview revealed
this was all prepped he didn't say how
deep it went but what a move done here
G4 just so bold it is of course Very
weakening but he figures that his
initiative is going to be well worth it
and now when the Knight jumps out to E4
another attack on the night and one
funny line is that if the Knight drops
back to E6 white goes D5 and the Knight
simply has no squares so Neil's forced
to make a counter-attacking move if he
goes Knight D5 then white can just
continue tossing the Knight around this
gets worse and worse so a very inventive
resource counter-resource by Niels
grendelius and hear another important
moment white shouldn't take on D6 uh
because after Knight D5 if you just
gobble up the pawns this is
extraordinarily dangerous for white
because of the pressure down the e-file
in fact this position is simply losing
and so vidit demonstrated a lot of
restraint uh and went for the move
Knight G3 after D5 and Fiona the next
moment was really really interesting
what he did after 96. for sure not a
move that was on my radar for sure video
pictures through the night forward to F5
where it looks at First Sight like what
are you doing black can simply captured
at night but G takes uh doesn't work at
least it's not as good as it seems at
First Sight because after white
recaptures the Knight on E6 is trapped
indeed it's trapped and White's gonna
put a rook on G1 here Black's King is
kind of toast in this position and so uh
Neil's correctly refrained from that
instead choosing to Counter-Strike in
the center but now vidit used that
Knight and exchanged it for nielsenketto
Bishop never a particularly encouraging
thing to have to face Knight takes G7
and now it taking the time to defend the
pawn on G4
C takes D4 and now that now another very
impressive move Bishop H6 didn't
realizes that he doesn't actually need
to rush uh to recapture the pawn it's a
lot more important to position his
pieces well and that Bishop is really a
bone in Black's throat Neil's deciding
to transition the game into an end game
he gives a check uh and after Queen
takes D2 Knight takes you to Fiona we
were impressed uh during the game with
the fact that vidit really didn't care
about recapturing that pawn at all was a
lot more important for him to build up
the pawn Mass on the king side great
Forward Thinking for a minute indeed he
understood that pawn on D4 is going
nowhere I can win that back any moment I
like and we saw in the game after Knight
C6 as you just highlighted and now with
it he is in time to play afro defend his
important Central Pawn uh on E5 and
Niels now making a move we thought it
was necessary but not a move you want to
make F6
yeah I mean he tries to get himself a
little bit of space I mean if black had
gone without it then white would have
repositioned the Knight Castle Queen
side and then reclaimed that pawn with
tremendous interest but it turns out
that even after the trade uh Black's
task defensive task is extremely
difficult uh vitted castling Queen side
and now an absolutely fascinating moment
so Niels plays rookie eight and here it
was important for vivid uh to start with
the move Bishop G2
uh Force the bishop to come out to E6
and only now play the move Knight B3 but
Vida decides to transpose the move order
that doesn't seem particularly
significant he plays Knight B3 first and
there was no harm no foul uh grandelius
played 96 and went Bishop G2 but Fiona
there was an absolutely incredible
resource that was overlooked by both
players here an incredible resource and
that move is Bishop F5 and that's where
all the difference comes from here once
again a piece seems to be just hanging
but if white were to capture the bishop
then after a knight takes the bishop on
H6 is lost and the idea of course behind
Bishop F5 is to bring the bishop to that
all-important square on e4
indeed and that works out in case white
takes on G7 black still plays Bishop
before The Rook is hanging white has to
deal with that and this position is
probably not even worse for black due to
the strength of that Bishop perhaps I
could keep a small Advantage with the
computer move Bishop B5 but it would
definitely be nothing more than the
tiniest of advantages this was a massive
missed opportunity but can you really
blame them kneels going full passive
defense 96 Bishop G2 the Knight has to
reposition to C7 and now vidit deciding
to move in with F5 he could have taken
on D4 but going for a very gutsy and
interesting decision ripping open
Black's King position G takes F5 and now
Rook F1 another important moment black
could have taken on G4 and then taken on
H3 and apparently black could have
survived this position but man oh man
can you blame Niels for not wanting to
go for this position absolutely not that
black king looks in a world of pain so
no surprise that Niels did not capture
instead he went King F7 trying to get
the king out of Harm's Way now of course
vidit simply recaptures and Neil's
trying to activate his work along the
g-file
indeed Rock today but that's pretty
nicely parried but not very nicely
paired as it turns out Rook D2 is an
inaccuracy and for the second time in
the game Niels had the possibility of
capturing an F5 a move that might have
been overlooked by both players this
time the idea is to play King G6 working
the bishop and the rook and although
white is undoubtedly still better after
Rook F2 I think that this would have
given Neil's very very good chances to
save the game he's still up a pawn and a
Lion's Share of White's Advantage has
evaporated for that reason it was better
for Reddit to actually tuck the bishop
away on H1 which would have given him
the possibility of delivering a check on
G1 there at the right moment but this
was also missed by Niels who plays 95
centralizing his Knight another natural
move but after a minute reclaims the
plan uh Fiona he eliminates all of Lex
counter playing and we were impressed
with vidit's patience he spends the next
part of the game just slowly but surely
improving his position
although material was uh even at this
stage Village has kept improving his
pieces and Neil's sadly his piece is so
crammed difficult to find counter play
and look at with it he's just bringing
first the bishop back into the game
playing uh Rook F2 to defend the bishop
on G2 and then finally improving the
last piece out comes the king
out comes the king and he's threatening
to go all the way to C5 that strains
Black's pieces even further anneals out
of desperation he finds a pretty nice
idea he's trying to get this Knight all
the way over to E4 and uh vidit
immediately responds with the move C4
boom time the moment the Knight leaves
uh its post he attacks the pawn on D5
and at this point Niels was already in
very serious time pressure and in this
position he collapses can't really blame
him the only way to stay in the game was
to return to C7 reinforce this Pawn as
much as one can and here that it would
have still had to work quite hard in
order to win the game the computer
indicates the very nice move Bishop F1
that's actually a prophylactic move
reinforcing the C4 upon if black takes
on C4 then white can take on C6 and when
everything is said and done at the end
of this line white plays Bishop takes E5
and the point of Bishop F1 is revealed
either Bishop takes C4 or Rook D7 check
and guess what if the bishop had been on
G2 in this position it would have been
hanging so bringing the bishop away make
sure that this line does win a piece
this would have been practically
speaking losing for black but after
something like A5 uh black could have
stayed in the game for a couple or more
moves but nil's panicking going Knight
G7 and Fiona it was all over now
indeed I have to visit captured at the
bishop on C6 the black position just
falls apart now with it instantly he
took on on D5 and there's just too many
uh threats here against the the black
king and Rook everything is falling
apart Niels tried a rook to d8
but resigned after a visit simply
captured on C6 if the trade on D2
happens uh Vivid can choose whichever
piece he wants to recapture with but
white now has two extra pawns and the C
Pawn is only two squares away from
cleaning so Dania what a game by visit
an incredible game so smooth and a
wonderful opening you know all of those
ideas with G4 it might have been
preparation but still so creative and
then the way that he transitioned into
the end game it wasn't Flawless but by
and large he demonstrated patience when
he needed to be patient patient decisive
play when he needed to be decisive and
both of the very endlessly improved
disposition slowly and then pouncing at
the right moment with C4 video bouncing
back from a painful loss to Jordan
benforest yesterday scoring a win and
getting back to the top quadrant of the
field a great game by minute today
indeed Kudos two with it and that was
your rapid recap of the day to conclude
the action here what a day it has been
done yeah we just saw this game here in
more detail once again we had two other
wins elsewhere giri are grinding out a
long-end game against the acipenko who
blundered in the end and of beating
pregnant and that to join me Magnus
Carlson in the lead let's have another
look at the standings before we wrap up
here
indeed we have Carlson and mamad yarov
atop the standings with five and a half
out of eight closely followed by Geary
and vidit who of course scored that win
today report the only other player with
a plus score and then a big group with
50 and as we talked about earlier those
players the Peloton their report karwana
kayak and they're gonna make a big push
I can guarantee it in the next couple of
rounds speaking of which let's have a
look at round nine pairings which will
happen after the rest day tomorrow Fiona
some really interesting matchups and I
think there's only one place we can
start here that is at the very bottom
where Magnus Carlson we see he will be
taking on shot they tried to hide the
pairing from us
I know it's ridiculous this is Bix doing
but the two leaders are playing what are
the odds the two leaders are playing
exactly when we need them to play Fiona
Magnus of the white pieces he is playing
all guns blazing he wants to win this
game for sure we heard from a media of
Magnus has a good plus score against uh
against Shaq he wasn't sure how much is
it is it plus five is it plus six now
the pairing is gone that is definitely
Vicks doing what else do we have and to
look forward to Anish Geary he won three
on the Trot he will be playing some
Shanklin next and with the white pieces
he will be looking to make it uh four we
have Jordan van for race against dubov
two members of Team Carson will be very
interesting to see them facing off and
what else Dania
yeah and and grendelius carwana is a big
game for Fabi who sits on 50 and he is
playing a struggling Niels grendelius he
has to play for a win today was a pretty
disappointing game for him as he never
really got off the ground against Jordan
van Forrest excellent preparation so
keep an eye out as Fabi uh tries perhaps
to play in a more risky fashion than
usual report and vid it oh that is going
to be an explosive match of both of them
in great form vidit on five out of eight
he's gonna try to keep his positive
momentum going and of course Prague
always fun to watch as he faces off
against Sergey karyakin who also sits at
50 and also will be playing for a win
with the black pieces but don't tune in
tomorrow Fiona right yes so much to look
forward to but not tomorrow uh us to our
producer the players you guys out there
everyone gets a rest day to take a deep
breath and then so many exciting
matchups to look forward when we return
on January 25th which round nine it will
be the usual starting time 2 p.m Central
European Time at 5 a.m on the Pacific
coast and Dania it's been an absolutely
uh tremendous day of Chess a big thank
you to you big thanks to everyone
watching us today and I'll leave you the
closing words
absolutely Fiona well this was an
absolute pleasure as as usual uh so fun
to commentate with you in these games
they were explosive we had all sorts of
openings today we had every single
player uh playing for a win whether or
not the game ended decisively or in a
drop and games middle games attacks and
everything in between this is why we
watched and this is why classical chess
is awesome what around it was this web
Buy in a Flash and we want to thank of
course uh everybody in the chat and
twitch and YouTube and thousands of you
who are cheering on your favorite player
and I have to begrudgingly thank the
producer Vic yep he does do a fantastic
job I just realized let's also give one
thanks to our moderators who are working
so hard every day to keep the chat nice
and in order so a big shout out to you
guys and of course everyone working
behind the scenes Dania it's been a
pleasure I'll see you two days from now
have a good one everyone we'll see you
then
goodbye
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]